ASSEMBLY JUDICIARY TODAY'S
TUESDAY APRIL TWENTY THIRD WE DO
NOT YET HAVE A QUORUM HOWEVER.
WHICH WILL START AS A SUB
COMMITTEE.
WE DO HAVE A NUMBER OF AUTHORS
PRESENCE AND WE WILL START WITH.
I DON'T NUMBER THIRTEEN MISTER
LOW.
THIS IS AB.
FIVE THIRTEEN FORTY TWO GOOD
MORNING THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS THIS IS
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTEEN FORTY TWO
WITH RESPECT TO THE SALE OF
NONPROFIT COLLEGES.
AT THAT SIMPLY OF REQUIRES THAT
WE HAVE THE TYPE OF OVERSIGHT OF
FOR THE SALE OF NON PROFIT --
I'M THE FOR PROFIT COLLEGES OF
THIS ARE QUITE ATTORNEY GENERAL
TO APPROVE WHATEVER A FOR PROFIT
COLLEGE.
SEEKS A TO BE SOLD AND WE LOOK
FOR THE TYPE OF PROTECTIONS IN
TRANSPARENCY FOR THE STUDENTS
THAT MIGHT BE ASSOCIATED WITH
THE IMPACT.
OF THIS TYPE OF TRANSACTION WITH
RESPECT ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND YES THIS IS TO
PASS OKAY PERFECT YOUR FIRST
WITNESS PLACER HI I'M BOB
SHERMAN I'M A SENIOR FELLOW AT
THE CENTURY FOUNDATION.
I'VE WORKED -- IN THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION AND THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION -- AND AND IT
OTHER FEDERAL AND AT FEDERAL
POSTS ON HIGHER EDUCATION.
HAVE BEEN FOLLOWING THE ISSUE OF
TORY FOR PROFIT COLLEGES -- FOR
FOR ALMOST THIRTY YEARS.
AND MANY OF THE WORST ABUSES
THAT WE HAVE SEEN -- HAVE COME
FROM.
COLLEGES THAT HAD BEEN NONPROFIT
HAD BUILT A POSITIVE REPUTATION
AND THEN WERE PURCHASED BY A FOR
PROFIT.
COMPANY THAT USE THAT REPUTATION
TO BRING IN STUDENTS BUT ENDED
UP RUNNING THE RUNNING THE
COMPANY INTO THE GROUND RUNNING
THE COLLEGE INTO THE GROUND AND
IN THAT ATTEMPT. TO PUMP UP THE
STOCK PRICE.
OR R. OR LARGE PROFITS SO IN THE
CASE OF ASHFORD IT HAD BEEN A
SMALL NONPROFIT RESIDENTIAL
COLLEGE AND BECAME AN EIGHTY
THOUSAND STUDENTS -- ONLINE
COLLEGE THAT IS NOW BEING SUED
BY THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY
GENERAL -- IN THE CASE OF HEALED
IN CALIFORNIA IT WAS A LONG TIME
QUALITY -- NONPROFIT COLLEGE
SURVEYING WORKING ADULTS WAS
PURCHASED BY CORINTHIAN COLLEGES
AND FAMOUSLY COLLAPSED --
LEAVING MANY STUDENTS WHO HAD
PORTENDING THOSE COLLEGES HIGH
AND DRY LEAVING TAXPAYERS WITH
THAT BILL SO THIS BILL WILL HELP
TO ASSURE THAT WHEN THE WHEN
COLLEGES GO FROM NONPROFIT TO
FOR PROFIT THAT THOSE ASSETS ARE
REATED.
APPROPRIATELY THAT THERE AREN'T
ANY PAY OFFS INVOLVED TO THE
NONPROFIT OFFICIALS -- AND AND
TO DO WHAT WE CAN ANY. TO HELP
ENSURE THAT -- THAT THEN THEY
OPERATE IN A NON PREDATORY WAY.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITE OF YES.
HI ANGELA PERRY POLICY ANALYST
WITH THE INSTITUTE FOR COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT THING THEN IS THERE
ANY OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
MARKETING THEN MR THOUGH YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH CHECK
FAST BY ABOUT THANK YOU AND WE
WILL TAKE IT UP BUT FORGET FOR
WHICH HOPEFULLY SHOULD BE.
IMMINENT ALRIGHT THANK YOU
MISTER FRAZIER HEY.
WE ARE.
THAT MOVIE THE ITEM.
NUMBER SEVEN WHICH IS AB.
EIGHT THIRTEEN AND LET'S PAUSE
FOR A MOMENT AND ESTABLISH A
QUORUM.
STONE HERE GALLAGHER.
CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
NORRIS [inaudible]
REYES.
THANK YOU SO WE DO HAVE A QUORUM
LET'S SEE IF WE COULD TAKE UP A
MOTION ON ITEM NUMBER THIRTEEN
A. B. THIRTEEN FORTY TWO LOW.
THANK YOU THAT IS A MOTION TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
MEMBERS PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER CHAU.
CHAO I CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN [inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS ADDRESS.
REYES AYE.
THANK YOU AND I WILL ALSO
ANNOUNCE THAT ITEM NUMBER ONE AB
ONE NINETY NINE HAS BEEN PULLED
FROM THE AGENDA SO A. B. ITEM
NUMBER THIRTEEN AB.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO IS OUT THANK
YOU.
MISTER FRAZIER AB EIGHT THIRTEEN
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR IN THE
MORNING MEMBERS.
FIRST I WOULD LIKE TO ACCEPT THE
COULD A MEMBERS RECOMMENDED BY
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR WORKING WITH US ON
THANK YOU ON THOSE.
AB EIGHT THIRTEEN PROPOSES A
ALTERNATIVE APPEALS PROCEDURE
THAT WILL PLACE DISPUTE
RESOLUTION RESOURCES.
INSIDE THE REGIONAL CENTER.
IT WILL OFFER EXHAUSTED PARENTS
A MORE ACCESSIBLE RESOURCE WHEN
DENIED SERVICES.
WHAT PEOPLE DON'T REALIZE THAT
OVER THE DECADES OF THE REGIONAL
CENTER HAS BEEN IN SERVICE?
THAT SINCE.
NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN THEY'RE
NOT EVEN NOW THAT NOW THESE ARE
NOT EVEN SHOWING WHAT --
SERVICES ARE EVEN OFFERED.
WE HAD THE BIGGER REGIONAL
SERVICE THEY'RE ACTUALLY PUT IT
ON THEIR WEBSITE WHAT SERVICES
THAT PARENTS MAY QUALIFY FOR
THEIR CHILD -- AS THE CHAIR OF
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
I'VE HEARD FROM FAMILIES AROUND
THE STATE AT OUR HEARINGS.
TIME AND TIME AGAIN I HEAR FROM
PARENTS EXPRESSING THEIR
FRUSTRATION ABOUT.
THE BROKEN SYSTEM. FOR THOSE
WITH ADD WHO COME FROM SINGLE
PARENT HOUSEHOLDS WHICH IS.
A VERY PREVALENT THE MORTALITY
RATE A MARRIAGES HE IS
ABSOLUTELY DEVASTATING A WHEN
YOU HAVE AN ID DE CHILD -- ON%
SINGLE PARENT HOUSEHOLDS OR LOW
INCOME FAMILIES APPEALS ARE
VIRTUALLY IMPOSSIBLE.
IF A PARENT DOESN'T HAVE A
FLEXIBLE WORK SCHEDULE OR IF
THEY HAVE A LANGUAGE BARRIER OR
IF IRAQ -- LACK RELIABLE
TRANSPORTATION THEY HAVE
ABSOLUTELY NO CHANCE.
AB THIRTEEN WILL GIVE EVERY
CLIENT WITH I. DG A FIGHTING
CHANCE TO GET THE SERVICES THEY
NEED.
WE HAD A WITNESS TODAY AND OUT.
I APOLOGIZE SHE CAME DOWN WITH
FOOD POISONING LAST NIGHT.
AND SO -- I'M HERE BY MYSELF AND
HOPEFULLY THERE'S THANK YOU WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
YOUR CARING IT VERY FINE BY
YOURSELF RECOGNITION.
SELF THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE
LIKE TO SPEAK AND SUPPORTS
[inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
I'M DELFIN CATHCART REPRESENTING
EMILY ALL OF CALIFORNIA.
WE ARE FIVE FOR FIVE AFFILIATES
IN CALIFORNIA'S SAN JOAQUIN
COUNTY FORCES THE NEED IS.
SAN DIEGO COUNTY JUSTICE
OVERCOMING BOUNDARIES SACRAMENTO
COUNTY -- CAPITAL REGION OCT
ORGANISE ISAAC PROJECT CINEMA
COUNTY.
BAY AREA ORGANIZING PROJECT.
ALAMEDA COUNTY GENESIS WE
SUPPORT AB THIRTEEN AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU.
NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALRIGHT SING NUNS THAT -- I'M
SORRY.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS MOHAMMED RASHID I'M
FROM VALLEY MOUNTAIN REGIONAL
CENTER AND WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR COMING
OUT THIS MORNING.
WHAT ELSE IN SUPPORT?
CNN IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
NOT OPPOSITION BUT DANIEL
SAVANNAH ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL
CENTER AGENCIES WE LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH THE
AUTHOR ON WAYS TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE CAN ACCESS THE SERVICES
THEY NEED.
WITH AN EXISTING MECHANISMS AND
WELL AS WELL AS LOOKING FOR
OPPORTUNITIES.
TO REFINE AND IMPROVE THOSE WERE
NEEDED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OR OTHERWISE.
ALRIGHT SIGNIN QUESTIONS
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ALL RIGHT.
SING NOT MISTER FRAZIER MAKE
CLOTHES THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
JUST RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU AND GIVE OUR BEST
YOUR WITNESS SORRY THAT THE I'M
SORRY.
CAME DOWN.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS TO
AS AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS I RE AS REYES AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT MISTER LEVINE YOU HAVE
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN A. B.
THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR AND AS HE
COMES UP I'LL TAKE A MOTION ON
THE CONSENT AGENDA UNLESS
SOMEONE WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE AN
ITEM FROM THE SENATE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE.
BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
HI MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I'D PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THOSE BILLS ARE OUT THAT IS AB
FORTY SIX CARILLO AB TWO EIGHTY
NINE FONG A BEFORE FORTY SIX
CHOI AB EIGHT NINETY TWO HOLDEN
AB.
TEN SIXTY EIGHT COOLEY AB ELEVEN
SIXTEEN GRAYSON A LATE AB ELEVEN
SEVENTEEN GRAYSON AB ELEVEN
THIRTY TO GABRIEL AND AB
SEVENTEEN THIRTY SEVEN OBERNOLTE.
ALL RIGHT.
THANKS YOUR PATIENCE MISTER
LEVINE THANK YOU SO MUCH MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS I WOULD LIKE TO
BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
SUGGESTED AMENDMENTS SAYS
AUTHORED AMENDMENTS AND THANK
THE COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK ON
THIS IMPORTANT ISSUE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR REQUIRES
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
SOCIAL SERVICES TO CONTRACT WITH
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRANT LEGAL SERVICES TO
UNDOCUMENTED MINORS AND NON
MINERS CURRENTLY IN FOSTER CARE.
WHAT CALIFORNIA ALREADY REQUIRES
THE UNACCOMPANIED UNDOCUMENTED
MINORS WHO ARE TRANSFERRED TO
THE CARE AND CUSTODY OF THE
OFFICE OF REFUGEE RESETTLEMENT
BE PROVIDED WITH LEGAL SERVICES?
THIS PROTECTION DOES NOT EXTEND
TO UNDOCUMENTED MINORS OR NON
MINORS IN CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER
CARE SYSTEM AB THIRTEEN TWENTY
FOUR WILL ENSURE THAT
UNDOCUMENTED DEPENDENCE IN
CALIFORNIA'S FOSTER CARE SYSTEM
ARE PROVIDED WITH ESSENTIAL
IMMIGRATION LEGAL SERVICES
NECESSARY. TO SEEK LAWFUL
RESIDENCY IN THE UNITED STATES
THERE IS NO OPPOSITION TO THIS
BILL I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE.
WITH ME TODAY IS SUSAN ABRAMS
THE POLICY DIRECTOR. FOR THE
CHILDREN'S LAWCENTER OF
CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE
THE MORNING CHAIR AN HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE.
HI MY NAME IS SUSAN ABRAMS AND
I'M WITH THE CHILDREN'S
LAWCENTER OF CALIFORNIA WE
REPRESENT THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
CHILDREN IN THE FOSTER CARE
SYSTEM IN SACRAMENTO PLASTER.
IN LOS ANGELES COUNTY -- I WANT
TO START BY THINKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LEVINE. FOR AUTHORING
THIS IMPORTANT LEGISLATION WHICH
WILL SERVE TO PROTECT
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN FOSTER
CARE BY PROVIDING ACCESS TO
LEGAL IMMIGRATION SERVICES.
MOST UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN IN
FOSTER CARE QUALIFY FOR
IMMIGRATION RELIEF THROUGH
SPECIAL IMMIGRANT JUVENILE
STATUS ALSO REFER TO ASSIDUOUS.
THIS WAS ENACTED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT IN NINETEEN NINETY
TWO ALLOW ABUSED ABANDONED AND
NEGLECTED UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN
TO ATTAIN LAWFUL PERMANENT
RESIDENCY.
AND ENTERED PROVIDE GREATER
STABILITY FOR THESE YOUNG PEOPLE
HOWEVER IN TODAY'S POLITICAL
CLIMATE THIS RELIEF IS DIFFICULT.
TO OBTAIN WITHOUT LEGAL
ASSISTANCE AND THERE'S NO
MECHANISM RIGHT NOW TO ENSURE
THAT CHILDREN IN FOSTER CARE
RECEIVE THIS LEGAL RESEARCH.
ASSISTANTS AND AS A RESULT SOME
CHILDREN NEVER RECEIVED THE
RELIEF TO WHICH THEY ARE
ENTITLED.
UNDOCUMENTED CHILDREN WHO EXIT
FOSTER CARE WITHOUT APPLYING FOR
SIEGES OR ANOTHER FORM OF RELIEF
WILL BE UNABLE TO WORK AND
TRANSITION TO SUCCESSFUL
ADULTHOOD WE ARE SETTING THESE
YOUTH UP FOR FAILURE.
AB THIRTEEN TWENTY FOUR WILL
ADDRESS THISSIGNIFICANT ISSUE
IN TWO WAYS.
FIRST IT WILL REQUIRE NOTICE TO
MINORS COUNCIL.
OF ANY IMMIGRATION ISSUES SO WE
CAN WORK TO ENSURE OUR CLIENTS
GET THE SUPPORT THEY NEED.
AND SECOND IT WILL CREATE A
FUNDING SOURCE WITHIN THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF SOCIAL
SERVICES TO CONTRACT WITH
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICE
ORGANIZATIONS TO PROVIDE
IMMIGRATION REPRESENTATION WE
URGE YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
CRITICAL LEGISLATION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
RAIN OR ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING SEAN CHILDREN WITH
THE ALLIANCE FOR CHILDREN'S
RIGHTS FOR IN SUPPORT THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I THINK NONE OF BRING BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SINGER MISCELLANY MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS THIS IS -- APRIL IS
CHILD ABUSE AWARENESS MONTH AND
THIS IS A SMALL WAY THAT WE CAN
HELP PROTECT CHILDREN WHO -- ARE
VICTIMS OF ABUSE THAT ARE IN THE
CARE IN CALIFORNIA AND THAT WE
CAN PROTECT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SO I STILL NEED A MOTION MOTIONS
TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
COVER AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU MISTER
NUMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MS COME UNDER DUFF THIS TAKES US
TO ITEM NUMBER TWO A. B..
TWO FORTY TWO THANK YOU WE DO A
MOTION IS THEIR SECOND.
AND THE SECOND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBER.
I AM HERE PRESENTING ASSEMBLY
BILL TWO FOUR TWO WHICH WILL
REQUIRE ATTORNEYS AND JUDGES TO
PARTY PARTAKE IN CONTINUAL
EDUCATION ON IMPLICIT BIAS.
EVERY THREE YEARS AND COURT
PERSONNEL EVERY TWO YEARS.
THE BIAS IS THE UNCONSCIOUS AND
UNINTENTIONAL MENTAL SHORT CUT
THAT HUMAN BEINGS CAN DEVELOP
AND IT AFFECTS US ALL.
IT IS OFTEN SUBTLE ASSOCIATIONS
WE MAKE BETWEEN GROUPS OF PEOPLE
AND STEREO TYPES ABOUT THOSE
GROUPS.
WE KNOW THAT EXPLICIT BIAS
PERSISTS LIKE RACISM SEXISM AND
OTHER FORMS OF BIGOTRY AND AS A
RESULT CLEAR ANTI DISCRIMINATION
LAWS ARE IN PLACE TO HELP CHECK
THOSE.
MOST OF US WOULD LIKE TO BE FREE
OF BIASES ATTITUDES AND
STEREOTYPES THAT LEAD US TO
JUDGE PEOPLE BASED ON THE SOCIAL
CATEGORIES THEY BELONG TO SUCH
AS RACE OR GENDER OR SEXUAL
ORIENTATION.
HOWEVER IT IS IMPORTANT THAT WE
COME TO TERMS WITH THE FACT THAT
EVERYONE HAS THEIR OWN
UNCONSCIOUS AN IMPLICIT BIAS
THESE AND THOSE ARE EQUALLY
IMPACTFUL.
DESPITE PEOPLE'S BEST INTENTIONS
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
SUBJECTS CAN CONSCIOUSLY EMBRACE
IDEAS OF FAIRNESS AND EQUALITY
AND YET ON TESTS THAT MEASURE
SUBCONSCIOUS TENDENCIES STILL
SHOW A STRONG PROPENSITY TO LEAN
ON STEREO TYPES TO FILL IN THE
BLANKS ABOUT PEOPLE THEY DON'T
KNOW.
IT IS CRITICAL THAT ATTORNEYS
JUDGES AND COURT PERSONNEL
RECEIVE TRAINING ON A ROUTINE
BASIS TO RECOGNIZE THEIR
IMPLICIT BIAS THESE AND TAKES
STEPS TO COUNTER ACT THEIR
UNCONSCIOUS INFLUENCES.
WHEN PEOPLE ENTER INTO A COURT
ROOM OR ENCOUNTER THE COURT
SYSTEM?
THEY'RE HOPEFUL FOR EQUAL
EQUITABLE AND FAIR TREATMENT
THEY ARE PUTTING THEIR LIVES
THEIR FAMILIES AND THEIR FUTURES
ON THE LINE IN IN THE TRUST OF
THE COURT.
AND YET UNCONSCIOUS AND IMPLICIT
BIAS HE'S CAN AND DO AFFECT THE
DAY TO DAY DECISION MAKING
PROCESS THESE OF EVEN THE MOST
AWARE COURT OFFICERS.
YET CHANGE CAN COME THROUGH
EDUCATION INTERACTION AND
CONVERSATION.
IN THE STATE OF JUDICIARY
ADDRESS LAST MONTH SUPREME COURT
CHIEF JUSTICE TANI CONCEAL
SOCCER WAY RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE AND EXPRESSED SUPPORT
FOR IMPLICIT BIAS TRAINING FOR
JUDGES.
AN UNCONSCIOUS BIAS TRAINING
MANDATORY FOR ALL COURT
ADMINISTRATIVE EMPLOYEES.
I WOULD LIKE TO BUILD A CULTURE
THAT CONSTANTLY AND RESPECTFULLY
ADDRESSES BIAS TO STRENGTHEN THE
TRUST BETWEEN OFFICERS OF THE
COURT IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
AB TWO FOUR TWO SIX TO AMPLIFY
THE SUPREME COURT.
CHIEF JUSTICES WORK ON IMPLICIT
BIAS AND MANDATE THAT JUDGES AND
ATTORNEYS MUST BE TRAINED EVERY
THREE YEARS AND COURT PERSONNEL
EVERY TWO YEARS.
TODAY WITH ME AND SUPPORT IS
KIMBERLY PAPPY ON JUDICIAL
PROFESSOR AND LISA HOLDER EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY LEGAL DIRECTOR
THANK YOU THANK YOU AND IS
COVERED OF THERE ARE AMENDMENTS
LISTED IN THE IT ALSO SAVES WHO
YOUR TAKING THOSE -- YES WE ARE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND THANK
YOU FOR THE WORK OF THE
COMMITTEE ON ENERGY ABOUT.
THE FIRST WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING I'M LISA HOLDER A
CIVIL RIGHTS ATTORNEY AND UCLA
LAW LECTURER UNCONSTITUTIONAL
POLICING SKIP TO SPEAK.
WE GET THIS IS A RECORD THANK
YOU OKAY.
I AM GRATEFUL TO BE HERE THIS
MORNING ADDRESSING THIS AUGUST
BODY OF LAWMAKERS.
AND I ADDRESS YOU TODAY IN MY
CAPACITY AS INTERIM LEGAL
DIRECTOR OF THE EQUAL JUSTICE
SOCIETY.
AND OAKLAND BASED.
RACIAL JUSTICE ADVOCACY GROUP.
THE EQUAL JUSTICE SOCIETY IS
TRANSFORMING THE NATION'S
CONSCIOUSNESS ON RACE THROUGH
LITIGATION SOCIAL SCIENCE AND
THE ARTS.
AND FOR TWENTY YEARS SINCE ITS
INCEPTION.
ALONG WITH ITS THOUGHT PARTNERS
A NETWORK OF JUDGES ATTORNEYS
SCIENTISTS.
UP.
SCIENTISTS AND ACADEMICS THE
EAGLE JUST JUST THE SOCIETY HAS
BEEN RESEARCHING AND ANALYZING
IMPLICIT BIAS AND THE WAY THAT
IT IMPACTS INDIVIDUALS.
AND THE INSTITUTIONS OPERATED
AND CREATED BY INDIVIDUALS.
WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT THE
WORK THAT WE'VE DONE ON THIS
BILL WHEN I TALK TO PEOPLE ABOUT
THE WORK THAT I DO AN IMPLICIT
BIAS?
SO MANY OF THEM SAY OH THAT'S
GREAT WORK ON I APPLAUD YOU BUT
I DON'T HAVE BIAS.
WELL ALL PEOPLE HAVE IMPLICIT
BIAS.
ALL PEOPLE HAVE UNCONSCIOUS
BIASES.
THAT THEY CANNOT CONTROL WITHOUT
ASSISTANCE AND INTERVENTIONS.
OUR BIASES DEVELOPED DURING THE
COURSE OF A LIFETIME THROUGH
EXPOSURE TO STEREOTYPES.
AN IMPLICIT BIAS.
INFLUENCES.
NOT ONLY OUR BELIEFS BUT OUR
ATTITUDES AND OUR ACTIONS TOWARD
OTHER PEOPLE.
AND THE WAY THAT WE CREATE AND
OPERATE OUR SYSTEMS AND OUR
INSTITUTIONS.
IN A RESEARCH STUDY INVOLVING
SEVEN HUNDRED THOUSAND
PARTICIPANTS THE MOST FREQUENT
ANSWER TO THE QUESTION WHO DO
YOU PREFER BLACK PEOPLE OR WHITE
PEOPLE WAS I HAVE NO PREFERENCE.
YET IN THAT SAME STUDY WHEN
GIVEN AND IMPERIL TEST THAT
MEASURES ONE'S LEVEL OF IMPLICIT
BIAS. 70% OF THOSE SEVEN HUNDRED
THOUSAND PEOPLE SHOWED A
PREFERENCE FOR WHITE PEOPLE OVER
BLACK PEOPLE.
JUDGES COURT PERSONNEL AND
ATTORNEYS ARE NOT IMMUNE FROM
BIAS THEIR PEOPLE.
TO A TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
STUDY.
DEMONSTRATED THAT JUDGES POSSESS
THE SAME LEVEL OF IMPLICIT BIAS
AGAINST AFRICAN AMERICANS AS DO
MOSTLY PEOPLE.
AT A TWO THOUSAND STEP SEVEN
CHEVY STOW THAT JUDGES AND
JURORS MAY UNINTENTIONALLY AND
AUTOMATICALLY MISS REMEMBER
FACTS IN A RACIALLY SKEWED
MANNER DURING ALL FACETS OF THE
LEGAL DECISION MAKING PROCESS.
EMPIRICAL RESEARCH ALSO SHOWS
THAT PROSECUTORS ARE MORE LIKELY
TO CHARGE BLACK SUSPECTS THAN
WHITE SUSPECTS IN SIMILAR
CIRCUMSTANCES.
SO WHEN LEFT UNADDRESSED THE
IMPLICIT BIASES OF JUDGES CLERKS
AND ATTORNEYS CONTRIBUTES TO AN
UNACCEPTABLE RACIAL DISPARITY IN
THE ADMINISTRATION OF JUSTICE.
IN SAN FRANCISCO LOCALLY BLACK
DEFENDANTS ARE HELD IN PRE TRIAL
CUSTODY 62% LONGER THAN WHITE
DEFENDANTS.
AND BLACK DEFENDANTS RECEIVED
28% LONGER SENTENCES THAN WHITE
DEFENDANTS CONVICTED CONVICTED
OF THE SAME CRIME.
AND NATIONALLY JUDGES SET BAIL
AMOUNTS OF BLACK MEN 35% HIGHER
THAN FOR WHITE MEN AND FOR LET
LATINO MEN 19% HIGHER THAN FOR
WHITE MEN.
SO SINCE BIAS IS LEARNED OVER
THE COURSE OF A LIFETIME IT'S
NOT EASILY -- LEARN BUT THE GOOD
NEWS IS THAT THERE IS ROOM FOR
CHANGE AND BIAS CAN BE MANAGED
THROUGH COUNTER BIAS TRAINING.
PRACTICAL TOOLS CAN HELP
PARTICIPANTS UNLEARNED
STEREOTYPES AND RETRAIN THEIR
BRAIN TO DISRUPT STEREO TYPE
BASS IMPLICIT ASSOCIATIONS.
COUNTERBALANCED COUNTER BIAS
TRAINING CAN BE MOST EFFECTIVE
WHEN ITS ONGOING AND REOCCURRING.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT
STRESSFUL WORKING ENVIRONMENT
STIMULATE BIAS.
AND INDIVIDUALS HAVE TO DO THE
HARD WORK OF DISRUPTING THEIR
BIAS BUT INSTITUTIONS HAVE AN
IMPORTANT ROLE TO PLAY AS WELL.
INSTITUTIONS NEED TO CREATE
POSITIVE BEHAVIORAL SUPPORT
STRUCTURES.
THAT DE STRESS THE WORK FORCE
AND ALLOW PROFESSIONALS TIME TO
MAKE CAREFUL AND DELIBERATE
DECISIONS.
DELIBERATE THOUGHTFUL DECISION
MAKING IS THE KEY TO DISRUPTING.
FIVE I'VE OBSERVED I DO NEED YOU
TO WRAP UP OKAY.
I KNOW THAT WE HAVE THE BODY
POLITIC SHARE VALUES OF FAIRNESS
EQUITY AND JUSTICE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL
THAT STRIVE TO ELIMINATE BIAS.
IN INDIVIDUALS AND INSTITUTIONS
TAKES US ONE GIANT LEAP TOWARD
THAT MORE PERFECT UNION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU NEXT WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING ME TODAY
MEDIAN CHAIR -- I'M PLEASED TO
BE HERE.
THE CONVERSATION THAT IF WE
COULD JUST ASSUME ARGUENDO FOR
THE PURPOSES OF CONVERSATION
THAT BIAS EXISTS AND THAT IT
AFFECTS DECISION MAKING -- ON
THE BENCH AND BEYOND -- THEN WE
GET TO EXPLORE THE QUESTION OF
THE VALUE OF TRAINING.
OF MAKE WILL IT SIMPLY BE A
MOMENT OF COMMON UNDERSTANDING
COMING TOGETHER NETWORKING OR
WILL IT ACTUALLY MAKE A
DIFFERENCE IN THE WAY THAT
PEOPLE MAKE DECISIONS.
BUCKLEY THE NEUROSCIENCE THAT IS
AVAILABLE -- GIVES US INSIGHT
INTO THAT.
EFFECT WAS NEUROSCIENCE THE HELP
THE FIRST OPEN THE DOOR. TO HELP
US UNDERSTAND HOW BIAS ACTUALLY
MANIFEST ITSELF.
IF WE HAVE A DIFFERENT BRAIN
REACTION TO A FACE A NAME A
VOICE.
WE WILL MAKE DECISIONS
DIFFERENTLY ABOUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS IN A COURT OF LAW --
THE WONDERFUL THING IS THAT THE
TECHNOLOGY IN THE NATURAL
SCIENCES ACTUALLY LET US KNOW
HOW TO CHANGE THOSE BRING
REACTIONS.
CUES CAN BE UTILIZED THAT WILL
LOWER OUR LEVEL OF THREAT
REACTION WHEN WE SEE INDIVIDUALS
WHO MIGHT OTHERWISE APPEAR FIGHT
MEAN THREATENING PERHAPS JUST
INDIVIDUALS WHO.
WHEN CONSIDERING THE OPTION OF
INCARCERATION WE SAY WE NEED TO
PROTECT OURSELVES FROM THEM AND
AND THEREFORE PERHAPS PLACE THEM
IN INCARCERATION? FOR A LONGER
PERIOD OF TIME [inaudible]
ADDITIONALLY.
NEUROSCIENCE HELPS US UNDERSTAND
WHAT PRECISELY A JUDGE COULD DO.
IN APPLYING LAW TO FACT. TO MAKE
A FAIR DECISION EVEN IN THE FACE
OF IMPLICIT BIAS.
ASSUMING THAT IMPLICIT BIAS
EXIST IN THE MIND OR THE BRAIN
OF THAT JUDGE AT THAT TIME.
CAN WE ACTUALLY TRAIN A JUDGE TO
MAKE A FAIR DECISION BY
ACTIVATING PARTICULAR PARTS OF
THE NEUROANATOMY AND SUBSYSTEMS
THAT WILL ALLOW THEM TO MAKE A
DECISION THAT'S REALLY ABOUT THE
FACTS AND THE LAW.
AND THE ANSWER IS YES WE HAVE
THAT AVAILABLE TO US AND THEY
DON'T HAVE TO ACTUALLYHAVE
THEIR BRAIN SCANNED IN THEY
DON'T HAVE TO TAKE ANOTHER NEURO
BIOLOGY CLASS OR THEIR FIRST ONE
PERHAPS.
IT ALL BECOMES A PART OF A
PRACTICAL APPLICATION IN A
CLASSROOM ENVIRONMENT.
OF THE MORE THAT WE DO THE MORE
CONTROL THE JUDGE HAS AND QUIRK
STAFF HAVE OVER THEIR BRAINS.
MANY OF CONTROL OF THEIR BRAINS
ABOUT CONTROL THEIR COURT.
AND THEN WE HAVE A FAIR.
SHERRI AND IN THE JUDITH PROCESS
THAT ACTUALLY LEADS TO THE
OUTCOMES WERE HOPING.
FOR SO I SUBMIT TO YOU THAT.
TRAINING IS MORE THAN HOLDING
HANDS SINGING KUMBAYA.
BUT RATHER IMPLEMENTING SPECIFIC
MECHANISMS THAT CAN ALLOW US TO
ENSURE THE FAIRNESS AND EQUITY
OF THE COURTS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU BUT ALLOW
ONE OTHER WITNESS HER TESTIMONY.
THE COURT JESTERS ON BEHALF OF
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL MY MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
WE DON'T HAVE AN OFFICIAL
POSITION THAT STILL GOING TO
ADVISORY COMMITTEE PROCESS BUT
WE ARE DEFINITELY SUPPORT OF WE
WELCOME THE ASSEMBLY MORMONS --
INTEREST IN THIS ISSUE WITH A
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE WAS NOTED
IN THE ANALYSIS -- THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT THE JUDGES WERE
COUNCIL HAS INTEGRATED INTO OUR
QUALIFIED ETHICS COURSE FOR
JUDGES I BELIEVE SINCE TWO
THOUSAND THIRTEEN WE CONTINUE TO
WORK.
ON THAT -- ON THE SUBJECT THANK
THE AUTHOR IN THE COMMITTEE FOR
THE TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
AMENDMENTS WE HAVE BEEN ENGAGED
WITH OUR PRESIDING JUDGE
LEADERSHIP IN COURT EXECUTIVE
OFFICER LEADERSHIP.
A WORKING ON SOME OF THE MOMENT
SO THAT'S BEEN NOT REALLY GREAT
AND I WOULD JUST INTRODUCE
BRIEFLY KAREEM ALTERADO WHO'S
JOINED US HERE SHE'S THE
DIRECTOR OF OUR CENTER FOR
JUDICIAL EDUCATION RESEARCH.
AND SHE'S AVAILABLE IF YOU HAVE
ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE WORK
THAT THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL IS
DOING IN THIS AREA THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT IF YOU
COULD COME FOR JUST GIVE US YOUR
NAME AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE --
CARES WITH DISABILITY RIGHTS
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL SAVANNAH ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES ALSO IN
SUPPORT.
CHRISTOPHER SONS THE CHAIR THAT
WE JUST FROM THE POSITION LAST
WEEK AND SUPPORT [inudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS YOU WANTED TO
CLIMB A AM A RESIDENT OF OAKLAND
CALIFORNIA AND I WORK FOR EQUAL
JUSTICE SOCIETY AND ALSO HERE IN
SUPPORT BECAUSE I THINK THIS
BILL IS CRITICAL.
I CAPACITY THEY DO ACTUALLY
ADMINISTER JUSTICE IN THIS
COUNTRY THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SIGNAL IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
I SAY NONE BRING BACK TO
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
REDRESS.
THIS IS REALLY IMPORTANT I KNOW
THAT -- WHEN I VOLUNTEERED AS A
TEMPORARY JUDGE WE HAD TO GO
THROUGH TRAINING?
AND ONE OF THOSE WAS ON IMPLICIT
BIAS.
AND YOU'RE RIGHT EVEN THOUGH YOU
THINK YOU DON'T HAVE THAT BIAS
IT IS THERE.
AND IT IS IMPORTANT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE IT AND THEN TO
FIGURE HOW YOU'RE GOING TO
CHANGE IT.
BECAUSE IF YOU JUST TO GLOSS
OVER AND SAY I HAVE NO BIAS AYE.
I GREW UP IN A SOCIETY WHERE I
EVERYBODY IS EQUAL.
IT THAT'S WONDERFUL BUT WHEN YOU
TAKE THOSE LITTLE TESTS AND YOU
FIND THAT THERE IS AN IMPLICIT
BIAS YOU NEED TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT ESPECIALLY WHEN
YOU'RE IN A POSITION. TO
DETERMINE A SENTENCE OVER
SOMEONE SO I ABSOLUTELY SUPPORT
THIS BILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THIS THE PETRIE-NORRIS.
I JUST ECHO AT MY COLLEAGUES
COMMENTS THIS IS SO IMPORTANT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD.
QUICK QUESTION FOR YOU AS YOU
MENTIONED TRAINING IS NOT JUST
HOLDING HANDS AND SING KUMBAYA
WHAT ARE THE SPECIFIC ELEMENTS
AS SUCCESSFUL TRAINING PROGRAMS
AND SUCCESSFUL STRATEGIES IF YOU
JUST.
BRIEFLY TOUCH ON THAT VERY
BRIEFLY CERTAINLY -- AND THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION -- NUMBER.
ONE AWARENESS.
STEP ONE ADMIT YOU HAVE A
PROBLEM BASICALLY SO IT IS
IMPORTANT FOR A PERSON TO BE
AWARE BUT THAT WHILE IS IT IS
NECESSARY IS ABSOLUTELY
INSUFFICIENT.
IT'S PART ONE BUT YOU GOTTA GO
TO THE NEXT STEP THEN ONCE
EVERYONE GETS TO THE POINT OF
SAYING YES INDEED WE HAVE A BIAS.
NOW WE CAN MOVE FORWARD AND
START UTILIZED TOOLS AND THE
TOOL SHOULD COVER AT LEAST THREE
CATEGORIES ONE REDUCING THE
LEVEL OF IMPLICIT BIAS WHICH WE
KNOW CAN BE DONE.
THAT THERE IS OUR ACTUAL
CURRICULA AVAILABLE THAT WILL
ACTUALLY BRING DOWN YOUR LEVEL
OF IMPLICIT BIAS ON THE I. A. T.
IN ALMOST EVERY CATEGORY.
SO THAT'S PART.
ONE PART TWO PROVIDING THAT'S
WHAT THAT'S LONG TERM
MAINTENANCE PART TO PROVIDING
PEOPLE WITH INSTANTANEOUS ACCESS
TO BRING DOWN THE DIFFERENT
NARAL PHYSIOLOGIC REACTIONS THAT
CAN CREATE PROBLEMATIC DECISION
MAKING.
THE SPIDER SNAKE REACTION THAT
WE HAVE IN OUR BRAIN WE CAN
ACTUALLY ALSO HAVE TWO OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO WE'VE BEEN TOLD
OVER LIFE TIME OR THE SCARY
PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
INCARCERATED LONGER.
FIRST A SHORT OF FOR SHORTER
PERIODS OF TIME AND NUMBER THREE
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT.
TEACHING PEOPLE HOW TO ACTIVATE.
THE SPECIFIC PARTS OF THEIR
NEUROANATOMY THE ENTER YOUR
SINGLE CORTEX TO BE SPECIFIC BUT
NOT TO MAKE EVERYBODY'S EYES
GLAZE OVER BUT TO PROTECT THE
THE SPECIFIC PARTS OF THEIR
NEUROANATOMY.
THAT WILL ACTUALLY ALLOW THEM TO
MAKE FAIR AND ACCURATE DECISIONS
EVEN WALL BIAS IS EXT IS
ACTUALLY ACTIVE IN THEIR BRAIN
AND IN THEIR PSYCHE SO TO SPEAK.
SO THOSE ARE THE THREE
COMPONENTS FOR PART TO THE
SOLUTION SECTION AND PART ONE IS
JUST THE PROBLEM AND A LOT OF
TRIMMING STOP AT PORT ONE NOW
YOU'RE ALL WE ARE GOING TO GO
OUT AND DO GOOD.
AND YET THE PERSON SITS THERE
CONFUSED.
THANK THANK THANK YOU WE'RE NOT
WE'RE NOT GONNA GO TO SOMEONE ON
ALL THESE FASCINATING AS IT IS
BUT WE'RE WE ARE TRYING TO MOVE
THE POLICY.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU I I WILL
GIVE A BRIEF PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT ON MAY FOURTEENTH
AT NINE O'CLOCK IN THIS ROOM
THIS COMMITTEE.
IN CONJUNCTION WITH THE NUMBER
OF THE CAUCUSES IN THE ASSEMBLY
ARE HOLDING HEARINGS ON
DIVERSITY.
IN THE ON THE BENCH DIVERSITY IN
THE BARK IS ONE OF THE PROBLEMS
THAT WE HAVE IS A LACK OF
DIVERSITY BOTH ON THE BENCH TO
THE BAR AND THE TRACK OF
STUDENTS COMING INTO LAW
PROFESSOR AND I THINK IT'S VERY
DIFFICULT FOR US. TO OVERCOME
THOSE BY SEES OR UNDERSTANDS.
BREAK DOWN THE INTERNAL BY SEES
IF WE DON'T HAVE A BENCH AT A
BAR THAT LOOK LIKE CALIFORNIA
IT'S MUCH EASIER TO SORT OF HIDE
BEHIND.
TRADITIONAL NOTIONS AND
TRADITIONAL STANDARDS SO THAT'S
GOING TO BE A VERY IMPORTANT
PART OF CALIFORNIA MOVING
FORWARD AND MAKING SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE LEGAL PROFESSION THAT
LOOKS AS MUCH LIKE CALIFORNIA AS
WE CAN POSSIBLY GET IT.
SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD.
OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS SEEING
NONE.
MS KAMARCK LOVE YOU MAY CLOSE.
I WILL JUST SAY IN AN EFFORT TO
DE STRESS THE WORKPLACE AND
IMPACT IMPLICIT BIAS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILLS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU MEMBERS.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER TEN
A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR MISTER
GLORIA.
YOU MADE YOUR BILL
. TO LEARN
MORE MISS CHAIRMAN I THANK YOU
SO MUCH FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
TODAY.
I TO START BY THANKING THE CHAIR
COMMITTEE STAFF AND STAKEHOLDERS
FOR THEIR TIME ATTENTION. TO
THIS BILL THE THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS THE CONSIDERATIONS
BROUGHT BY MY OFFICE HAVE BEEN.
BROUGHT TO MY OFFICE HAVE
BENEFITTED THIS BILL IN THE
TREMENDOUSLY THE MORNING THANK
YOU HEY WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND
A SECOND TEN TASTIC JUST VERY
QUICKLY AB ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR
WILL REQUIRE PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
RETAIN PUBLIC RECORDS.
THAT ARE TRANSMITTED BY EMAIL
FOR AT LEAST TWO YEARS THIS WILL
CLARIFY EXISTING PUBLIC RECORD
RETENTION Là AND BRING IT INTO
THE TWENTY FIRST CENTURY.
EMAILS OF COURSE AS YOU ON OUR
CRITICAL CONDUCTING OUR DAILY
BUSINESS I THINK IT'S
APPROPRIATE TO SUGGEST THAT
THEY'RE SOMEHOW DIFFERENT THE
PAPER RECORDS.
WE HAVE RECORDS WE HAVE --
EXPERIENCES -- IN MY HOME COUNTY --
OF LITIGATION AROUND THIS MATTER
ARSENIO UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
RECENTLY A CELL TO EXPENSIVE
LAWSUIT AFTER THEY APPROVED A
POLICY WOULD ALLOW FOR THE
DESTRUCTION OF EMAILS AFTER --
IN MUCH LESS TIME THAN PROPOSED
IN THIS BILL -- WITH ME THIS
MORNING -- IS JIM YOUR COMPANY
NEWSPAPER PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION
AS OUR WITNESS.
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE LISTED IN
THE ANALYSIS YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
AUTHORS DISTRICTS THANK YOU SO
MUCH.
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE MISTER
CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
JIM YOU WORK FOR THE CALIFORNIA
NEWS PUBLISHERS ASSOCIATION --
WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL --
WE THINK THAT THERE IS A NEED TO
CREATE MINIMUM STANDARDS THAT
APPLY STATEWIDE AND DON'T LEAVE
IT UP TO THE DISCRETION OF EACH
AGENCY IN AN AREA THAT IS
SOMEWHAT UNCLEAR.
WITH REGARD TO THE INFORMATION
THAT HAS TO BE RETAINED.
AS THE SOME LIMóN POINTED OUT
THERE HAVE BEEN INSTANCES WHEN
RECORDS HAVE BEEN DESTROYED --
THIRTY DAY PERIOD LET'S SAY --
THAT'S INFORMATION THAT COULD BE
USED BY THE PUBLIC TO LEARN
ABOUT THE DEVELOPMENT OF POLICY
ABOUT HOW.
SOMETHING IS SHAPED IN A
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY.
WE THINK THIS IS A GOOD BILL AND
WE STRONGLY YOUR DRIVER.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT SEEN THAT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION -- CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE UNTIL GIVEN FOR
THE CALIFORNIA SPECIAL DISTRICTS
ASSOCIATION I'D LIKE TO THINK
THE THE AUTHOR FOR WORKING WITH
US IN AND TRYING TO NARROW THE
SCOPE OF THE BILL -- AT THIS
TIME WE STILL BELIEVE IT'S A
LITTLE TOO BROAD AND WILL
ULTIMATELY LEAD TO US KEEPING.
EVERY EMAIL THAT WE HAVE -- FOR
TWO YEARS AND AND AGAIN THIS IS
IN A THAT THIS BILL DOES NOT
REQUIRE ANY NEW DISCLOSURES.
IT DOESN'T REQUIRE -- PROVIDE
ANY NEW EXEMPTIONS -- THIS IS A
DATA STORAGE BILL THIS IS A WE
HAVE TO KEEP -- THESE EMAILS AND
AND THAT WOULD BE -- MEN EMAIL
CHAIN WHERE YOU'VE GOT IN A
FIFTEEN PEOPLE RESPONDING TO AN
EMAIL IT'S NOT THE LAST EMAIL
THAT HAS THE RECORD OF ALL OF
THE EMAILS THAT WE HAVE TO KEEP.
IT ALL OF THE FIFTEEN RESPONSES
AS WELL.
AND SO WHAT THIS IS GOING TO DO
IS COST ARE A PUBLIC AGENCIES
MORE MONEY AS FAR AS THE THE
DATA STORAGE NOW.
HI I APPRECIATE WHAT THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IS GETTING AT
AND I THINK THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO WORK TOGETHER TO TRY AND FIND
SOME SORT OF RESOLUTION. ONE OF
THE OTHER ISSUES IS THIS --
RETENTION REQUIREMENT AS POINTED
OUT THE ANALYSIS IS IN THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS ACT
RATHER THAN ANOTHER SECTION THE
GOVERNMENT CODE.
AND ESSENTIALLY WHAT THAT DOES
IS THAT CIRCUMVENTS THE
REIMBURSEMENT PROCESS FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES THERE'S NO OTHER
RETENTION REQUIREMENTS.
IN THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC RECORDS
ACT THEIR OTHER PLACES IN THE
GOVERNMENT CODE AND SO WE WOULD
SUGGEST THAT THIS IF IF IT'S
GOING TO MOVE FORWARD BE MOVED
FROM THE CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
RECORDS ACT.
INTO THE GOVERNMENT COAT -- AND
HOPEFULLY THAT THAT WILL ALLOW
OUR AGENCIES THAT DO EXPERIENCE
CERTAIN COSTS THAT ARE ELIGIBLE
FOR YOUR REIMBURSEMENT WILL BE
ABLE TO SEEK THOSE COSTS.
AND WITH THAT -- THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING ADJACENT BRIAN I'LL
BE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA DOWNTOWN
ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA'S BUSINESS
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICTS APPRECIATE
THE AUTHOR OR WORKING WITH US ON
AMENDMENTS CONTINUES TO WORK
WITH YOU OF MOVING FORWARD.
WE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT COSTS AND
BEFORE NEXT UPS THANK YOU.
I GIVE ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING CARA CROSS ON
BEHALF OF DOWNTOWN CENTER
BUSINESS IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT
WHICH YOU'RE LOOKING FORWARD --
TO WORKING WITH AUTHOR OF
CURRENTLY WE OPPOSE BUT WE'RE
OPTIMISTIC THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION SEEING
NONE BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNAL. TO GLORY MIKLOS.
TWENTY NINETEEN MISTER IT'S TIME
TO UPDATE THIS AND CLARIFY -- I
WOULD SAID ASSEMBLY SUGGESTS
THAT THE REDUCTION LITIGATION
MAY ACTUALLY MORE THAN MAKE UP
FOR THE DIFFERENCE IN STORAGE.
AND I PERCENT GAS FOR EITHER.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I RATE THIS.
RACE I BUT I WAS OUT BIG CHEVY
SO MUCH.
RIGHT MR SANTIAGO THAT NOW TAKE
SAYS.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN AB.
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN OF THE
ELECTRONIC RECORD.
THAT IS ITEM TWENTY SIX THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF YOU'VE
WORKED ON THIS WITH US FOR A
COUPLE OF YEARS AND WERE --
APPRECIATIVE OF THAT.
WE ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS AND IN SHORT AS YOU
KNOW AB SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN
WOULD RECOGNIZE OUT OF STATE
ELECTRONIC WILL WILLS THAT MEET
SPECIFIC CRITERIA WILL CONTINUE
TO WORK WITH YOU.
HI IN THE SESSION.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
WAS WITH US PLEASE I MISSED
CHAIR -- MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MARKUP PRAY I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF LEGALZOOM WE WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING THIS MEASURE -- THE
STAFF FOR WORKING WITH US -- AND
AS THE AS THEY BUILD AS PROPOSED
TO BE AMENDED BY THE BY THE
COMMITTEE -- WOULD -- RECOGNIZE
OUT OF STATE ELECTRONIC WILLS
I'LL JUST POINT OUT THAT.
THIS WEEKEND -- THE UNIFORM WALK
COMMISSION WILL BE MEETING FOR
THE FINAL TIME -- TO REVIEW
THEIR PROPOSAL -- WE ALSO ARE
ARE WELL AWARE THAT OTHER STATES
HAVE ADOPTED ELECTRONIC WILLS
AND THAT PEOPLE ARE UTILIZING --
ELECTRONIC MEANS OF CREATING
WILLS AND WE LOOK FORWARD TO
WORKING WITH THE COMMITTEE TO
DEVISING A STANDARD THAT CAN BE
APPLICABLE IN CALIFORNIA WE URGE
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I'D SING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
AT NOT OPPOSITE TO TURN MEMBERS
CAN PLAN FOR THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL.
WE'VE HAD GOOD PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE OTHER
STAFF AND COMMITTEE STAFF ON
THIS ISSUE -- THE ISSUE OF
ELECTRONIC WILL THIS VERY
COMPLEX AS WAS MENTIONED THE
UNIFORM Là COMMISSION IS
STUDYING AT THERE'S A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT VIEWS OUT THERE.
WE LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO
WORK COOPERATIVELY WITH AUTHOR
SPONSOR COMMITTEE STAFF AND ALL
THE OTHER STAKEHOLDERS MOVING
FORWARD THANK YOU [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE ERIN RUBBER ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA JUDGES
ASSOCIATION AND JUST NEAR THE
SAME COMMENTS AS THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE COMMITTEE FOR INCLUDING US
IN THE DISCUSSIONS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN OPPOSITION OR TO YOU IN
DISCUSSION SO ALL RIGHT SEE NONE
BRING BACK TO THE COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU MISTER SANTIAGO FOR
WORKING WITH US.
THAT ONE OF THE CHALLENGES
THERE'S THERE'S THIS GREAT
NOTION OF OF WANTING TO USE
TECHNOLOGY TO REPLACE.
TRADITIONS AND AND LEGAL
STRUCTURE THEY'VE BEEN BUILT UP
OVER THE YEARS IN PAPER AND I'LL
TELL YOU FOR ONE I AM VERY
SUPPORTIVE OF THAT.
BUT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS TRANSLATE
[inaudible]
PAPER.
INTO ELECTRONICS AND AS WE DO
THAT MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING.
THE IN THIS CASE THE INTENT OF
THE THE CREATOR OF THE WILL AND
THOSE PROCESS IS WHAT WE NEED TO
DO TO MAKE SURE WE DO.
SO THAT THE SYSTEM HAS A WAY TO
TO MANAGE SO I I THINK THIS IS A
VERY GOOD ISSUE I WANNA MAKE
SURE WE FIND A WAY. TO
ACCOMPLISH IS BECAUSE THIS IS
WHERE WE'RE GOING -- BUT MAKE
SURE THAT THAT WE'RE DOING IT IN
A WAY THAT THAT WE ARE
PRESERVING THE EVIDENCE
PRESERVING THE STRUCTURE.
THAT'S REALLY WHAT THE CONCERN
IS SO WE WE WILL GET THERE.
THIS RACE. TO SHARE -- THAT
CONCERNED -- MISTER CHAIR RIGHT
BY I DON'T KNOW IF THERE WILL BE
LIMITATIONS ON THIS AT A FUTURE
DATE FOUR WHEELS OF PARTICULAR
VALUE.
A SIMPLE WILLS AS OPPOSED TO
VERY COMPLICATED WILLS.
I THINK BEING ABLE TO TALK TO
THE PERSON.
BEING ABLE.
TO TO CONFIRM THEIR THEIR
INTENTIONS BUT I I AM.
CERTAIN THAT THAT TO THE AUTHOR
WILL BE LOOKING AT THE
PROTECTIONS OF ALL OF THOSE.
WHO WILL BE INVOLVED IN SUCH A
WILL?
THAT WILL BE SIGNED
ELECTRONICALLY.
MISTER CHAIRMAN I RESPOND.
PLACE YEAH BUT WE'RE ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT THOSE ARE THOSE --
ISSUES AND COMMENTS AND WE WOULD
AGREE WITH THE CHAIR THIS IS WHY
WE'VE TAKEN OUR TIME OVER THE
LAST COUPE OF YEARS AND YEAH
THIS IS A PLACE THAT MOVES VERY
QUICKLY IN IN EVEN IN THIS%
SITUATION WE DECIDED TO TAKE THE
LONG ROAD IN.
AND EVEN TABLE BILLS IN THE PAST
WE CAN GET IT RIGHT I MEAN THIS
IS IMPORTANT AND WE IN A WEEK
KNOWLEDGE -- POTENTIAL ABUSES
WHICH IS WHY WE'RE TAKING OUR
TIME WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE CHAIR HOPEFULLY WE GET DONE
THIS YEAR I'M OPTIMISTIC -- BUT
IF NOT WE'RE NOT LOOKING -- FOR
SOME SORT OF RAM JOB ON THIS
EITHER I MEAN WE WANT TO GET IT
DONE RIGHT.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS IT'S AN EVERYDAY THAT
MISTER SANTIAGO YES WE I THINK
WE WE WILL DEFINITELY BE ABLE TO
GET THIS SORTED OUT BUT IT'S
GOOD.
I THINK TAKE A LITTLE BIT OF
EVERY SHAPE YOUR YOUR PATIENCE
YOU'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BUT
IN THE END I THINK YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE A GREAT WORK PRODUCT.
THAT REALLY SUPPORTS
CALIFORNIANS.
ALL RIGHT SEE NOTHING ELSE WAS
UNDERGOING A CLOSE NOT RESPECT
WESTERN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAU.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES HI RES
SIDE.
THE BILL IS OUT SICK THANK YOU
SO MUCH MISTER BLOOM THANK YOU
FOR BEING PATIENT.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB -- SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO ITEM.
TWENTY SEVEN GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS AND NOW FOR
SOMETHING A LITTLE DIFFERENT.
AB -- SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO IS A
BILL THAT IS INTENDED TO PROVIDE
CLEAR CONSUMER INFORMATION ABOUT
HOW CONSUMERS SHOULD PROPERLY
DISPOSE OF SINGLE USE WET WIPES.
PRODUCTS WITH THE ATTENTIVE
KEEPING NON DISPERSIBLE WIPES
OUT OF THE SEWER SYSTEM.
BOB.
THIS IS TOILET PAPER THAT WAS
PLACED IN THIS JAR THIS MORNING
AND YOU CAN SEE HOW IT'S ALREADY
DISSOLVED INTO SMALL PIECES.
THIS IS -- PERMISSION TO USE
PROPS GRANTED.
WITH YOUR PERMISSION MISTER
CHAIR.
YOU'RE JUST GONNA WANT TO HEAR
THIS MISTER CHAIR -- THIS THIS
IS -- TUG OF BOOZE KIDS WIPES --
YOU CAN SEE IT'S STILL IN ONE
PIECE THIS WOULD PLACE THE JAR
BACK IN FEBRUARY THE BEGINNING
OF FEBRUARY OF OF OF THIS YEAR
AND THAT IN CAPSULE IT'S THE
PROBLEM THAT WE'RE TRYING TO
ADDRESS HERE WITH.
WITH THIS BILL.
THE FACT OF THE MATTER IS RIGHT
NOW ANY COMPANY CAN CALL THEIR
PRODUCT FLUSHABLE REGARDLESS OF
THE POTENTIAL HARM TO THE SEWER
SYSTEM OR WHETHER IT.
TRULY BREAKS APART -- OF LIKE
TOILET PAPER DOES.
WHEN AND WHAT WHITE PRODUCTS ARE
FLUSHED INTO THE SEWER SYSTEM
THAT CAN CAUSE SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES FOR PRIVATE PROPERTY
OWNERS SEWER COLLECTIONS AND
WASTE TREATMENT PLANTS AND IN
FACT THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT WE'RE
SEEING?
OUT IN THE FIELD A SINGLE USE
WET WIPES ARE HEAVIER THICKER
AND HAVE LARGER SURFACE AREAS
THAN TOILET PAPER AND
RESEARCHERS HAVE FOUND THAT
UNDER WHAT CONDITIONS WHITE.
MAINTAIN MOST OF THEIR STRENGTH
AS THEY ARE COMPOSED OF
SYNTHETIC FIBERS THAT RETAIN
THEIR SHAPE AND STRENGTH.
THEY OFTEN DO NOT BREAK DOWN --
FOR A LONG LONG TIME AFTER BEING
FLUSHED AND CAN ACCUMULATE WITH
FATS OILS AND GREASE.
THAT BECOME LARGE OBSTRUCTIONS
IN OUR PIPES AND TO HAVE EARNED
THE DISGUSTING NAME OF FAT BERKS --
FURTHER DOWN THE LINE THEY WEAVE
TOGETHER AND THEY CAN CREATE
GIANT RAGS -- THAT -- THEN CAN'T
CATCH IN OUR PUMP SYSTEMS
COLLECTION SYSTEMS AND MOTORS
CAUSING BACKUPS AND EQUIPMENT
FAILURES AND THIS IN FACT IS A
PROBLEM THAT HAS BEEN
EXPERIENCED ACROSS THE STATE.
I COULD GIVE YOU EXAMPLES IN
PETALUMA AN ORANGE COUNTY -- IN
THE ORANGE COUNTY SANITATION
DISTRICT OF THE CITY OF CAMERI --
A WASTE WATER TREATMENT PLANT IT
HAS INVESTED A HALF MILLION
DOLLARS TO UPGRADE ITS WASTE
WATER TREATMENT PLANT JUST TO
DEAL WITH THIS ISSUE.
IN EACH OF THESE CASES THE COST
GETS PASSED ON TO RATE PAYERS
NOT THE MANUFACTURERS OF THE
WHITES THAT ARE ACTUALLY
DAMAGING THE SYSTEMS AND SO THIS
BILL SIMPLY PRESCRIBES CLEAR AND
CONSISTENT CONSUMER MESSAGING.
FOR THESE PRODUCTS SO THAT
CONSUMERS LEARN WHAT GOES DOWN
THE TOILET AND WHAT DOESN'T --
AND THESE SHOULD NOT BE FLUSHED
DOWN THE TOILET IT'S IT'S THAT
SIMPLE SO UNDER THE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL WIFE CAN BE LABELED
AS FLUSHABLE IF THE IF THEY DO
NOT CAUSE HARM TO THE SEWER
SYSTEM.
MEANING THAT MANUFACTURERS WILL
NEED TO DEMONSTRATE THAT THEIR
WIVES CAN BREAK DOWN OF THE
SEWER SYSTEM MUCH LIKE TRY
TOILET PAPER FOR ALL OTHER WIPES
THAT ARE NOT INTENDED TO BE
FLUSHED.
FELT BE MARKED DO NOT FLUSH IT'S
VERY SIMPLE IT'S VERY LOGICAL.
AND TESTIFYING IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL IS JESSICA GALLAGHER WITH
THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
SANITATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITNESS PLEASE
GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN STONE AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HOW I'M
JUST C<c.cyan> AUGER WITH CALIFORNIA</c>
ASSOCIATION OF SANITATION
AGENCIES WERE THE SPONSOR BABY
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO HERE TODAY
AND STRONG SUPPORT.
SINGLE USE WET WIPES THE BECOME
WIDELY AVAILABLE TO CONSUMERS
OVER THE LAST FIFTEEN OR TWENTY
YEARS AND THERE'S A DIRECT
CORRELATION WITH THE INCREASING
POPULARITY.
OF SINGLE USE WIPES PRODUCTS IN
THE SIGNIFICANT PROBLEMS WE'RE
SEEING IN THE SEWER SYSTEM WITH
RAGGING.
SOME MORE -- WIPES ARE MARKETED
AS FLUSHABLE OTHERS ARE LABELED
WITH DO NOT FLUSH DIRECTIONS OR
NOT LABELED WITH ANY DISPOSAL
INDICATIONS AT ALL.
BECAUSE OF THIS INCONSISTENCY IN
LABELING PRACTICES AND BECAUSE
MOST OF THESE WIPES LOOK AND
FEEL THE SAME.
THE RESULT IS AN ONSLAUGHT OF
WHITE SEEING FLUSHED DOWN THE
DRAIN -- BOTH WIPES THAT ARE
LABELED AS POSSIBLE IN THE ART
AND THE CAUSING MAJOR ISSUES.
FOR SEWER SERVICE PROVIDERS --
ONE WIPES GET INTO THE SYSTEM
THEY WEAVE TOGETHER -- INFORMED
LARGE BLANKETS AND WHEN THEY
CATCH ON TO OTHER DEBRIS AND
GREECE THEY FORM FAT BERKS.
AND THESE ARE GIANT OBSTRUCTIONS
THAT ARE MAJORLY DESTRUCTIVE FOR
THE SYSTEM THINKING COST
SANITARY SEWER OVERFLOWS.
A SEWER SPILL OF ANY AMOUNT --
IS A PUBLIC AN ENVIRONMENTAL
HAZARD AND THE WATER BOARD HAS A
ZERO TOLERANCE POLICY FIRST
BILLS.
SO FAR IN TWENTY NINETEEN THE
WATER BOARD'S BILL DATABASE
INDICATES THAT THERE BEEN AT
EIGHTY SANITARY SEWER OVERFLOWS
ATTRIBUTED TO RAGGING AND NON
DISPERSIBLE.
THAT'S FIFTY THOUSAND GALLONS --
IN THIS YEAR ALONE THIRTY FIVE
THOUSAND OF WHICH REACH SURFACE
WATERS AND WERE SUBJECT TO
ADMINISTRATIVE PENALTIES.
AND THAT NUMBER DOESN'T ACCOUNT
FOR THE OVERFLOW THAT PRIVATE
RESIDENCES OR BUSINESSES THAT GO
UNREPORTED.
IN ADDITION TO OVERFLOWS ONE
WIFE GET FURTHER DOWN IN THE
SYSTEMS LARGE RAGS GET WRAPPED
UP IN HEAVY MECHANICAL FEATURES
OF THE SYSTEMS LIKE PUMPS.
MOTORS AND SCREENS REQUIRING
MANUAL REMOVAL OF DEBRIS AND
ADDITIONAL MAINTENANCE OR
REPLACEMENT OF THE STRUCTURES.
ON THE CONSTANT REMEDIATION
EFFORTS TO DISRUPT ALL STAGES OF
TREATMENT THE TREATMENT PROCESS
AND AS A RESULT -- AT RESULTING
COSTS ON MANY LEVELS FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND ULTIMATELY ON
REPAIRS -- ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT MANY WIPES LIKE BABY WIPES
AND CLEANING WIPES ARE MADE OF
PLASTIC AND WHEN THEIR FLESH
IMPROPERLY THEY CAN CONTRIBUTE.
TO LOADING MY IN WASTEWATER
EFFLUENT -- THERE SIGNIFICANT
TIME ENERGY ND PUBLIC MONEY
BEING SPENT ON MASSIVE PUBLIC
EDUCATION EFFORTS ABOUT THE
PROBLEMS WITH FLUSHING WIPES.
PRETTY MUCH EVERY AGENCY HAS
DONE OUT REACH ABOUT WIPES FOR
MANY YEARS AND WE'RE HERE TODAY
BECAUSE EDUCATIONAL CAMPAIGN
SIMPLY AREN'T EFFECTIVE ENOUGH
AND MANAGING THIS PROBLEM.
WE RECENTLY DID SOME POLLING ON
THIS ISSUE IN THE BAY AREA AND
BY A LARGE MARGIN IT WAS EVIDENT
THAT CONSUMERS TRUST THE
LABELING ON PACKAGES.
AND THAT'S THE PREFERRED METHOD
FOR RECEIVING INFORMATION ABOUT
PROPER DISPOSAL OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
FAR AND ABOVE HEARING ABOUT IT
FROM THEIR LOCAL SEWER UTILITY.
ON THE PERFORMANCE METRICS FOR
FLEXIBILITY IN THE BILL ARE
BASED ON SCIENCE AND ACCURATELY
REFLECT THE CONDITIONS IN THE
SEWER ESPECIALLY THE SYSTEMS
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHERE THERE'S
LESS TURBULENCE BECAUSE THE
SUCCESSFUL WATER CONSERVATION
EFFORTS.
THE MEASURES WERE DEVELOPED BY
AN INTERNATIONAL GROUP OF MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRED PUBLIC WASTE
WATER ENTITIES USING A
SCIENTIFIC AN EVIDENCE BASED
PROCESS WITH FEEDBACK FROM THE
NON WOVEN FABRICS INDUSTRY.
THE DO NOT FLESHLY BAND LABELING
REQUIREMENT IS IN ACCORDANCE
WITH THE VOLUNTARY INDUSTRY
GUIDELINES THAT MANY OF THESE
PRODUCTS ALREADY ABIDE BY.
THE ENFORCEMENT PROVISIONS ARE
REFLECTIVE OF OTHER SOURCE
CONTROL LEGISLATION AND WE SHEET
THE AMENDMENTS BEING DISCUSSED
IN THE ANALYSIS THAT EXTEND OUT
THE IMPLEMENTATION PERIOD TO
GIVE MANUFACTURERS TIME TO COME
INTO COMPLIANCE -- BOTTOM LINE
WE'VE SPENT MANY YEARS --
PROVIDING FEEDBACK TO THE
MANUFACTURERS OF WET WIPES ABOUT
THE PROBLEMS WE'VE BEEN
EXPERIENCING.
AND SUGGESTING CHANGES TO
LABELING GUIDELINES WITH LITTLE
SUCCESS SO WE FEEL IT'S TIME TO
ADDRESS THIS PROBLEM AND THAT
REQUIRING MANUFACTURERS TO
PROVIDE CLEAR CONSUMER
INFORMATION ABOUT THE
APPROPRIATE DISPOSAL OF THESE
PRODUCTS.
IS A SENSIBLE AND MODERATE
APPROACH SO FOR THESE REASONS
WERE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THE
BILL AND WOULD URGE THE
COMMITTEES I BUT WE HAVE CHAIRED
BOSS GOAL OF A KATHY HERE TODAY
TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL FEEDBACK IF
NECESSARY AS WELL.
AND A MISTER CHAIR I NEGLECTED
TO OF ACTION OF THE TOTAL EXCEPT
OF THE AMENDMENT SAID THAT THE
COMMITTEE HAS RECOMMENDED.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU RIGHT ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
SCHERING GREEN SANITATION
DISTRICTS OF LOS ANGELES COUNTY
HERE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
JOHN LANDED ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF WEST HOLLYWOOD IN
SUPPORT.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF
EVERYTHING WASTE IN SUPPORT.
ERIC O'DONNELL BEHALF THE ORANGE
COUNTY SANITATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
STARSKY WAS ON BEHALF THE LESS
BURGESS AND DEPUTY IN TRIUMPH
WAS SANITATION DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT AND ELSEWHERE VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
JASON OCCURRED WITH THAT'LL
STAND GILBERT ROBESON SMITH ON
BEHALF OF THE SAN FRANCISCO
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
THE TICKETS WITH THE CITY OF
ROSEVILLE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS LOUIS SQUARE FOR MY
CALIFORNIA I'M A WATER TREATMENT
PLANT OPERATOR AND I UNDERSTAND
EVERYTHING THAT THEY'RE TALKING
ABOUT. ONE OF THE THINGS I
LEARNED WE'RE NOT TAKING FOR THE
TESTIMONY I JUST EDUCATION I
SUPPORT YES I SUPPORT THIS BILL
THANK YOU.
EMILY BARNETT STRONG SUPPORT FOR
THE CENTRAL CONTRA COSTA
SANITARY DISTRICT.
ANGELA LARA DEL TO DOUBLE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
JENNIFER WILLIAMS WITH THE EAST
BAY MUNICIPAL UTILITY DISTRICT
IN SUPPORT.
DON'T GIVEN FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING BATH A LOSS ON
BEHALF OF THE INLAND EMPIRE
UTILITIES AGENCY ARE UP OR
DIDN'T TAKE A POSITION TO AFTER
YOUR LETTER DEADLINE SO WE'RE
NOT ON YOUR HOUSES BUT IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
BORN COMMON SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
GOOD MORNING A CHAIR STONE IN
MEMBERS CURSOR IS ON BEHALF OF
INTO THE ASSOCIATION FOR NON
WOVEN FABRICS INDUSTRY THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO PROVIDE
TESTIMONY ON SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO
OUR INDUSTRY IS COMMITTED TO
CONTINUE IMPROVING OUR WIPES
PRODUCTS TO MEET THE
EXPECTATIONS OF CONSUMERS WHILE
MINIMIZING THE IMPACTS.
OF WASTE WATER INFRASTRUCTURE IN
THE ENVIRONMENT AND TO THAT END
THE ONLY VIABLE SOLUTIONS TO THE
PERSISTENT ISSUE OF WASTE WATER
SYSTEM CLOGS.
COME FROM SYSTEM STUDIES AND
WHAT TRIBES CONSUMER DISPOSABLE
BEHAVIOR WE'VE ALL SEEN THE
PICTURES OF THE BIG UGLY CLOGS
PULLED OUT OF SYSTEMS.
MANY SUCH PICTURES APPEAR TO
INVOLVE WIPES OR RACKING
MATERIAL THAT ARE WIDELY
REPORTED AS FLUSHABLE WIPES.
HOWEVER AFTER SEVERAL FORENSIC
ANALYSES OF ACCUMULATIONS AND
CLOGS IN THE UNITED STATES AND
U. K. MUNICIPAL SYSTEMS WE KNOW
THAT MOSTLY THIS IS.
A CASE OF MISTAKEN IDENTITY.
THESE WASTEWATER COLLECTION
STUDIES INDICATE THAT THE
FLASHING OF NON FLUSHABLE SUCH
AS BABY WIPES SURFACE WIPES AND
SANITARY PIPES ARE THE PRIMARY
CAUSE OF THE OF THE CLOGS IN THE
SEWER SYSTEMS NOT FLUSHABLE
WIPES FOR EXAMPLE.
A COMPREHENSIVE STUDY IN TWENTY
SIXTEEN IN NEW YORK CITY
ADMINISTERED BY AN INDEPENDENT
ENGINEERING FIRM AT THE REQUEST
OF NEW YORK CITY LAW DEPARTMENT
FOUND FLUSHABLE WIPES WHERE THE
SMALLEST CATEGORY OF MATERIALS
COLLECTED AT 2%.
THIS SHOWS THAT THE IN THE FLESH
ABILITY GUIDELINES FOR FLUSHABLE
WIPES ACTUALLY WORK AS INTENDED
AND THAT FLUSHABLE WIPES ARE NOT
THE SOURCE OF THE PROBLEM
CONTRARY TO THE STATED PURPOSE
OF AB.
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO THE UNITED
KINGDOM STUDY OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN BY WATER U. K..
HOW YOU SIMILAR PROTOCOLS AND
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED MORE THAN
FIFTY CLOGS IN PUMPS SEWER
BLOCKAGES AND WASTE WATER
TREATMENT IN LET SAMPLES OVER A
PERIOD OF MORE THAN TWO MONTHS?
UPON COMPLETION RESEARCHERS
FOUND THAT FLUSHABLE WIPES
ACCOUNTED FOR A NEGLIGIBLE
AMOUNT OF IDENTIFY MATERIAL
MACHINE LABEL OF BABYSURFACE
AND OTHER WIPES IDENTIFIED AS
THE PROBLEM IN PRIMARY STUDIES.
THE BILL'S PRIMARY FOCUS ON ONE
CATEGORY OF FLUSHABLE WIPES
ACTUALLY DESIGNED AND ENGINEERED
TO BE SAFE THE FLASH IS A
QUESTIONABLE APPROACH TO THE
PROBLEM. FOR THIS REASON WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NO
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DON CAP KEEP Q. CAP CAN
ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION ALSO WITH
RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION.
OUR OPPOSITION IS BASED AS WELL
ON THE FORENSIC ANALYSES AS
REFERENCED -- BY AND THEY CHAU
FLUSHABLE WIPES OR NOT INDEED
THE CHIEF CONTRIBUTORS TO THESE
CLOGS -- AND THEREFORE WE DON'T
BELIEVE THAT THIS BILL AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO ADDRESSES
ARE THE PROBLEM.
A RECENT COLLABORATION BETWEEN
INDUSTRY IN THE JACKSONVILLE
ELECTRIC AUTHORITY WASTE WATER
SYSTEM IN JACKSONVILLE FLORIDA
IN MARCH OF JUST THIS YEAR FOUND
THAT BOTH WASTE WATER AND
INDUSTRY REPRESENTATIVES WORK
TOGETHER TO COLLECT AND ANALYZE
MATERIALS.
FROM THREE SEPARATE SETS OF BAR
SCREEN SAMPLES OVER A TWO DAY
PERIOD.
ONCE AGAIN FLUSHABLE WIPES AND
NOT STUDY FOUND TO OUGHT TO BE
LESS THAN 1% OF THE MATERIAL
COLLECTED AND ANALYZED.
COLLECTION STUDIES USING
FORENSIC ANALYSES IN PORTLAND
MAINE AND WE'RE A CALIFORNIA
SIMILARLY SHOWED FLUSHABLE WIPES
REPRESENT ONLY A SMALL PORTION.
OF MATERIALS COLLECTED AND
IDENTIFIED.
AND NOTED -- BY THE PROPONENTS I
DOUBT IT WAS REFERENCE -- TO
FROM THE CALIFORNIA STATE WATER.
RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD SANITARY
SEWER OVERFLOW REDUCTION PROGRAM
WHICH ALSO NOTABLY DESPITE THE
NUMBERS MENTIONED IS JUST
REPRESENTS JUST A DE MINIMUS
AMOUNT OF THE KIND OF THOSE
ISSUES AS REPORTED BY THE STATE
WATER BOARD'S OWN DATA.
AND ILLUSTRATES AT THE END OF
FLEXIBILITY STANDARDS ARE INDEED
WORKING WELL.
NOT DOT APPEARS THAT OUT. FOR
THE COMPREHENSIVE FIELD STUDIES
IN FORENSIC ANALYSES AS WELL AS
THE STATE'S DATA COMBINED SHOW
THE END OF FLEXIBILITY
GUIDELINES TO BE SUFFICIENT FOR
PROTECTING MUNICIPAL WASTE WATER
SYSTEMS.
THIS IS WHY COUNTRIES SUCH AS
SPAIN BELGIUM NETHERLANDS AND
GERMANY ARE STEADILY INCREASING
KEY STANDARDS RATHER THAN THE
FAULTY STANDARDS THAT WE ARE
CONCERNED -- IN THIS BILL.
THE BILL STANDARDS OF FASHION
EFFECTIVELY BANNED FLUSHABLE
WIPES IN CALIFORNIA BASICALLY
ALL FLUSHABLE WIPES CURRENTLY ON
THE U. S. MARKET A PRODUCT WHEN
WE SPUR SYSTEMS STUDIES AND
STATES DATA TO NOT BE A PROBLEM.
WE WOULD ASK THE PROPONENTS WHY
CHOOSING A BAND OF WHAT IS NO
MORE THAN 2% OF THE PROBLEM
RATHER THAN COMMITTING TO A
TARGETED STRATEGY ON 98% OF THE
PROBLEM.
IS THE DIRECTION WE'RE HEADED UP
WITH THE FOR THESE REASONS THAT
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR NEW
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
THE SEARCH AREA THREE MILLION ON
BEHALF OF THE GROCERY
MANUFACTURERS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
MORNING SHARING COMMITTEE ADAM
REGULAR AND AFTER THE CALIFORNIA
CHAMBER OF COMMERCE WE ALIGN
WITH SEEM TA AND I NDA WERE
OPPOSED THANKS THANK YOU ANYONE
ELSE IN OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SEE NONE OF BRING IT BACK
TO THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS -- ON
MY VERY MANY LEE ON BEHALF OF
THE PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
CANCEL ANY OUR COMMENTS.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS.
PRICING THAT MISTER BLOOM --
PROPS YOU CAN ADDRESS THE
SERVICE THEY MISS THE OPPOSITION.
SMITH GOVERNOR TO DO THAT OF
COURSE SO -- I THINK THERE'S
JUST A FUNDAMENTAL DISAGREEMENT
ON THE RESEARCH -- HERE -- THAT
WE FEEL THAT THE RESEARCH THAT
THE INDUSTRY PRESENTS AS
SOMEWHAT FLAWED AND WE OBJECT TO
MANY OF THE KLUTE CONCLUSIONS
IT IS BOTH THE FLUSHABLE.
AND NON FLUSHABLE WIPES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THE PROBLEMS -- IN
THE SYSTEMS AND FOR PUBLIC
AGENCIES AND WE ALSO KNOW BASED
ON SOME FIELD STUDIES THAT HAVE
BEEN DONE SPECIFIC TO THE
FLUSHABLE WIPES CATEGORY -- THAT
WHEN WE DROP -- A VARIETY OF
FLUSHABLE WIPES INTO THE SYSTEM
THEY DO COME THROUGH INTACT SOME
OF THE WIPES ARE HIGH PERFORMERS
AND THEY COME THROUGH AND
DISPERSE BUT OF A LARGE AMOUNT
DO COME THROUGH AND TAX SO THAT
TELLS US THAT AND THEY ARE NOT
PERFORMING -- THE WAY THAT THEIR
INTENDED TO PERFORM AND THAT'S A
STUDY DONE IN A FIELD OUTSIDE OF
THE LABORATORY SETTING SO WE
KNOW THAT -- THEY ARE MAKING IT --
THROUGH THE SYSTEM SO -- THAT'S
WHY WE HAVE INTENDED TO ADDRESS
THE WHOLE SUITE OF PRODUCTS BY
ADDRESSING LABELING OF BOTH THE
NON FLUSHABLE.
AND FLUSHABLE MARKETED -- WHAT
WHITE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
ALRIGHT THIS WILL BE MY CLOSE.
THANK YOU I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR RIVAL.
THANK YOU.
WE DO HAVE THE MOST -- NOW
LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
THANK YOU AND THE SECOND MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAU.
CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS AYE HOLDEN.
IN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS
PETRIE-NORRIS AYE REYES.
AYE REYES AYE.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISTER BILL OF RIGHTS MS
CARILLO YOU HAVE TO BILLS WORTH.
YEAH GIVE A PREFERENCE FOR WHICH
YOU'D LIKE TO TAKE UP FIRST.
RIGHT LET'S START WITH ITEM
NUMBER SIX THEN AB.
SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT MORNING
GOOD MORNING.
HELLO GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE TO PRESENT
ASSEMBLY BILL SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
A BILL THAT ADDRESSES THE
UNLAWFUL WORKPLACE PAID
DIFFERENCES. FOR EMPLOYEES OF
ALL GENDERS OUR CURRENT EQUAL
PAY INSURERS THAT EMPLOYEES OF
DIFFERENT GENDER RACE AND
ETHNICITY THROUGH PERFORM
SIMILAR WORK ARE PAID FAIRLY.
THE LAW ALSO DISCOURAGES PAY
SECRECY BY PROHIBITING
RETALIATION OR DISCRIMINATION
AGAINST EMPLOYEES WHO DISCUSS
THEIR INCOME.
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT THREATENS
OUR FAIR PAY ACT BY REMOVING THE
GENDER BINARY TERMINOLOGY THE US
INCORPORATING.
NON BINARY PEOPLE INTO THESE
PROTECTIONS AND CLARIFYING THAT
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE HAVE ALWAYS
BEEN AND WILL CONTINUE TO BE
PROTECTED.
THIS BILL ALSO SPECIFIES THAT
ONE THE WORKER FILING A CLAIM AS
ONLY ESTABLISHED THAT THEY WERE
PAID LESS THAN A SINGLE EMPLOYEE
OF ANOTHER SEX OR RACE.
AND TO WORKERS HAVE A ONE YEAR
OF A FILING DEADLINE FOR
ADMINISTRATIVE RETALIATION
CLAIMS LIKE THEY DO FOR CIVIL
RETALIATION CLAIMS.
WHILE GENDER NON CONFORMING AND
TRANSGENDER PEOPLE HAVE ALWAYS
OCCUPIED OUR WORKPLACE THEY HAVE
NOT ALWAYS BEEN LEGALLY
RECOGNIZED OR PROTECTED.
THESE PROTECTIONS ARE NECESSARY
AS SHOWN IN THE NATIONAL CENTER
FOR TRANSGENDER EQUALITY SURVEY
WHICH REPORTED THAT ONE OUT OF
EVERY THREE TRANS GENDER
RESPONDENTS REPORTED BEING FIRED.
DENIED A PROMOTION OR MISTREATED
BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER.
ADDITIONALLY WORKERS HAVE ONE
YEAR TO FILE A CIVIL RETALIATION
COMPLAINING PORTS UNDER THE
EQUAL PAY ACT.
BUT SIX MONTHS TO FILE
ADMINISTRATIVE RETALIATION
CLAIMS WE MUST PROVIDE THE SAME
FILING DEADLINES REGARDLESS OF
WHICH ROUTE A WORKER CHOOSES TO
PURSUE.
HERE TO TESTIFY IS TAMMY MARTIN
LEGISLATIVE MANAGER OF EQUALITY
CALIFORNIA JESSICA STERN -- WHO
IS A SENIOR STAFF ATTORNEY AT
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES?
AND HER CLIENT CAROL HANDED.
THANK YOU THANK WORST WITNESS
PLEASE.
MISTER CHAIR AND COMMITTEE
MEMBERS TAMMY MARTIN ON BEHALF
OF EQUALITY CALIFORNIA THE STATE
WIDE LGBTQ CIVIL RIGHTS
ORGANIZATION AND PROUD CO
SPONSOR OF AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
WHICH REFLECTS CALIFORNIA'S
RESPECT FOR ITS DIVERSE
POPULATION.
AND UPDATES THE OUTDATED IT
GENDER BINARY LANGUAGE IN THE
STATE'S EQUAL PAY ACT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WE
SPONSORED THE GENDER RECOGNITION
ACT WHICH ENABLED MORE PEOPLE TO
OBTAIN A STATE ISSUED IDENTITY
DOCUMENTS THAT ACCURATELY.
REFLECT THEIR GENDER IDENTITY BY
CREATING A THIRD NON BINARY
GENDER MARKER.
AND THE CURRENT LANGUAGE OF THE
CALIFORNIA'S EQUAL PAY ACT.
PROHIBITS EMPLOYERS FROM PAYING
AN EMPLOYEE LESS THAN AN
EMPLOYEE OF THE OPPOSITE SEX FOR
SUBSTANTIALLY SIMILAR WORK SO AB
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WILL UPDATE
THIS OUTDATED BINARY LANGUAGE TO
ENSURE THAT EMPLOYEES OF ALL.
GENDERS AND GENDER EXPRESSIONS
ARE PAID EQUITABLY.
AND WE KNOW THAT LGBT Q. PEOPLE
AND TRANS GENDER AND NON BINARY
PEOPLE IN PARTICULAR HAVE
HISTORICALLY FACED HIGH LEVELS
OF SOCIETAL STIGMA AND
DISCRIMINATION.
A RECENT STUDY REVEALED PATTERNS
OF DISCRIMINATION AGAINST
TRANSGENDER NON BINARY PEOPLE IN
A VARIETY OF SETTINGS INCLUDING
WORK PLACES. ONE OUT OF EVERY
THREE RESPONDENTS REPORTED BEING
FIRED TONIGHT A PROMOTION OR
OTHERWISE BEING MISTREATED AT
WORK BECAUSE OF THEIR GENDER
IDENTITY OR EXPRESSION.
AND THIS PERPETUATES THE CYCLE
OF ECONOMIC INSTABILITY FOR
TRANSGENDER AND NON BINARY
CALIFORNIANS ONE THIRD OF WHOM
LIVE IN POVERTY. EIGHTY SEVEN
FIFTY EIGHT IS A THOUGHTFUL
UNNECESSARY UPDATE TO EQUAL PAY
LAWS AND WE THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CARILLO FOR ADVANCING
THIS CRITICAL LEGISLATION.
AND WE URGE THE COMMITTEE TO
SUPPORT AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JESSICA
CENTER AND I'M AN ATTORNEY EQUAL
RIGHTS ADVOCATES -- WE EMPHASIZE
THE NEED TO MAKE THE FILING TIME
LINES CONSISTENT FOR FILING A
RETALIATION CLAIM IN COURT -- OR
pTO THE LIMITATIONS THAT MANY
PEOPLE HAVE IN FINDING A LAWYER
TO ACTUALLY BRING UP RETALIATION
CLAIM IN COURT WITHOUT ALTERNATE
TO OUR CLIENT CORAL HAND IN --
TO SPEAK ABOUT THE ISSUE THE
THANKS WITH THIS PLEASE.
A GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF AB.
SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WHICH WAS A
PROVIDE IMPORTANT UPDATES AND
CLARIFICATIONS TO OUR STATE
EQUAL PAY LAW.
I WORKED FOR A MAJOR GOLF COURSE
BEACH RESORT FOR A YEAR AND A
HALF AS A ROTATIONAL MANAGER.
IN THAT POSITION I WORKED AT
SEVERAL DIFFERENT RESTAURANTS AT
THE RESORT ON A ROTATIONAL BASIS.
THE TIME THAT I WORKED THERE I
WORKED HARD I DID MY JOB WELL
AND I RECEIVED POSITIVE FEEDBACK
AND EVALUATIONS FOR MY
SUPERVISORS.
AFTER A LITTLE OVER A YEAR
WORKING THERE.
I CAME ACROSS A DOCUMENT A
SHARED SERVER THAT LISTED THE
SALARIES OF ALL THE MANAGERS.
AND REFLECTED DISPARITIES
BETWEEN MALE AND FEMALE MANAGERS
WITH THE MEN RECEIVING HIGHER
WAGES.
I IMMEDIATELY INFORM MY
SUPERVISOR THAT IT COME ACROSS
THE DOCUMENT IN THE OFFICES
DIGITAL FILES AND GIVEN.
THAT IT HAD SENSE OF WAGE
INFORMATION I THOUGHT IT SHOULD
PROBABLY BE PASSWORD PROTECTED.
I ALSO RAISE THE GENDER GENDER
WAGE DISPARITIES THAT REFLECTED
IN THE DOCUMENT WITH HR.
AS FAR AS I KNOW NO CHANGES IN
PAY WERE MADE AFTER A REPORTED
THE PAY.
DISPARITIES A FEW MONTHS LATER I
DECIDED TO TAKE ANOTHER JOB
BECAUSE IT PAID MORE.
DURING MY EXIT INTERVIEW THE H.
WAS LEAVING I TOLD HER THAT I
LOVE MY JOB.
AND THAT THE REASON I WAS
LEAVING WAS THAT I WAS BEING
PAID TOO LITTLE AND BECAUSE OF
THE PAY DISPARITIES THAT I HAD
SEEN IN THE DOCUMENT.
NATURE REPRESENTATIVE THEN TOLD
ME THAT MY SUPERVISOR WAS NO
VERY UPSET WITH ME FOR HAVING
RAISE THE ISSUE OF PAY.
I EXPLAINED THAT I HADN'T ACTED
WITH ANY MALICE.
I'D SIMPLY REPORTED THE ISSUE TO
HR BECAUSE THEY FELT IT WAS THE
RIGHT THING TO DO.
THE NEW JOB DIDN'T WORK OUT AS I
HAD HOPED SO AFTER A FEW MONTHS
I'VE APPLIED FOR SEVERAL OPEN
POSITIONS WITH MY FORMER
EMPLOYER I WAS ALREADY TRAINED
AND HAD EXPERIENCE IN ALL OF THE
POSITIONS THAT I APPLIED.
HOWEVER AFTER MONTHS OF WAITING
AND THE POSITIONS STILL BEING
OPEN.
I DID NOT HEAR BACK ABOUT ANY OF
MY APPLICATIONS.
I WAS CONFUSED AND UPSET BECAUSE
I HAD BEEN A GREAT EMPLOYEE I
FELT A TO HANDLE THE SITUATION
PROFESSIONALLY.
BY REPORTING TO PAY PROBLEM THAT
I DISCOVERED.
MY FORMER SUPERVISOR HAD EMAILED
ME PRIOR TO MY DEPARTURE SAYING
THAT HE WOULD CERTAINLY WELCOME
ME BACK IF THIS NEW OPPORTUNITY
DIDN'T WORK OUT.
IT WAS CLEAR TO ME EVENTUALLY
BUT THEY WERE NOT CONTACTED ME
ABOUT THE OPEN POSITIONS BECAUSE
I HAD RATES RAISE THE ISSUE OF
EQUAL PAY.
APPROXIMATELY FIVE MONTHS AFTER
I FIRST RE APPLIED TO WORK FOR
THE COMPANY.
I FILED A WAGE CLAIM AND
RETALIATION CLAIM UNDER THE
EQUAL PAY ACT WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
AN INVESTIGATOR CONTACTED ME
ABOUT THE EQUAL PAY CLAIM BUT I
WAS NOT CONTACTED ABOUT THE
RETALIATION CLAIM.
DESPITE MAKING REPEATED
INQUIRIES.
I FINALLY LEARNED THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER HAD DISMISSED MY
RETALIATION CLAIM.
ON THE GROUNDS THAT WAS FILED
MORE THAN SIX MONTHS AFTER THE
END OF MY EMPLOYMENT.
I FILED AN APPEAL ON THE GROUNDS
OF THE DEADLINE FOR THE
RETALIATION CLAIM IS ONE YEAR AS
MY STATS AS STATED IN THE
STATUTE I DID NOT RECEIVE ANY
RESPONSE FROM THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
ABOUT MY APPEAL OF THE
RETALIATION DISMISSAL DESPITE
REACHING OUT MULTIPLE TIMES.
FINALLY THE INVESTIGATOR WHO IS
INVESTIGATING MY EQUAL PAY CLAIM
TOLD ME THAT THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER WAS UNABLE TO RE
OPEN THE CLAIM AND THEN I COULD
REACH OUT TO THE RETALIATION
PUBLIC LINE FOR MORE INFORMATION.
I SENT MULTIPLE REQUESTS AND
RETALIATION PUBLIC LINE BUT I
HAVE NOT HEARD BACK ONCE.
I FILE MAKE IT WILL PLAY AND
RETALIATION CLAIMS WITH THE
LABOR COMMISSIONER BECAUSE I
COULDN'T FIND A LAWYER.
AND WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO
FILE A LAWSUIT ON MY OWN.
I THINK WORKERS SHOULD HAVE THE
SAME AMOUNT OF TIME TO FILE A
RETALIATION CLAIM WITH THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER.
AS THEY HAVE TO FILE IN COURT.
IT WORKERS ABILITY TO FIND A
LAWYER AND FILE A LAWSUIT SHOULD
NOT DICTATE THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THAT SHE HAS TO SEEK JUSTICE FOR
BEING RETALIATED AGAINST.
AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT WOULD
CLARIFY THAT THE FILING DEADLINE
FOR THESE CLAIMS IS THE SAME
REGARDLESS OF THE FORM AND I
URGE YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU FOR GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
ABOUT MY SITUATION [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT.
IF YOU ARE ON THE TOP OF THE
THERE'S ASSOCIATION PART BECAUSE
ONCE AS OF THIS BILL ARCHER
SUPPORT.
THE MORNING CHANCES CALLING ON
BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
FOR CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT ALSO A
CO SPONSOR.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RISKS OVER TOLD SANTA CLARA
COUNTY WHICH HAVE COALITION AND
CATHERINE AND GEORGE ALEXANDER
COMMUNITY LAW CENTER IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU NO ONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
MISTER OBERNOLTE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO -- IN
ADDITION TO THE GENDER IDENTITY
CHANGES TO STATE LAWYER ALSO
PROPOSING TO CHANGE THE BURDEN
OF PROOF ON EMPLOYER FROM A
GROUP OF EMPLOYEES TO A SINGLE
EMPLOYEE.
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHY YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO THAT AND WHY THAT'S
NECESSARY [inaudible]
HI.
SO -- THE LONGSTANDING
INTERPRETATION OF THE BOTH
FEDERAL EQUAL PAY ACT AND THE
CALIFORNIA EAGLE PACK WHICH HAS
BEEN MODELED AFTER THE FEDERAL
EQUAL PAY ACT IS THAT A SINGLE
EMPLOYEE USE BRING ANY CO PACK
LAID NEEDS ONLY TO FIND.
ONE COMPARATOR -- I BELIEVE THAT
THAT'S REFLECTED THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS THE CASE LAW THAT THAT
THAT SUPPORTS THAT THE
INTERPRETATION OF NEED ONLY --
ONE COMPARED OR EMPLOYEE -- THE
STATUTE ITSELF HAS A SEVEN
POISONS OR MERELY CLARIFYING IT
TO SAY NGUYEN PLEASE SINGULAR TO
REFLECT WHAT THE CASE LAWS WERE
HAS HAS HELD FOR MANY YEARS.
OKAY THANK YOU SO I ACTUALLY
DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
GENDER IDENTITY PORTIONS OF THAT
WATER IDEA IN SUPPORT IF THAT
WAS IN THERE.
I DISAGREE WITH YOUR ANALYSIS OF
OUR CURRENT CASE LAW -- THERE
FOR ABOUT TO BE RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION BUT IT'S A SHAME
BECAUSE I WOULD LIKE TO BEEN
WITH WITH YOU ON THIS BECAUSE I
AGREE WITH 90% OF WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS
COMMENTS.
RIGHT SEE NONE THIS CAREER YOU
MAY CLOSE THANK YOU AND THANK
YOU MISTER OBERNOLTE FOR THAT
THAT'S CERTAINLY SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WILLING TO LOOK AT AS A
SMALL MOVES FORWARD.
BECAUSE WE ARE TRYING TO UPDATE
THE LAW TO MAKE SURE THAT EVERY
WORKER IN CALIFORNIA REGARDLESS
OF GENDER ETHNICITY RACE CREED
IS PROTECTED EQUALLY UNDER THE
LAW SO THANK YOU FOR THAT.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY TEAM ON
THIS AS WELL AND THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU WE DO NEED A MOTION
THE MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
CALL THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY
STONE AYE GALLAGHER -- NO CHAU
[inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE RADIUS.
REYES I AS SEVEN DOES IT IS OUT
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH SO
WE WILL NOW MOVE TO ITEM NUMBER
TWENTY TWO AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE EVERYONE
.
YOUR LAST NAME.
WELL GOOD MORNING AGAIN CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I'M HERE 2% AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE A BILL
THAT INSURANCE IMMIGRANTS ONLY
RECEIVE A HIGHLY IMPORTANT LEGAL
ADVICE FROM INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE
THE LEGAL EDUCATION AND
EXPERTISE TO PROVIDE SUCH
ASSISTANCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO BEGIN BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE STAFF
AGAIN FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
ANALYSIS I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
TWELVE OF THE ANALYSIS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS AT OTHERWISE KNOWN
AS THE I. C. A. REGULATES
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAVE PROVIDE WHO
PROVIDE IMMIGRATION ASSISTANCE.
AND ARE NEITHER ATTORNEYS NOR
ACCREDITED BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
THE I EE A AUTHORIZES
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS TO
COMPLETE IMMIGRATION FORMS UNDER
CERTAIN CONDITIONS BUT PROHIBITS
THEM PROVIDE FROM PROVIDING
LEGAL ADVICE OR REPRESENTING
CLIENTS.
IN AN IMMIGRATION COURT IN JUNE
OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN FEDERAL
POLICY WAS MODIFIED THAT PUTS
IMMIGRANTS AT A GREATER RISK OF
DEPORTATION BY ALLOWING
OFFICIALS TO START THE
DEPORTATION PROCESS. FOR TO
NIGHT IMMIGRATION PETITIONS AND
TO REFER CASES TO THE
IMMIGRATIONS.
AND CUSTOMS ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
OTHERWISE KNOWN AS ICE NO
CRIMINAL OR SECURITY GROUNDS.
THIS IS IMPORTANT TO MY DISTRICT
BECAUSE ACCORDING TO THE US
CENSUS NEARLY 35% OF LA COUNTY.
TEN MILLION RESIDENTS WERE BORN
IN ANOTHER COUNTRY MYSELF
INCLUDED.
ESTIMATES FURTHER INDICATE THAT
APPROXIMATELY NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS IMMIGRANTS LIVE IN LA
COUNTY.
MORE THAN ANY OTHER COUNTY IN
OUR STATE. FOR THESE VULNERABLE
COMMUNITIES HIRING AND
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS OFTEN
COST LESS THAN HIRING AND AN
ATTORNEY.
BUT THE RISK OF POTENTIAL
DEPORTATION AND THE DENIAL OF
CITIZENSHIP OR RESIDENCY
INVOLVING HIRING A LOWER COST
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT.
FAR OUTWEIGHS THE COST BENEFIT.
THE CURRENT EXPANDED DISCRETION
OF FEDERAL OFFICIALS TO DENY
IMMIGRATION APPLICATIONS LEAVES
NO ROOM FOR ERROR.
IN THE ACCURACY SUBMISSION AND
COMPLETENESS OF IMMIGRATION
APPLICATIONS.
AND E. IN OF ERRORS CAN BE
RECTIFIED.
AFFECTED IMMIGRANT VICTIMS OFTEN
LACK THE ABILITY TO CORRECT
THESE MISTAKES.
BE IT FOR LACK OF RESOURCES FEAR
OF RETALIATION OR A VERY REAL
DISTRUST OF OUR FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AT THIS MOMENT.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
ADDRESSES THIS ISSUE BY MAKING
IT UNLAWFUL FOR A PERSON OTHER
THAN A LICENSED ATTORNEY OR A
PERSON.
OR ORGANIZATION FEDERALLY
AUTHORIZED TO REPRESENT
INDIVIDUALS IN IMMIGRATION
MATTERS TO PROVIDE IMMIGRATION
RELATED SERVICES FOR A FEE AND
CALIFORNIA.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT IS
CHASE OF NIKITA DIRECTOR OF THE
LA COUNTY DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER
AND BUSINESS AFFAIRS.
WHO HAVE ASK IS PROFESSOR OF
SOUTHWESTERN SCHOOL OF LAW AND
DANIEL SHARP THE LEGAL DIRECTOR
OF THE CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE
CENTER TO PROVIDE TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE?
I THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M WE HAVE THAT FAITH
ASSOCIATE CLINICAL PROFESSOR OF
LAW AT SOUTHWESTERN LAW SCHOOL.
I'VE DEDICATED MY CAREER TO
TEACHING IMMIGRATION LAW AND
PRACTICING IMMIGRATION LAW ONE
OF THE MOST COMPLEX AREAS OF US
LAW.
THE TIME HAS COME TO OVERHAUL
THE CALIFORNIA IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS ACT WHICH WAS PASSED
OVER THIRTY YEARS AGO UNDER A
VERY DIFFERENT IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM.
UNDER TODAY'S IMMIGRATION LAWS
MOST UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS DO
NOT QUALIFY FOR RELIEF.
I OFTEN IS THIS IMMIGRANTS
WHO'VE ALREADY FALLEN VICTIM TO
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
DECEPTIVE AN UNSCRUPULOUS
PRACTICES.
IMMIGRANTS ARE OFTEN AN
UNDERSTANDABLY CONFUSED BY THE
TERM IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT.
AND THEY'RE OFTEN LED TO BELIEVE
THAT THE TERM DENOTES A FORM OF
EXPERTISE IN IMMIGRATION LAW.
CONSEQUENCES OF IT IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT FILING A BOTCHED OR
ILL ADVISED APPLICATION ARE
DEVASTATING.
THEY CAN INCLUDE IMMIGRANTS
BEING PLACED IN REMOVAL
PROCEEDINGS DEPORTATION
PROCEEDINGS AND POSSIBLY
DETENTION.
SURELY BE SIX ARE TOO HIGH. FOR
MERELY A BONDS AND A BACKGROUND
CHECK WHICH IS THE LOW BAR UNDER
THE CURRENT ACT.
IMMIGRATION FORM PREPARATION IS
NO LONGER A SIMPLE SERVICE AND
IT REQUIRES LEGAL ADVICE.
I RECENTLY CONDUCTED A THOROUGH
ANALYSIS OF THE CURRENT US
IMMIGRATION FORMS COMMONLY FILED
BY IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS I
FOUND THAT ONLY ONE FORM A SHORT
HALF PAGE CHANGE OF ADDRESS FORM.
CAN ACCURATELY BE COMPLETED WITH
OUT THE PROVISION OF LEGAL
ADVICE.
SOMETHING WHICH IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS CAN NOT STATUTORILY
PROVIDE.
YES IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS
ROUTINELY IGNORE THESE LIMITS
AND PLACE IMMIGRANTS AT RISK.
IT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO DIVORCE
IMMIGRATION FORM PREPARATION
FROM THE PROVISION OF LEGAL
ADVICE.
AND CALIFORNIA'S SHOULD NO
LONGER SANCTION A SYSTEM THAT
IGNORES THIS REALITY.
THE IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS ACT
IT'S OUTDATED AND PLACES
IMMIGRANTS AT E. WEBER BOWL RISK.
I ENCOURAGE YOU TO SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE AND
CONTINUE CALIFORNIA'S ADMIRABLE
PATH OF PROTECTING ITS IMMIGRANT
COMMUNITIES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE
GOOD MORNING MR CHEN MEMBERS
JONI KEYED ON BEHALF OF THE LA
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AS
CO SPONSOR.
OF AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE I'M THE
DIRECTOR OF THE LA COUNTY
DEPARTMENT OF CONSUMER AND
BUSINESS AFFAIRS MY DEPARTMENT
IS RESPONSIBLE FOR PROTECTING
OVER TEN MILLION CONSUMERS IN LA
COUNTY.
AND SUPPORTING BUSINESSES TO
CREATE A FAIR AND THRIVING
MARKET PLACE I WANT TO THANK
MEMBER CREEL FOR ADVANCING THIS
IMPORTANT BILL.
AND THINK PROFESSOR VASQUEZ FOR
HER TESTIMONY IN AS THE CHILD OF
IMMIGRANTS THIS IS ALSO
PERSONALLY IMPORT FOR ME AS WELL.
YOU'VE JUST HEARD HOW DIFFICULT
IT IS FOR IMMIGRANTS TO NAVIGATE
OUR IMMIGRATION SYSTEM AND
AGAINST THIS BACKDROP.
AND BASED ON OUR EXPERIENCE IN
LA COUNTY THE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT ACT IS BAD FOR
CONSUMERS.
MOST CONSUMERS ENGAGE IN
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT BECAUSE
THEY NEED SUBSTANTIVE HELP THEY
MAY HAVE A GENERAL UNDERSTANDING
OF WHAT OF WHAT THEY WANT TO
ACHIEVE.
LIKE GETTING A GREEN CARD BUT
THEY WON'T KNOW HOW TO HAD IT
THEY ONE OF THE QUALIFY THEY
WON'T KNOW HOW TO GO ABOUT
APPLYING -- WHAT FORMS TO FILL
OUT A WHAT PROCEDURES TO FOLLOW?
UP BUT FOR GOOD REASON THE I. C.
FOR BIDS A CONSULTANT FROM
PROVIDING THAT SUBSTANTIVE HELP
AND THIS PUTS THE CONSULTANT.
IN THE UNTENABLE POSITION OF
LETTING CONSUMERS GAS AND HOW TO
PROCEED OR ATTEMPTING TO GUIDE
WERE ADVISED THE CONSUMER IN
VIOLATION OF THE I SEE A BOTH OF
WHICH COULD HAVE CATASTROPHIC
OUTCOMES FOR THE CONSUMER.
SOME OF OUR DATA FROM LA COUNTY
BEARS THIS OUT.
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE MY
DEPARTMENT HAS LOGGED OVER EIGHT
HUNDRED COMPLAINTS INVOLVING
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS MORE
THAN TWO HUNDRD AND SEVENTY
LAST YEAR ALONE.
I'VE HEARD IT SAID THE
COMPLAINTS TYPICALLY INVOLVE
CONSULTANTS WHO ARE NOT BONDED
UNDER THE ICY BUT THAT DOES NOT
REFLECT.
OUR EXPERIENCE IN THE COUNTY.
OUR DATA SHOWS UP FOR
CONSULTANTS WHO HAD FOUR OR MORE
COMPLAINTS AGAINST THEM INTO A
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE IN OTHER
WORDS THE REPEAT OFFENDERS.
UP 55% OF THOSE WERE OR ARE
BONDED AT IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
I. CA ONE SUCH CONSULTANT HAD
OVER EIGHTY THREE COMPLAINTS
HIMSELF ALONG WITH OUR
DEPARTMENT BUT HE HAD HUNDREDS
OF VICTIMS COME FORWARD -- WHEN
IT CASES BROUGHT AGAINST THEM?
SINCE TWENTY FIFTEEN THE LA
COUNTY DA HAS CHARGED NUMEROUS
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS OF
VARIOUS CRIMES THEY VICTIMIZE
MORE THAN THREE HUNDRED PEOPLE
WHO COLLECTIVELY LOST OVER THREE
MILLION DOLLARS AND THAT'S JUST
THE LA COUNTY DA DOES REFLECT
OTHER.
PROSECUTING.
LOOK WE'VE TRIED TO AMENDED THE
I SEE A AT LEAST ELEVEN TIMES
SINCE NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WITH
OVER THIRTY SUBSTANTIVE CHANGES
TO STRENGTHEN CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS.
GET COMPLAINTS CONTINUE TO
INCREASE.
THERE ARE OTHER OPTIONS OUT
THERE FOR IMMIGRANTS ATTORNEYS
AND FEDERALLY ACCREDITED
NONPROFITS WHO CAN HELP.
AND I ALSO IN CLOSING WOULD LIKE
TO CHALLENGE THE NOTION THAT
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS PROVIDE
LOW COST ALTERNATIVES TO
ATTORNEYS.
THAT'S REALLY AN APPLES TO
ORANGES COMPARISON IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS CANNOT PROVIDE.
THE LEGAL ADVICE NEEDED TO HELP
CONSUMERS IN TODAY'S IMMIGRATION
LANDSCAPE EVEN SMALL ERRORS ON
WAS PERCEIVED AS A ROUTINE
MATTER.
COULD HAVE SOME SERIOUS ADVERSE
OUTCOMES AS REFLECTED IN THE
BILL ANALYSIS OF WHAT THAT I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR YES
VOTE.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US WITH.
I'M HERE FOR TECHNICAL
ASSISTANCE ONLY SO RIGHT THANK
YOU.
NO ONE ELSE LIKE TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS MADELINE
AND I'M FROM SAN FERNANDO VALLEY
AND I'M FROM THE G. Là AN I'M
HERE TO SUPPORT AB. SEVENTY
FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS NORMAN
WITH ONLINE SO.
MANY THROUGH SHOWN AS FORTY TWO
LEARNING HI SUPPORT LARA.
AB SEVENTEEN SEP FIFTY THREE
THANK YOU.
WHEN OF THEIR MINIMUM MILLION
UNDER THING LESS OPEN ON THE
WIDELY -- GOING CHILDREN.
HE YOUR BY A STEP FOR YOUR UPPER
BUT THE YES HE ADMITTED AS HE
SHOULD THE SINK WHEN THEY THREE
THANK YOU.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN SUPPORT.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
HELLO MY NAME IS BUT THAT IS A
FELLOW SIDE A FROM PALM THEN M.
FROM TO LET TOLL IN A TO PUT IT
THE A. B.. SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE
ONE OF THE ASK ME NUMBER SEVEN
MIGHT BE AN ISSUE IN THE BAND
WHILE I CENTERS.
BUT A LOT OF IT.
THIS IS IT THIS HE WENT BACK THE
BEST THING WAS A THREAT OR
SOMETHING IS GOING.
TO WELL I MEAN NUMBER IT'S A
MATTER OF THE PLAN FOR YOU THINK
WHAT FOR YOUNGER THAT.
I HAVE A THE A CITIZEN WHEN THEY
THOUGHT IF THEY LAWCENTER.
HELLO MY NAME IS BRIAN WHO STILL
I'M FROM LOS ANGELES I'M PART OF
WISE OF WHICH WORKS IT'S YOUR
AND I SUPPORT THE SEVENTEEN
FIFTY THREE HI MY NAME IS RICK
HELDER FULLER I AM FROM PALMDALE
AND I'M A MEMBER OF CHIRLA AND I
SUPPORT -- AB.
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE I ALSO
FEEL THE FLOW FROM PALMDALE I'M
MITCHELL ND I SUPPORT AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS ME THEY YEAH --
COMING YOU KNOW THEN THEY SAID
WITH CHILLING SOME BUT NOT
ENOUGH AND I'M SUPPORT AB.
FIFTY SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE MON
MAR AND THE NUMBER THE MORE
BECAUSE I WANNA.
EVEN WORSE [inaudible]
EARN.
WERE YOU ALONE HE SAID THIS WITH
IT THIS.
HI MY NAME IS CAROLINE I'M WHAT
I AM FROM CHILE AND NINE SUPPORT
LET SEVEN THE FIFTY THREE WHAT
ARE THE YES WE NOTICED THAT
MICROWAVING GO UP WE AND THE
LAST.
HAVE RAISED THE CITY WITH A
VAGUELY BUT THE CHEESE Là.
CHECK IT OUT.
WHEN OF FAMINE NUMBER SOUND THAT
CLOSE THEN GO UP I AM GOING TO
HAVE A SAY THIS IS YET THE THING
WENT BY IT THAT IS?
THEY'RE SO THEY'LL ORANGE.
GOING TO LETTING GO -- HI GOOD
MORNING MY NAME IS GOT THEIR
GARCIA YOUTH ORGANIZER WHICH YOU
LIE AND I STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
JAZZY GIRL WITH THE S. E. W.
ESSENCES COUNTS ON SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
HI MORNING UNIVERSE OF THE
CALIFORNIA ROOM TO SELLING IS
OFTEN SUPPORT.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH ARE THE
PROUD TO BE A SPONSOR.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DâN FULL
ASSAULT ON BEHALF THE LOS
ANGELES COUNTY DISTRICT
ATTORNEY'S OFFICE PLEASE TO CO
SPONSOR.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION PROUD CO
SPONSOR IN STRONG SUPPORT.
ACTUALLY ARE THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE ON BEHALF
OF JOURNEY GENERAL HOBBY OF THE
SENATE IN SUPPORT OF THE
OUTRIGHT BAN.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
VERY COURTEOUS HARLEM HALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA PLAN MILLERS
ASSOCIATION SUPPORT.
DOES THE CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION SUPPORT.
RUTH'S OVER TOBE -- CATHERINE
AND GEORGE ALEXANDER COMMUNITY
LAWCENTER AT SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY LAW SCHOOL AND SANTA
CLARA COUNTY WHICH THE COALITION
IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEN THAT IS THEIR
OPPOSITION.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO COME UP TO THE
TABLE COULD YOU MAKE SOME ROOM.
HI MY NAME IS ERIN RAY BURKE AND
I REPRESENT THE NATIONAL NOTARY
ASSOCIATION AND A PORTION OF
WHICH WE'VE -- WORK WITH THE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS AND WE
HAVE A LOT IN THE ROOM TODAY
INCLUDING TWO AT THE TABLE -- IN
FRONT AND I MOSTLY HERE FOR
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS AND
ASSISTANCE BUT IT BEFORE I TURN
IT OVER.
I JUST WANT TO ADD THAT
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE LIKE ITS
PREDECESSOR AB SIX THIRTY EIGHT
IS ANTI IMMIGRANT AND THAT'S WHY
WE WERE.
FIRST SIX THIRTY EIGHT WE HAD
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS GROUPS ON BOTH
SIDES OF THE BILL AND THAT'S WHY
IT DIED SUCH A PAINFUL DEATH ON
THE SENATE FLOOR.
BECAUSE WE HAD GROUPS AND STRONG
OPPOSITION TO IT AND THEY'RE
SIMPLY ASKING THE PROPONENTS AND
THE AUTHOR TO WORK WITH US TO
ADD TRAINING STANDARDS IN
EDUCATION STANDARDS.
WHICH WE HAVE BEEN WILLING TO DO
RATHER THAN GETTING THROWING
AWAY AN ENTIRE INDUSTRY THAT DID
HELP TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
IMMIGRANTS LAST YEAR.
AND WITH THAT I'LL TURN IT OVER.
THANK YOU SIX WITNESS PLEASE.
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS SALLY I TRY THIS AND
I HAVE BEEN IN IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT FOR THE PAST TWENTY
FIVE YEARS.
I WORKED AS A LIAISON CONSULAR
THE DAVIS SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR
MANY YEARS IN MY INVOLVEMENT
WITH THE SPANISH SPEAKING
PARENTS I REALIZE THE NEED FOR
SERVICE PROVIDERS IN THE
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
I WENT TO SAN FRANCISCO CITY
COLLEGE TO EDUCATE MYSELF
THROUGH IMMIGRATION LEGAL
RESOURCE CENTER.
I STARTED TEACHING CITIZENSHIP
CLASSES FOR PARENTS WHO AFTER
BECOMING CITIZENS.
I COMPANIES THE LEGALIZATION OF
THEIR OWN CHILDREN WHO WERE MY
STUDENTS AND EVENTUALLY
GRADUATED AND WENT ON TO COLLEGE.
THERE ARE THOUSAND SIXTEEN
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS WHO ARE
BONDED AND REGISTER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA SECRETARY OF STATE.
THEN.
THERE ARE THE BAD ACTORS WHO ARE
NOT LAWFULLY REGISTER WHO ARE
NOT BONDED TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC
NOR HAVE THEY BEEN FINGERPRINTED.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
NOT STOP THEM IT COULD END UP
CREATING MORE FRAUD.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE WILL
LEAVE MANY OF US UNJUSTLY
UNEMPLOYED AND FINANCIALLY
STRESS WE BELIEVE THAT WE HELP
THE STATE'S ECONOMY AS WELL AS
THE EMPLOYMENT INDUSTRY.
THE STATE WILL NOT BENEFIT FROM
THERE FROM THE AND BONDED BAD
ACTORS WE NEED IMMIGRATION
LAWYERS I ATTEND A YEAR YOU
SEMINAR TAUGHT BY IMMIGRATION
LAWYERS.
WE NEED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATIONS
BUT WE ALSO NEED EXPERIENCE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS IN GOOD
STANDINGS.
AB SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE WELL
HEARD IMMIGRANTS IF AFFORDABLE
NON LEGAL IMMIGRATION HELP IS
ELIMINATED.
IN AN IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT IS
NOT THE BUSINESS OF COMPETITION
BUT A BUSINESS OF COMPASSION.
I HAVE HELPED THOUSANDS AND
THOUSANDS OF IMMIGRANTS
ACCOMPLISH THEIR IMMIGRATION
DREAM.
SO AGAIN ON BEHALF.
OF THE THOUSAND SIXTEEN REGISTER
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS IN
CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK.%
FOR YOUR NO VOTE ON AB.
SEVENTEEN THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US PLEASE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- FOR
ALLOWING ME TO VOICE MY
OPPOSITION TO A. B. ONE SEVEN
FIVE THREE MY NAME IS NELLIE OF
A YES.
AND I AM I CONCEDE TO AND
TELEPHONE WILL NOT I WILL THEY
BE CHIU FROM SAN FRANCISCO.
I HAD BEING IT RAISED THEIR
IMMIGRATION CONSULT THEM FOR
TWENTY SIX YEARS IN THE SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA.
I WAS TRAINED BY THE IN WE GET A
LEGALLY SUBSTANTIVE TO PROVIDE
LOW INCOME IMMIGRANTS WITH
IMMIGRATION SERVICES THAT DO NOT
REQUIRE AN ATTORNEY.
I WAS AN ACCREDITED
REPRESENTATIVE AND WHAT CAN
PARTNERSHIP WITH CARY SENT TO
PROMOTE CITIZENSHIP THROUGH
CITIZENSHIP FAIRS.
I CONTINUED TO BE IN BUSINESS
THANKS TO PERSONALLY FERRIS.
THE CITY OF OAKLAND NAME AUGUST
ELEVEN THEN THE LATEST THEY AND
I RECEIVED THE PHILIP BARTON
IMMIGRATION AND CIVIL RIGHTS I
WORKED.
HOWEVER YOU HAVE NEVER HEARD OF
ME QUITE.
BECAUSE I AM A GOOD HONEST
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT.
YOU HEAR ABOUT THE BAD ONES.
BUT YOU DON'T HEAR ABOUT THE
WATER THAT THE OVER ONE THOUSAND
THREE YOU STUDY CONSULTANTS.
TO AND YOU WILL NEVER HEAR ABOUT
US IS THIS TO BE THE PROCESS.
BECAUSE WE WILL CLOSE OF
BUSINESS WEEK.
BUT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR
ABOUT THE BAD ONES.
THIS IS THE WRONG B. L. AT THE
WRONG TIME.
WHEN I A STEP THAT CALLING MY
CLIENT SERVER AB?
ONE SEVEN FIVE THREE THEY
IMMEDIATELY ASKED ME IF
PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS BEHIND.
THERE IS ALREADY A LOT OF FEAR
IN THE IMMIGRANT COMMUNITY.
AND THIS BILL WILL ELIMINATE
DUST A HOST WHO HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE.
I URGE YOU TO AMEND THE BILL.
DON'T THEY LEAVE ME LATER IN
STATE WATER WITH US TO FIND THE
SOLUTION.
WE HAVE OFFERED AMENDMENTS BUT
NO ONE WOULD LISTEN.
AB SEVEN WHAT. SEVENTEEN FIFTY
FIFTY THREE WILL HELP IMMIGRANTS.
AND THE GOOD THING TO GET ACTUAL
BUSINESS CUSSING FINANCIAL
HARDSHIP TO SINGLE MOTHERS.
PAYING PENALTIES FOR BREAKING A
LEASE NOT BEING ABLE TO PAY THE
RENT OR MORTGAGE.
WE WILL DISAPPEAR.
BUT YOU WILL CONTINUE TO HEAR
ABOUT THE FRAUD COMMITTED
AGAINST SENIOR.
I ASSURE YOU THAT.
THANK YOU FOR LISTENING.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION IF YOU
COULD GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION PLEASE.
YEAH I KNOW I'M FROM ORANGE
COUNTY.
OF I HAVE BEEN IN IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS
WE'RE NOT ABLE TO TAKE YOUR
TESTIMONY WAS TAKING AIM
AFFILIATION OKAY SAW THREE STUDY
ON A FROM ORANGE COUNTY AND I AM
AGAINST IT.
I WISH I COULD MAKE A FEW POINTS
BUT I'M NOT ALLOWED.
NO NOT AT THIS POINT OKAY.
GOOD MORNING TO KIND OF
AMERICA'S THE NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS ARE NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION WE STRONGLY OPPOSE
THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS THEIR MOTHER
GUIDELINE BEING A GONG A MISSION
CONSULTANT FOR THIRTY YEARS AND
I OPPOSE THE BILL.
EVERYTHING ABOUT CHAIR LANDING
OUT INTO THE BECAUSE SOME MONEY
THEY MADE SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
A YEAR [inaudible]
GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS A WITH A YES AND I'M
HERE ON BEHALF OF THE HOPS.
THE SPAWNING ASSOCIATION THE
PROFESSIONAL SERVICE HEY WE
DELIVER EDUCATION SINCE.
NINETEEN NINETY SIX SAY I HAVE
THE CERTIFICATION Và WE DO HAVE
CONTINUED EDUCATION.
I'M SORRY WE CANNOT TAKE MORE
TESTIMONY IS YOUR NAME YOUR
ANGER LEAVES AND AND THAT YOU'RE
THANK YOU I OPPOSE OKAY.
MY NAME'S ABIGAIL MARIA HERRERA
I AM THE DAUGHTER OF AN
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT AND I
OPPOSE THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS BETTER ESPINOZA
PERSONAL FIVE HOPS HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES MY POSTED THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS ROSE THAT ARE THE
BIGGEST FROM SAN DIEGO
CALIFORNIA ON BEHALF OF HISPANIC
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SERVICES AND I OPPOSE THE BILL.
MY NAME IS SOPHIE NORMAL FROM
SAN DIEGO AND AYE OPPOSED TO THE
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE MY NAME IS
MONICA TAPIA FROM.
THE SAN GABRIEL VALLEY A UP A MY
ENGLISH IMMIGRATION CONSULTED
AND OPPOSE THE BILL THANK YOU.
IT MIGHT BE ANOTHER FROM ON
MONNING AYE OPPOSED TO THE BILL.
JUGGLING BARRIOS FROM ORANGE
COUNTY AND I STRONGLY OPPOSE
THANK YOU.
GREG MCEWEN -- ON BEHALF OF THE
LATIN AMERICAN IMMIGRATION
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION OF THE
BILL.
MINE IS CARLOS SO DO I YOUR ON A
STRONG POSITION OF THE BILL.
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS ASSIMILATION
SOLD.
MY NAME IS GLENDA SILVA AND I'M
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT FOR
NINETEEN YEARS AND AYE OPPOSED
TO THE BILL.
MY NAME IS JOSEPHINE A RUN FROM
ORANGE COUNTY AND I OPPOSE THIS
BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS --
ACOSTA WITH HISPANIC COMMUNITY
SERVICES HAVE BEEN TEACHING
HISTORY CIVICS CLASS OF THE PAST
TEN YEARS.
I STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL SOON
HEARD IMMIGRANTS.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING AND I
WILL BUT I BECAUSE MIX -- SO I'M
I STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL.
MY NAME IS RISK WAY OUT FROM
FROM MY CALIFORNIA AND I
STRONGLY OPPOSE THIS BILL.
GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS CAROLYN
ARABIA IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT
FOR NEARLY TEN YEARS.
IN BEHALF OF MY CLIENTS IN
BEHALF OF MY FAMILY AND MINE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR KNOW WHAT
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY.
GOOD MORNING BILL ANDERSON
NATIONAL NOTARY ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE OPPOSE.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING BACK THE
COMMITTEE WAS OUT -- HAVING.
TRY TO PREVIOUSLY DO BILLS IN
THE SPACE TO TIGHTEN THINGS UP.
I'M JUST KIND OF A DISTURBED
OKAY CURIOUS WHY THE NATIONAL
NOTARY ASSOCIATION IS INVOLVED
IN THIS DISCUSSION.
SO A PORTION OF OUR NOTARIES ARE
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS AND IN
THERE IN LIES THE PROBLEM IS
THAT WE HAVE BEEN TRYING TO
BATTLE FOR DECADES.
I I REPRESENT A BORDER COMMUNITY
AND THE TERM NOBODY ALL.
IN SPANISH IS VERY IT MEANS VERY
DIFFERENT THINGS I I DON'T
UNDERSTAND AND WE HAVE BEEN
TRYING TO GET THE BUSINESS OF
NOTARIES OUT OF THE IMMIGRATION
BUSINESS BECAUSE THE CONFUSION
THAT HAS CAUSED IN THE COMMUNITY
OVERT THAT SIMPLE WORD AND WE
HAVE TRIED TO LEGISLATE THIS --
IS SHOCKING AND WE'VE ALWAYS
BEEN TOLD NO WE'RE NOT TRYING TO
SUGGEST WERE ANYTHING BUT
NOTARIES AND YET HERE THE
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION IS HIGHLY.
INVOLVED IN OPPOSING THIS BILL
WHEN -- AS I UNDERSTAND THAT A
LOT OF NOTARIES ARE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANTS BUT THERE'S A REASON
WHY IT AND WE'RE NOT -- I'M
AWARE OF THAT REASON I THINK
EVERYBODY HERE I KNOW I KNOW YOU
HAVE TO GET PAPERS NOTARIZED BUT
WE ALSO KNOW THAT THE TERM
NOBODY -- HISTORICALLY IN OUR
COMMUNITY HAS BEEN USED TO PULL
PEOPLE.
INTO BELIEVING THAT THE HELP
THAT THEY'RE GETTING IS A
DIFFERENT LEVEL OF HEALTH I'M
SORRY WE WILL NOT TAKE.
I COMMENTS FROM THE AUDIENCE AT
THIS POINT PLEASE RESPECT MS
GONZALEZ AND QUITE READY.
I LIVE IN THIS COMMUNITY AND
AFTER BILL AFTER BILL AFTER BILL
WHEN WE HAVE TRIED TO TIGHTEN
THIS UP YOU CAN GO DOWN DOWN THE
STREET AND SEE YOU CAN SEE THE
ADS IN THE NEWSPAPER YOU CAN SEE.
THE CROSS BORDER ADDS THAT WE
CAN'T CONTROL SO.
SO I AM SORRY PLEASE WE WILL NOT
TAKE OUTBURST FROM THE AUDIENCE.
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE MOVING
FORWARD THE UTILIZATION OF
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANTS UNDER AN
ATTORNEY TO PROVIDE HELP TO AN
ATTORNEY IN IN A KIND OF PARA
LEGAL SENSE.
BUT NOT ACTING ON THEIR OWN
BECAUSE WE HAVE SEEN WITH WHEN I
INITIALLY DID A BILL ON THIS AND
AND MISC CARILLO I KNOW YOU KNOW
THIS.
IN MY OWN OFFICE IN MY OWN
ASSEMBLY OFFICE WE HAVE EVERY
SINGLE MEMBER OF MY DISTRICT
OFFICE HAD A STORY ABOUT THEIR
OWN FAMILIES PROBLEMS WITHIN
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT.
THIS IS NOTHING THAT IS NEW. TO
OUR COMMUNITY AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT ALL THE PEOPLE WHO
TESTIFIED TODAY AYE AYE.
I THINK YOU'RE PROBABLY GOOD
PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO DO A
GOOD SERVICE FOR COMMUNITY I
DON'T THINK YOU CAME ALL THE WAY
UP HERE BECAUSE YOUR HI JACKING
OUR COMMUNITY BUT THERE ARE
PEOPLE WHO ARE MAKING.
MONEY OFF OF OUR COMMUNITY
PROVIDING A BAD SERVICE AND
ACTUALLY HAVE GETTING PEOPLE
DEPORTED OR NOT ALLOWING THEM TO
IT TO WRITE THEIR PAPERWORK
BECAUSE IT'S DONE WRONG THE
FIRST TIME.
AND ALL OF US THERE IS NOT A
SINGLE PERSON WHO I THINK
TESTIFIED TODAY WHO IS NOT HEARD
THOSE STORIES.
SO UNTIL WE CAN FIGURE OUT HOW
TO PROVIDE -- A TRUE
UNDERSTANDING OF WHO THE THE THE
QUALIFIED.
WELL ESTABLISHED.
TESTED WORKING UNDER AN ATTORNEY
IMMIGRATION CONSULTANT HAS I I
HAVE NO ABILITY TO DO ANYTHING
BUT SUPPORT THIS BILL.
AND I I WANT TO THANK YOU I KNOW
IT'S A TOUGH BILL TO BRING
FORWARD I KNOW I'M GOING TO GET
A LOT OF A LOT OF LETTERS IN MY
COMMUNITY A LOT OF VISITS FROM
FOLKS WHO.
OPERATE SMALL BUSINESSES MY
COMMUNITY BUT THERE'S A POINT
WHERE WE HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE BAD ACTORS.
ON PEOPLE'S LIVELIHOODS IS TOO
GREAT TO ALLOW THIS TO CONTINUE
SO THANK YOU FOR THE RING AS
BILL AND I MOVE.
AND I'M THINKING IF YOU HAVE A
I'M SORRY.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS THERE A
SECOND.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU -- NO YOU
CAN ONLY RESPOND IF YOU ASK THE
QUESTION [inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
I'VE I SHARE THE CONCERN FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN DIEGO AND
I'VE ACTUALLY SUPPORTED
LEGISLATION THAT YOU PASS A FEW
YEARS AGO.
TRYING TO REGULATE THE ABUSIVE
PRACTICES OF NOTORIOUS.
I ACTUALLY SUPPORTED A VERY
SIMILAR BILL LAST YEAR.
IN IN REVIEWING THIS AGAIN AND
LISTEN TO THE TESTIMONY I DO
THINK THAT THAT BILL -- IT AND
THIS BILL IS IS OVER BROAD I
MEAN I I THINK WHAT WE'VE HIT ON
IS HEY WE DO NEED.
YOU KNOW BETTER TRAINING WE DO
NEED TO HAVE -- YOU BETTER
PRACTICES BUT TO WHAT THIS BILL
SEEMS TO DO IS JUST COMPLETELY
GET RID OF THE IMMIGRATION
CONSULTANT.
THE INDUSTRY WILL ALL TOGETHER
AND I AND I THINK AS WE'VE SAID
HERE NOT NOT EVERYBODY IN THAT
INDUSTRY IS A BAD ACTOR IN FACT
THERE'S A LOT OF GOOD ACTORS WHO
ARE HELPING PEOPLE.
EVERY DAY -- IN IN THIS SPACE
AND SO I THINK THIS IS JUST IS
JUST TOO DRASTIC OF A MOVE --
AND I'M ALSO REALLY HESITANT
ANYTIME THAT WE YOU KNOW AND
GOVERNMENT SORT OF I MEAN
ESSENTIALLY ELIMINATE AN ENTIRE --
INDUSTRY YOU KNOW WITH A PIECE
OF LEGISLATION I THINK BEFORE
YOU TRY TO DO IS.
GO TO SOMETHING THAT DRASTIC
MAYBE WE SHOULD BE LOOKING AT
OTHER THINGS THAT COULD HELP.
ENSURE THAT THERE ARE
PROTECTIONS BECAUSE I THINK
EVERYBODY IN HERE CARES ABOUT
ENSURING THAT.
PEOPLE DO GET GOOD ADVICE THAT
THINGS ARE FALL THROUGH ON WITH
REGARD TO THEIR IMPORTANT
IMMIGRATION -- ISSUES AND
DOCUMENT SO -- NO I CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL IN THIS FORM --
AND YOU KNOW WOULD WOULD LIKE TO
SEE THIS MAY BE MORE FROM THE
SOMETHING THAT.
YOU KNOW MAYBE IT MAYBE THERE IS.
SOME COMMON GROUND THAT WE COULD
THAT COULD BE REACHED WITH THE
OPPOSITION -- YOU KNOW WHETHER
IT'S ON TRAINING OR FURTHER
PROTECTIONS OR REQUIREMENTS FOR
THE CERTIFICATION.
NOW I THINK THERE'S MAYBE
SOMEWHERE WE CAN GET THERE SO.
THAT I WOULD JUST ASK IF MAYBE
YOU COULD WORK ON THAT YOU KNOW
AS YOU AS YOU MOVE MOVE THE BILL.
FOR THANK.
THANK YOU OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD JUST FROM.
AND THIS COMMITTEE STANDPOINT
ONE OF THE THINGS WERE VERY
CONCERNED ABOUT IS UNLESS
PRACTICE OF LAW AND IN THESE
IMMIGRATION CASES THAT SEEMS TO
BE ONE OF THE TOP AREAS THAT THE
BAR.
HAD NECESSARILY GONE AFTER WERE
TRYING TO MAKE SURE THAT THE BAR
DOES.
MEET ITS PUBLIC PROTECTION
OBLIGATIONS BY GOING AFTER A
LICENSE PRACTICE OF LAW WITH
THIS CONSTANTLY CROPS UP AS ONE
OF THE MOST SIGNIFICANT ISSUES.
SO IT'S STATE IT IS A DIFFICULT
ISSUE I UNDERSTAND IT'S A VERY
EMOTIONAL ISSUE. FOR THOSE
CONSULTANTS WHO ARE.
WORKING TRYING TO MAKE A LIVING
IN VARIOUS AREAS THERE BUT A
NUMBER OF TABS TO TRY AND
ADDRESS THIS AND AND THE FACT OF
THE MATTER IS A LOT OF PEOPLE
GET HURT.
A LOT OF OF EXAMPLES OF UNLESS
HIS PRACTICE OF LAW WHICH DOES
HARM THE PUBLIC AND THAT'S WHY
VERY SERIOUSLY.
SO THAT WAS MISS CAREER YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
SUPPORTERS I CAME TO TESTIFY AS
WELL AS THE OPPOSITION WHO IS
HERE TO TESTIFY YOU HAVE A
MISTER GALLAGHER TO YOUR POINT.
IS CONSOLIDATING HER -- ADVOCACY
AS WELL YOU DO HAVE A COMMITMENT
FROM MYSELF AND FOR MY OFFICE TO
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL TO
MAKE SURE THAT WE COME TO A
RESOLUTION.
THE DOESN'T PUT PEOPLE OUT OF
BUSINESS.
BUT AT THE SAME TIME AND CHORES
THAT ANYONE THAT'S SEEKING
IMMIGRATION HELP IN THIS MOMENT
IN TIME WHEN THERE'S SO MUCH AT
STAKE.
HAS THE OPPORTUNITY TO RECEIVE
LEGAL SERVICES FROM ANY
CERTIFIED LEGAL PROVIDER
FEDERALLY RECOGNIZED OR AN
ATTORNEY WHEN IT COMES TO
IMMIGRATION CASES.
THAT'S A FORMALLY UNDOCUMENTED
PERSON MYSELF I TAKE OFFENSE TO
THAT I WOULD PERSONALLY DO
ANYTHING THAT'S EVEN SLIGHTLY
ASSOCIATED.
WITH THE CURRENT PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES I WOULD NEVER
PUT MY COMMUNITY AT HARM'S WAY.
AND THIS IS IN FACT AN EFFORT TO
PROTECT THAT VERY COMMUNITY AND
I RESPECTFULLY ASK.
FOR NINE THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND THE MOTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED. TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAU CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
[inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
AS I REYES.
THAT NEEDS TO MORE OF THE PLACE
THAT THE LAW CALL.
THANK YOU.
THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN MS
BARNHART [inaudible]
FIVE I
GOOD MORNING EVERYONE
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING ME.
SO COULD WE PLEASE HAVE A QUITE
SO WE CAN CONTINUE OUR HEARING
PLEASE -- MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
HEARING THE SPELL SIXTEEN OH
SEVEN IT WOULD REQUIRE CITIES
AND COUNTIES THE ISSUE LOCAL
BUSINESS LICENSES TO ISSUE A
NOTE NOTICE TO A BUSINESS.
WITH INFORMATION ABOUT THE
GENDER TAX REPEAL ACT AT THE
TIME THE BUSINESS RECEIVES ITS
BUSINESS LICENSE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW THE GENDER TAX
REPEAL ACT PROHIBITS BUSINESSES
FROM CHARGING DIFFERENT PRICES
FOR SERVICES BASED ON GENDER.
VIOLATION OF THE FAULT RESULT IN
AN AUTOMATIC FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLAR STATUTORY PENALTY OR
THREE TIMES THE ACTUAL DAMAGES
SUFFERED WHICHEVER IS HIGHER.
THE ACT ALSO REQUIRES CERTAIN
BUSINESSES TO POST A NOTICE AND
TWENTY FOUR POINT FONT OF THE
GENDER TAX REPEAL A VIOLATION OF
THIS POSTING REQUIREMENT RESULT
IN A THOUSAND DOLLAR STATUTORY
PENALTY.
THE CHALLENGES THAT MANY
BUSINESSES ESPECIALLY SMALL
BUSINESSES ARE NOT AWARE THAT
THIS LAW EVEN EXISTS.
SOME SMALL BUSINESSES HAVE
CHARGE DIFFERENT PRICES FOR
SERVICES BASED ON TIME AND
EFFORT.
BUT THERE HAVE BEEN TARGETED
WITH FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS
DEMANDING THE MINIMUM STATUTORY
PAMPHLET PENALTY AND MORE.
PERSONALLY THIS IS THAT
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE MANY OF
YOU KNOW I HAVE A SMALL BUSINESS
I DESIGNED SENSORY FAMILY
CLOTHING FOR LITTLE GIRLS.
AND THE REASON I CHOSE LITTLE
GIRLS AND LITTLE BOYS IS BECAUSE
IT'S MORE FUN TO DESIGN FOR
LITTLE GIRLS -- BUT HAD I DONE
THIS ALSO FOR BOYS I WOULD HAVE
NOT KNOWN ABOUT THIS LAW AND I
THINK I WOULD HAVE VIOLATED IT.
AND SO THIS IS ONE OF THE SMALL
THINGS WE CAN DO TO REALLY MAKE
SURE SMALL BUSINESSES ARE AWARE
AND THEY ARE FOLLOWING THE LAW.
SO AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN WOULD
REQUIRE CITY OR COUNTY.
WHO ISSUES ISSUES THE BUSINESS
LICENSE TO NOTICE?
GIVE NOTICE OF THE GENDER TAX
REPEAL ACT OF THE TIME THE
BUSINESS RECEIVES ITS BUSINESS
LIFE.
IN ADDITION AB SIXTEEN OH SEVEN
WHAT AUTHORIZED THE CITY OR
COUNTY TO INCREASE THE FEES FOR
A BUSINESS LICENSE TO RECOVER
THE ACTUAL COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH
THE ISSUING THIS NOTICE.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND WITH ME HERE TODAY IS
JENNIFER BARRERA FROM THE CAL
CHAMBER TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THE MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JENNIFER BROWN WE HAVE
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE AND WE ARE IN SUPPORT
AND PLEASE TO SPONSOR THIS BILL
WE HAVE SEEN.
INSTANCES IN WHICH SMALL
BUSINESSES HAVE BEEN.
BASICALLY SUBJECT TO FRIVOLOUS
LAWSUITS -- FOR PRICE
DIFFERENTIALS THAT THEY'RE ABLE
TO JUSTIFY BUT THE COST OF THE
FENCE IS JUST SIMPLY TOO HIGH
FOR THEM TO ENGAGE IN -- AND
THEY'VE BEEN LEVERAGED BY SOME
UNSCRUPULOUS I WOULD SAY
PLAINTIFFS ATTORNEYS -- FOR THE
AUTOMATIC FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS
IN STATUTORY DAMAGES EVEN THOUGH
THE DIFFERENCE IN PRICING IS NOT
A NOMINAL LIKE TWENTY CENTS I
THINK ON A DRY CLEANING AND IT
WAS JUSTIFIED BY THE TIME AND
EFFORT ENGAGED IN SO.
WE'RE JUST HOPING TO PROTECT
SMALL BUSINESSES BY GIVING THEM
NOTICE UP FRONT OF WHAT THIS LAW
REQUIRES SO THAT ONE THEY CAN
SATISFY THE POSTING REQUIREMENT
AND NOT BE SUBJECT TO THE
THOUSAND DOLLAR PENALTY AND TWO
IF THEY ARE GOING TO HAVE PRICE
DIFFERENTIALS.
THAT THAT PRICE DIFFERENTIAL IS
OBJECTIVE AND THEY ARE INFORMED
AND THE CONSUMERS INFORMED ON
WHAT THE DIFFERENCES SO THAT
THEY CAN AVOID A POTENTIALLY
THESE FRIVOLOUS LAWSUITS THAT
THEY'VE BEEN SUBJECTED TO AND SO
WE AGAIN -- PLEASE TO SPONSOR
AND SUPPORT AND ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I THINK THAT IS THEIR OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE I VOTE ON
AB SIXTEEN OF SEVEN THANK YOU I
DO NEED A MOTION.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I CHAU CHIU AND SALAS.
CONSULT AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THAT NEEDS ONE MORE -- PLACE IT
ON CALL THANK YOU.
MR TANG.
SPRING THIS TO ITEM NUMBER
FOURTEEN A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY MORNING -- MISTER
MEMBERS -- AB THIRTEEN SIXTY
ESTABLISHES JUST BASIC HEALTH
AND SAFETY STANDARDS FOR GROCERY
DELIVERY THROUGH ONLINE
PLATFORMS.
IT JUST GIVE EXAMPLE THE BILL
REQUIRES DELIVERY PERSON OF A
FOOD HANDLER CARD.
THAT ASKED DELIVERY VEHICLE TO
ME VEHICLE CODE STANDARDS.
HOUSE THAT THE ONLINE PLATFORM
DRIVER TO ENSURE FOOD IS
TRANSPORTED MEETING SPECIFIED
HEALTH AND SAFETY STANDARDS.
THE AND AGAIN.
WHEN WE GO TO THE GROCERY STORE
THE FOOD IS HANDLED IN A
PARTICULAR WAY WE JUST WANT TO
MAKE SURE?
THAT AS IT'S DELIVERED THAT WE
CONTINUE TO MAINTAIN THAT SAME --
CONSUMER SAFETY AND THAT HEALTH
SAME HEALTH STANDARDS.
WITHOUT A RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
IDLE FOR A. B. THIRTEEN SIXTEEN
HAVE WITNESSED.
THANK YOU FIRST WHAT IS PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR NUMBERS.
MY NAME IS DANIEL CURRY AND I
REPRESENT THE UNITED FOOD AND
COMMERCIAL WORKERS UNION WESTERN
STATES COUNCIL.
I'M HERE TODAY SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF OVER ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THOUSAND UNION MEMBERS
TO SUPPORT.
THIRTEEN SIXTY THIS BILL CLOSES
THE GAP IN LIABILITY COVERAGE
THAT EXISTS FOR CONSUMERS TO USE
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORMS AND FOR
WORKERS OF THOSE DELIVERY
PLATFORMS.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTEEN SURE IS THAT
OF CONSUMER WORKER.
SUFFERS HARM AS A RESULT THE
FOOD DELIVERY PLATFORM THAT
VICTIM IS NOT LEFT BEAR THE
COSTS.
I WELCOME ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
I'D SEEN THAT IS OUR OPPOSITION.
MR CHAN MEMBERS COURT IN JENSEN
WITH TECH MATT HERE TODAY IN
OPPOSITION TO AB -- THIRTEEN
SIXTY WE DO NOT BELIEVE THIS
BILL WILL MITIGATE ANY POTENTIAL
FOOD SAFETY CONCERNS RELATED TO
THE DELIVERY OF FOOD.
FOOD SAFETY AND CONSUMER TRUST
IS A TOP PRIORITY FOR TECHNICS
MEMBER COMPANIES AND WE HAVE
DONE MUCH TO WORK WITH OUR
RETAIL AND GROCERY PARTNERS TO
DELIVER FOOD.
AND AND HAVE IMPLEMENTED RACE
BASED FOOD SAFETY MEASURES
APPROPRIATE FOR THE POTENTIAL
FOOD SAFETY RISKS.
BUT SIMPLY THIS BILL IS TRYING
TO FIT THE THIRD PARTY FOOD
DELIVERY INDUSTRY INTO A BOX
THEY DON'T FIT IN THIS WILL
STIFLE THIS INNOVATION AND HARM
CONSUMERS AND BUSINESSES IN THE
STATE.
NOT TO MENTION THE ELIMINATION
OF EARNING POTENTIAL OF TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF CALIFORNIANS WHO
MAKE MONEY ON THESE PLATFORMS.
AB THIRTEEN SIXTY SINGLES OUT
COMPANIES THAT SERVE CONSUMERS
BY PROVIDING CONVENIENCE AND
CHOICE TO HAVE FOOD STORE WHICH
INCREASES THE MARKET RESEARCH OF
THOSE MARKET REACH OF THOSE
BUSINESSES.
THERE'S TWO BASIC MODELS JUST TO
GIVE YOU A LITTLE IDEA OF THESE
PLATFORMS -- FIRST FOR MANY
GROCERY FOOD DELIVERY ORDERS A
CUSTOMER SUBMITS IN ORDER TO THE
GROCERY STORE AND A GROCERY
STORE EMPLOYEE ASSEMBLES THE
ORDER.
AND THEN THE DRIVER WORKING ON
THE DELIVERY PLATFORM PICKS UP
THE ORDER AND DELIVERS THAT TO
THE CUSTOMER. FOR OTHER ORDERS A
SHOPPER GOES TO THE GROCERY
STORE PICKS UP THE GROCERIES IN
THE SAME WAY THE CONSUMER WOULD
AND THEN THE SHOPPER ACTS LIKE
THIS CONSUMER.
THAT PAYS FOR THE GROCERIES AND
TRANSPORTS THEM TO THE CONSUMERS
HOME.
SO FOR THE BILL IT BY ONE OF THE
PROVISIONS THE BILL REQUIRES ADD
THESE DRIVERS HAVE FOOD HANDLER
CARDS NOT EVEN GROCERY STORE
pSAME THING AS THE SHOPPERS WOULD
DO.
ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE FOOD
HANDLER CARDS ONLY THOSE
EMPLOYEES THAT PREPARE AND SERVE
FOOD ARE REQUIRED TO HAVE FOOD
HANDLER CARDS.
DIFFERENT FOOD HANDLER CARD
PROGRAM REQUIRES A NINETY MINUTE
COURSE AND THEN PASSING A FORTY
QUESTION TEST FOCUS ON HOW FOOD
IS PREPARED AND SERVED NOTHOW
FOOD IS GONNA PICKED UP FROM THE
GROCERY STORE AND THEN DELIVERED
TO A CONSUMER.
SO THE INTENT OF THE FOOD
HANDLER CARD HAS ALWAYS BEEN FOR
WORKERS AT RESTAURANTS AND OTHER
ESTABLISHMENTS WHERE FOOD IS
BEING PREPARED AND SERVE WHICH
IS NOT THE CASE FOR THESE
DRIVERS SIMPLY COLLECTING.
AND DELIVERING PACKAGE PRODUCTS
TO A CONSUMER.
THEY DID SOME HURDLE OF THIS
WOULD REQUIRE THAT DELIVERY
DRIVERS WOULD HAVE TO HAVE THIS
FOOD HANDLER CARD WHICH WOULD BE
A ROAD BLOCK FOR MANY OF THESE
DRIVERS WHO JUST DO THIS -- TO
MAKE A LITTLE BIT OF EXTRA MONEY --
WHILE DOING OTHER JOBS OR
RAISING AT CHILD OR BEING A
STUDENT -- THERE'S MANY OTHER
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL THAT WE
HAVE CONCERNS WITH THE FINAL ONE
I'LL MENTION IS THAT.
THE BILL WOULD REQUIRE
CALIFORNIA WOULD SUPPLANT
CALIFORNIA'S LEADING REGULATORY
GUIDANCE ON I'LL CALL DELIVERY --
UNDERSTANDING THIS NOT THE GEO
COMMITTEE BUT AND FOR THAT I'LL
CALL DELIVERY SECTION THE
CALIFORNIA ABC IS OCTOBER TWO
THOUSAND ELEVEN GUIDANCE ON THE
THIRD PARTY PROVIDERS -- CREATED
INEFFECTIVE REGULATORY REGIME
FOR THIRD PARTY DELIVERY DRIVER
A DELIVERY OF OUT HALL AND THEN
A NUMBER OF OTHER STATES HAVE
ACTUALLY TAKEN AND USED AS A
MODEL THERE'S NO REASON THAT
THIS BILL IS NEEDED TO SUPPLANT
THAT REGULATORY SCHEME.
I'LL WRAP UP BY SAYING THAT ARE
MET MEMBER COMPANIES PROVIDE TO
THEIR SHOPPERS INFORMATION THEY
NEED TO SAFELY PERFORM THE WORK
THAT THEY DO WHICH IS SIMPLY
GOING AND PICKING UP GROCERIES
AND DELIVERING IT.
AND WE DO NOT THINK THAT SIT
BIDDING THIS INNOVATIVE INDUSTRY
INTO A PRE EXISTING ON RELATED
REGULATORY FRAMEWORK IS IT
APPROPRIATE AND I THINK YOU AND
ASK FOR KNOW ABOUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
BOB MARTIN HERE ON BEHALF OF
GROUP.
OF ALBERTSON'S SAFEWAY -- WE ARE
HERE WAS A LITTLE LATE
OPPOSITION AND WE'RE NOT A 100%
SURE IT'S OPPOSITION MY CLIENT
HAS REVIEWED THE BILL AND HAS
IDENTIFIED SOME CONCERNS
RELATIVE TO THE BUSINESS MODEL.
THAT THEY USE FOR HOME DELIVERY
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
MR TANG THE SPONSORS AND HIS
STAFF TO GET SOME CLARIFICATION
BUT AS WRITTEN THEY DO HAVE SOME
SERIOUS CONCERNS SO WE WANTED TO
GET ON THE RECORD SO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD MORNING LOWER CURTIS ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
FOR THE REASONS PREVIOUSLY
STATED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
RIGHT SIGNAL BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
RIGHT SIGNALED VISITING YOU MAY
CLOSE.
AGAIN THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR I
WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
OPPOSITIONS -- FEEDBACK AND
COMMENTS.
AGAIN THIS IS AN INDUSTRY THAT
I'VE USED -- TO PERSONALLY AS A
CONSUMER AND I'M A BIG FAN OF
HOWEVER WE DO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT THERE ARE -- FOOD IN SAFETY --
HANDLING STANDARDS ESPECIALLY AS
THIS INDUSTRY EXPANDS AND MORE
MORE PEOPLE USE THEM WE SEE THIS
INDUSTRY AS A CONTINUUM OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING IN THE GROCERY
STORES AND AGAIN.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FIVE OH FOR
A. B..
THIRTEEN SIXTY THANK YOU.
LOOKING FOR A MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THANK YOU MOTIONS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CULTURAL PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHAU.
CHIU GONZALEZ CONSULT BY HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
I REYES.
THE BILL NEEDS TO MORE -- PLACE
IT ON CALL THANK YOU MISTER TECH.
THAT BRINGS US TO MISTER REAVIS.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHTEEN A. B..
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT AS CHAIR
OUR GOOD MORNING COMMITTEE
MEMBERS AND COLLEAGUES OKAY WE
DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
HOW DOES IT WELL I -- FIRST ONE
TO SAY GOOD MORNING -- AND TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF I REALLY
APPRECIATE THE WORK ON THE
ANALYSIS SO I KNOW I HAVEN'T
BEEN HERE VERY LONG BUT THE
ANALYSIS WAS GLOWING SO I
APPRECIATE IT -- BUT NOT LAST
YEAR ATTORNEY GENERAL HABIA BUT
SERRA HIS THAT WAS THE BUREAU OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE -- ANY DID
SO TO PROTECT PEOPLE AND
COMMUNITIES.
PEOPLE COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE
THAT INDOOR A DISPROPORTIONATE
SHARE OF ENVIRONMENTAL POLLUTION
AND PUBLIC HEALTH HAZARDS.
SO AS THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS
STATES TOO FREQUENTLY ARE STATES
LOWER INCOME -- THE COMMUNITIES
OF COLOR EXPERIENCE FAR GREATER
IMPACTS FROM POLLUTION FROM
TOXICS.
FROM THE TOXIC -- CONTAMINATION
AND THE EFFECTS OF GLOBAL
WARMING THAN RICHER AREAS OF THE
STATE.
UNFORTUNATELY THESE THESE
IMPACTED AREAS AND THE CAT THAT
COMMUNITIES OFTEN LACK RESOURCES
AND OPPORTUNITIES. TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE THAT WE COMBAT SUCH
ENVIRONMENTAL HARMS.
AND RARELY RARELY THEY POSSESS
THE MEANS TO REPRESENT THEIR
INTERESTS THEIR CONCERNS IN
COURT OR BEFORE THE APPROPRIATE
STATE AGENCY OR REGULATORS.
THUS THEY HAVE BEEN DENIED A KEY
ROLE OR A VOICE IN DECISIONS
THAT AFFECT THE QUALITY OF THEIR
LIVES.
SO AS A RESULT THIS BILL AB
SIXTY TWENTY EIGHT IT DOES TWO
THINGS FIRST IT WOULD INCLUDE
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL AND THE
NEWLY ESTABLISHED DOJ'S BUREAU
ENVIRONMENTAL.
JUSTICE -- TO TO THE LIST OF
AGENCIES THAT THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE OF PLANNING RESEARCH MUST
COORDINATE WITH REGARDING
CALIFORNIA'S ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAMS.
AND SECOND RECOGNIZING THE NEED
FOR ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE --
THESE COMMUNITIES TO BE INVOLVED
TO BE ENGAGED WITH STATE
GOVERNMENT AND TO TRULY HAVE
AGENCY IN THE DECISIONS THAT
IMPACT THEM.
AT THIS BILL EXPANDS THE
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE TO INCLUDE MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENT. TO ENSURE THAT OUR
STATE IS MEANING FULLY ENGAGING
PEOPLE OF ALL RACES CULTURES AND
INCOMES.
WHEN MAKING THESE DECISIONS
ABOUT ENVIRONMENTAL PROGRAMS AND
SO WITH THAT MISTER CHAIR I DO
HAVE THE BILL'S SPONSOR WITH US
HERE TODAY FROM THE CALIFORNIA
JUSTICE ALLIANCE AND ALLOW THEM
TO TO DO SOME SELF?
THANK YOU CHRIS WITNESS PLEASE
[inaudible] ONE OF OKAY.
A GOOD MORNING CHAIR MEMBERS MY
NAME IS TIFFANY AND I'M WITH THE
CALIFORNIA ENVIRONMENTAL JUST
ALLIANCE.
A SALES A PROUD SPONSOR OF AB
SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT WHICH
ADVANCE IN THE FORMAL JUSTICE ON
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA IN TWO
IMPORTANT WAYS.
FIRST BY REQUIRING THE OFF TO
PLAY RESEARCH TO CONSULTS WITH
ATTORNEY GENERAL'S BUREAU VJ ON
EASY PROGRAMS WE BELIEVE THAT
THE STRESS AND COORDINATION
WOULD HELP TO ENSURE THAT MORE
EASY COMMITTEES.
THAT PREDOMINATE LOW INCOME
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR WOULD
RECEIVE GREATER PROTECTIONS
INCREASE RESOURCES AND MORE
SUPPORT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
NEED TO PROTECT THEIR HEALTH AND
LIVELIHOODS.
WE'VE ALREADY SEEN THE
DIFFERENCE AT THE AGE OF YOUR
HAS MADE IN SEASON COMMUTES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THEIR ENHANCE
COORDINATION WITH OPR.
SECOND WE ARE EXCITED ABOUT THE
BILL'S INCLUSION OF MEANINGFUL
ENGAGEMENTS AND THE STATE'S
DEFINITION OF ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE.
I DID THIS CONCERT WITH A LINE
CALIFORNIA DEFINITION MORE WITH
THE FEDERAL DEFINITION OF VJ.
I WOULD IN ADVANCE PROCEDURAL
JUSTICE NOT JUST DISTRIBUTIVE
JUSTICE WHEN IT COMES -- TO
INFORMAL JUSTICE.
WHILE WE THE CURRENT DEFINITION
DOES DISCUSS THE NEED TO
EQUITABLY DISTRIBUTE
ENVIRONMENTAL BENEFITS AND
PROTECTIONS TO ALL PEOPLE
REGARDLESS OF RACE CLASS GENDER
ECCENTRIC THEIR BACKGROUNDS.
ATTY MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT WOULD
SET A CLEAR MESSAGE TO DECISION
MAKERS FROM THE STATE LEVEL TO
THE LOCAL LEVEL THAT FRONT LINE
AFFECTED COMMITTEES A RESIDENTS
DESERVE TO BE AT THE TABLE WHEN
IMPORT DECISIONS ARE BEING MADE
THAT AFFECT THEIR ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH AND OUTCOMES.
AND WE ALSO WANT RECOGNIZE THAT
THEY ALSO HAVE LOCAL EXPERTISE
ON EACH ISSUES.
LASTLY SO HOW WOULD LIKE TO
APPRECIATE IT SO THE MEMBER
REVERSE WAS LEADERSHIP ON THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE THANK YOU SO MUCH THANK YOU
THANK GOODNESS PLEASE.
<c.red>I -- GOOD MORNING CHAIRMAN AND</c>
MEMBERS THAT MY NAME IS JASIM
JOHNSON AND I'M WITH PHYSICIANS
FOR SOCIAL RESPONSIBILITY LOS
ANGELES AND WE ARE -- A MEMBER
OF SAY HI AND WE STRONGLY
SUPPORT THIS BILL -- AS GOING
USING HEALTH BERMAN SOCIOPATHS
ARE AWAY I EXAMINE THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT LAND USE AND PLANNING
PLAY IN THE HEALTH AND SAFETY
AND WELL BEING OF COMMUNITY
RESIDENTS.
AND REQUIRED FOR NATION BETWEEN --
OPR AS WELL AS ALL OTHER
OVERSIGHT AGENCIES AND THE AG'S --
BIERMAN RAMIL JUSTICE WILL ONLY
FURTHER STRENGTHEN POLICIES PUT
IN PLACE TO UP LIFT AND I'M
PROTECT OVER BRING COMMUNITIES.
IN IN CALIFORNIA EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS FEAR WILL BE
ABLE TO REMEDY INSTANCES
ENVIRONMENT AND JUSTICE WHERE
IT'S NOT BEING PROPERLY ADDRESS
SUCH AS MANY INSTANCES OF
INCOMPATIBLE AND USE AND SOUTH
AND SOUTHEAST LA -- ADDITIONALLY
SIXTEEN SB SIX AND TWENTY EIGHT
BY FORMALLY ESTABLISHING AGES
BUILT ON EACH DAY ENSURE THAT
THERE'S A PERMANENT BODY IN
PLACE TO IMPROVE ENFORCEMENT OF
ENVIRONMENTAL LAWS AND BEHALF OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE
COMMUNITIES.
AND IS ESPECIALLY IMPORTANT
PLACES WHERE THE LITTLE VERY
LITTLE RESOURCES ON OR INTEREST
FOR LOCAL ENFORCEMENT OR EVEN
REGULATORY FAILURE.
ENVIRONMENT JUSTICE HAS STRONG
ROOTS IN THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT YET IS OFTEN CARPETED
BY INDUSTRY AND OTHERS WHO CARE
LITTLE FOR THE HEALTH AND WELL
BEING A FRONT LINE COMMITTEES.
LASTLY BUT OF GREAT IMPORTANCE
AND CLICK WITH GREAT INSIGHT
EXCITEMENT -- IS THE BILL'S
EXPANSION OF THE DEFINITION OF
ENVIRONMENTAL JUSTICE.
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES
COMMUNITIES OF COLOR AS WELL AS
UNINCORPORATED COMMUNITIES
DISPROPORTIONATELY BY THE BURDEN
OF POLLUTION AND OF OUR MELINDA
COLLECT.
YET THEY OFTEN -- AS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MENTIONED HAVE LITTLE
RESOURCES AT THEIR DISPOSAL TO
BE ABLE TO ENGAGE -- WITH
REGULATORY AGENCIES TO ADDRESS
THESE ISSUES -- RESIDENTS OFTEN
HAVE TO FIGHT TO SIMPLY HAVE AND
PUT ABOUT A POTENTIALLY HAS THIS
WAS SO HE'S MOVING TO THEIR
NEIGHBORHOODS AND MOREOVER IT IS
THE HISTORICAL LACK OF
COMMUNICATION THAT IS PLACES
COMMUNITIES IN THE CONDITIONS
THAT THEY'RE CURRENTLY ENTERING.
ESSENTIALLY ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE WITHOUT MANY BOOKING
ENGAGEMENT IS SIMPLY NOT JUSTICE.
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE SOMEONE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER REDUCES LEADER
SHIP AND PRIORITIZING
PRACTICALLY ADDRESSING A FAMILY
JUSTICE AND ENSURING CLEAN SAFE
AND HEALTHY NEIGHBORHOODS IN
CALIFORNIA.
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE
VOTES THANK YOU.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT. FOR CALLING
ON BEHALF OF SIERRA CLUB
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
RIGHT SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SIGNALED THE SERVICE YOU MAY
CLOSE -- MISTER CHAIR AGAIN -- I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE THIS MORNING
AND CERTAINLY THIS BILL SUPPORT
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S MISSION
TO PROTECT OUR MOST VULNERABLE --
BUT COMMUNITIES -- AND AND AND
AND WHEN YOU SHARE THEIR
MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT IN EFFORTS
TO COMBAT BY MIDDLE HAZARDS --
IT'S R. SPEC WE ASK FOR YOUR
I'VE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND MOTION IS TO PASS
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
CHAU CHIU GONZALEZ.
SALAS I HOLDEN.
OLD AND I KALRA KILEY
MAIENSCHEIN.
I MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THE BILL NEEDS TO MORE SO PLACE
AT ALL CALL THANK YOU.
THIS IS THE MOST.
WELCOME THIS WILL TAKE US TO
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU
THERE IS A MOTION AND A SECOND.
SO AT WITH THE MOTION AND A
SECOND I WOULD JUST SAY ADD THAT
AT EIGHT A. B. THREE SEVENTY
EIGHT WAS HEARD EARLIER I'M IN
THE LABOR AND EMPLOYMENT AND IT
PASSED A UNANIMOUSLY.
FROM THE ASSEMBLY LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT AT COMMITTEE THIS IS
ABOUT ALLOWING CHILD CARE
WORKERS A SEAT AT THE TABLE
THROUGH -- BARGAINING.
AND I DO HAVE SOME FOLKS I HERE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
AND I WILL LET THEM INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES AND IS THE ONE YOU.
THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS YES
THANK YOU SO MUCH ALL RIGHT
FIRST WITNESS PLEASE GOOD
MORNING.
MY NAME IS LIZ THAT REINA.
I LIVE IN LOS BANOS AND I HAVE
BEEN A FAMILY CHILDCARE PROVIDER
FOR TWENTY FIVE YEARS.
LICENSE LARGE FAMILY CHILD CARE
AND CURRENTLY CARE FOR SIXTEEN
CHILDREN. TEN WHICH ARE ON STATE
SUBSIDIZED.
I ALSO HAVE TWO CHILDREN OF MY
OWN AN EIGHTEEN YEAR OLD
GRADUATING FROM HIGH SCHOOL THIS
YEAR AND A CUTE SIX YEAR OLD
LITTLE GIRL.
I'M ALSO A PROUD.
MEMBER OF CHILD CARE PROVIDERS
UNITED A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN D.
U. D. W. AS FOR ME.
LOCAL THREE THIRTY NINE THIRTY
AN SD I YOU LOCALS NINETY NINE
AND FIVE TWENTY ONE I'D LIKE
THOUSANDS OF FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
DEDICATE MY LIFE TO NURTURING
EDUCATING INFANTS TODDLERS AND
SCHOOL AGE CHILDREN IN MY HOME.
I LOVE WHAT I DO AND TAKE MY
WORK VERY SERIOUSLY BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT IN MY HANDS IS THE
EDUCATIONAL EMOTIONAL.
SOCIAL WELL BEING OF THESE
CHILDREN.
AND JUST AS IMPORTANTLY I AM I
AM THEIR PARENTS PEACE OF MIND.
WHEN THEY GO TO WORK?
IN MY CARE THEY KNOW THAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE BEING EDUCATED
NURTURED AND KEPT SAFE.
THE WAY I SEE IT THERE IS NO
GREATER RESPONSIBILITY THAN
TAKING CARE OF SOMEONE'S ELSE
CHILD.
AND YET FOR FAMILY CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS LIKE ME WE CAN BARELY
TAKE CARE OF OUR OWN MUCH LESS
FORD.
A FORD.
ANY ADDITIONAL EDUCATION AND
TRAINING TO PROVIDE THE BEST
EARLY CARE AND EDUCATION
POSSIBLE.
WE DON'T EARN A MINIMUM WAGE
MUCH LESS COVERED BY MINIMUM
WAGE LOSS IF WE GET INJURED ON
THE JOB WE ARE ON OUR OWN AS WE
ARE NOT COVERED BY WORKERS
COMPENSATION LAWS.
AND MANY OF US STILL STRUGGLE TO
PAY FOR HEALTHCARE DESPITE THE
SUBSIDIZED.
IN FACT WE QUALIFY FOR THE SAME
CHILD CARE SURVEYS THAT WE
PROVIDE.
JUST LET THAT SINK IN FOR A
MOMENT WE QUALIFY FOR THE SAME
STAES OF SURVEYS WE PROVIDE.
THIS LOOK AT THINGS LIKE.
SAVINGS SIX DAYS OF WORK
VACATION TIME ARE JUST A PIPE
DREAM I FACE CHALLENGES ON A
DAILY BASIS.
JUST RECENTLY AN ERROR IN A WORK
PAPERWORK BY THE AGENCY I
CONTRACT WITH MEANT THAT I WENT
OVER A MONTH WITHOUT PAY.
SALLY THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME
THAT THIS HAS HAPPENED TO ME.
AND I DOUBT IT WILL BE THE LAST
BECAUSE OF THE LOW WAGES I EARN
WHEN I DON'T GET PAID ON TIME
THAT MEANS THAT I CAN'T PAY MY
MORTGAGE MY BILLS OR PUT FOOD ON
THE TABLE. FOR MY FAMILY AND I
IT IT ALSO MEANS THAT I CANNOT
CONTINUE TO AFFORD TO TAKE THE
CHILDREN TO IN MY CARE ON
EDUCATIONAL FIELD TRIPS.
BY ART.
ART SUPPLIES OR TOYS THAT WILL
HELP THEM LEARN ALL OF THIS
CONTRIBUTES TO OVER ALL EXCITING
I FEEL.
THAT MAYBE THAT NEXT TIME I
WON'T BE ABLE TO STRETCH WHAT
LITTLE FUNDS I HAVE AND WILL
HAVE TO BE FORCED TO CLOSE MY
DOORS.
UNFORTUNATELY MEANT MY STORY IS
ONE OF MANY AND A GLARING
EXAMPLE OF THE DEEP CRACKS IN
CALIFORNIA'S CHILD CARE SYSTEM.
THAT NOT ONLY IMPACTS PROVIDERS
LIKE ME BUT OUR CHILDREN AND
PARENTS WHO RELY ON US.
THAT'S WHY I'M HERE TODAY
BECAUSE AFTER FIFTEEN YEARS OF
FIGHTING FOR THE RIGHTS TO FORM
A UNION AND AND NEGOTIATE WITH
THE STATE WE KNOW THAT.
IF WE ARE GOING TO CHANGE THE IN
QUALITY AROUND AS WE NEED TO BE
TREATED AS REAL PARTNERS.
THE MOST MEANINGFUL WAY TO DO
THAT IS BY GIVING AS THE RIGHT
TO COLLECTIVELY BARGAIN WITH THE
STATE AS IT IS THE MOST
EFFECTIVE TOOL FOR EPIC SEE FOR
PROVIDERS LIKE ME.
THEREFORE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR HI BO FOR A. B..
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS BOOK. TWENTY ON
AIRING ON BEHALF OF BOTH THE
UNIONS AND I'M HERE JUST TO
PROVIDE TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
HE GIVES YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION.
LATER IS THAT THE WITH THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CAN REALLY ROSENBERGER WITH
SERVICE EMPLOYEES INTERNATIONAL
UNION SUPPORT AND I ALSO HAVE A
DO YOU DO A PORTAL ISSUE THIRTY
LETTERS THAT WE SUBMITTED LAST
WEEK THAT IT BEGINS ANALYSIS AND
BECAUSE I ALSO AN ATTORNEY AND A
PAPER TRAIL MATTERS SO.
I HAVE THIS TO GIVE.
TO YOU JUST TO PUT ON THE RECORD
THAT A LOT OF LOCAL ORGANIZATION
ACTIVE SUPPORT.
HI MY NAME IS A RESERVE ARMY
THIS AND I AM A CHUNK OF FOR WHY
THERE IS JOSE FOR THREE YEARS.
AND ALSO A MEMBER OF THE AS YOU
FIVE TO ONE AND NOW -- I AM I AS
FAR HERE IS A PART OF IT AB
THREE SEVEN IT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS STILL UP ON THEM
PROVIDER WOULD BE TOTALLY FOR
NOW I SUPPORT THEM AB THREE
SEVEN EIGHT THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS GERALDINE SAY I AM
FROM STOCKTON CALIFORNIA I'VE
BEEN A CHILD CARE PROVIDER FOR
SEVENTEEN YEARS.
I AM WITH -- SEIU LOCAL.
FIVE TWENTY ONE AND I AM IN
SUPPORT OF A. B..
THREE SEVEN EIGHT THANK.
HELLO MY NAME IS JULIE APONTE
PROVIDERS WHO DEAL DOWNEY FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS.
AND I'M REMEMBER AS HE A YOU
LOOK ON NINETY NINE AND I'M
SUPPORT A THREE SEVEN EIGHT AND
I ASK.
FOR YOUR ALBUM.
THANK YOU.
HI AM THE NETTING CNCEITO FROM
LA COUNTY I TO SUPPORT AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THE THING
THAT I MEAN IS NOT TO KNOW WHAT
CHILDREN NOW IN STRONG SUPPORT
OF THIS MEASURE.
CHARLOTTE NAILS SACRAMENTO
CALIFORNIA -- PROVIDER EIGHTEEN
YEARS AND I SUPPORT.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT VERY GOOD --
SHE HARM TO HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
EMPLOYMENT LAWYERS ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT.
MY NAME IS NORA ALLEN SWAY LE IN
I SUPPORT AB.
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT THANK YOU.
MEDI GRATEFUL FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY MY NAME IS C.
BEETHOVEN.
AND I'M A BEING CHILD CARE
PROVIDER. FOR FIFTEEN YEARS AND
I YOU STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS.
BUT HE GOT A FOUR FOUR TWO THANK
YOU.
ALEX TO CAPRI ON BEHALF OF FIRST
FIVE CALIFORNIA WE DON'T YET
HAVE A POSITION ON THE BILL OR
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSOR TOWARD SUPPORT THANK YOU.
MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION LOS
WERE ALSO YOUR SUPPORT.
GOOD MORNING MY SHOULD CALL FROM
THE CHILD CARE LAWCENTER AND WE
ARE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF THIS
LEGISLATION HAVE A GOOD DAY.
LEAGUE BYNUM YOU W. ASKED ME
THEIR NINE THIRTY HOW CLOSE
SPONSORS ON THE BILL AND WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
THE MORNING WHEN YOU PROUD
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WEIRD NEUTRAL ON THE
BILL -- I JUST WANTED TO THANK
THE AUTHOR WE EXPRESSED A
CONCERN ABOUT THE PUBLIC RECORDS
PROVISION IN THE BILL.
AND WE APPRECIATE HER TAKING THE
AMENDMENT TO ADDRESS THAT
SOMETHING KILL.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION OR NEUTRAL OR
OTHERWISE ALL RIGHT.
SEEING NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS
[inaudible]
WAS GALLAGHER.
YES SO I MY CONCERN AT THIS BILL
IS THAT YOU KNOW I THINK
ULTIMATELY YOU KNOW ALLOWING THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING IS GONNA
MAKE CHILD CARE MORE EXPENSIVE
AND I THINK THAT'S GOING TO BE.
REALLY DIFFICULT ESPECIALLY IN
IN MY DISTRICT WHERE YOU KNOW
PEOPLE ARE MIA.
DON'T MAKE AS MUCH MONEY.
AND YOU KNOW THE COST OF LIVING
IN THE THINGS ARE GOING UP
CONSTANTLY IN THE STATE IT MAKES
IT VERY TOUGH YOU KNOW AND SO --
I BY NO A LOT OF PEOPLE TO
PROVIDE CHILDCARE.
BEYOND THE ONES OF MY DISTRICT
THEY'RE REALLY NOT INTERESTED IN
UNION UNIONIZE IN.
AND YET THAT'S THE OTHER PROBLEM
I HAVE WITH THIS BILL IS THAT
YEAH FOR THOSE THAT WANT.
TO YOU KNOW THAT'S I MEAN THAT'S
HOW THIS YEAR PRAGUE IF -- BUT
SHARING THEIR INFORMATION
PRIVATE INFORMATION AND THEIR
HOME ADDRESSES AND AND THEIR
INFO ABOUT YOU KNOW THEIR CHILD
CARE BUSINESS WITH THE UNION IS
SOMETHING THAT THEY DON'T WANT
TO SEE DONE YOU KNOW AND SO.
AND I AND I THINK IT GOES THE
OTHER IS KIND OF A CONSTANT
THEME HERE THIS YEAR WAS PRIVATE
AND HE GOES TO OUR PRIVACY
ISSUES LIKE.
WHY SHOULD?
THIS INFORMATION BE SHARED THIS
PRIVATE INFORMATION ABOUT YOUR
BUSINESS WE SHARED WITH SOME
THIRD PARTY GROUP -- THAT MAY
HAVE AN INTENT THAT YOU JUST
THAT YOU DON'T PARTICULARLY
AGREE WITH -- SO I THINK WE
SHOULD YOU KNOW HELP PROTECT
THAT AND SO FOR THOSE REASONS
THAT'S WHY.
I UNDERSTAND YOU KNOW YOUR
INTENT BEHIND IT AND WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO AND AND AND
CERTAINLY.
YOUNG SYMPATHIZE WITH THAT BUT I
JUST THINK THAT YOU KNOW IT'S
NOT IT'S NOT FOR EVERYBODY AND
WE NEED A LOT OF CHILD CARE
PROVIDERS OBVIOUSLY IT.
IN THE STATE IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON A MANY
DIFFERENT ASPECTS -- AND SO
THAT'S WHY I CAN'T SUPPORT THE
BILL.
CAN I JUST RESPOND I THINK THAT
THAT'S ONE OF THE THE ELEMENTS
THAT THAT COME UP -- IN TERMS OF
THE COST BUT EIGHT EIGHT THINK
THAT.
THE REAL COST IS OUR FUTURE AND
IF WE DON'T HAVE CHILD CARE
WORKERS.
THAT HAS A HUGE COST TO THE
STATE TO THE EDUCATION AND
PREPARATION OF OUR KIDS AND I
THINK THAT THAT'S WHERE WE'RE AT
WE'VE HEARD TESTIMONY FROM
ACROSS ALL THE STATE.
ABOUT A CHILD CARE WORKERS WHO
ARE QUALIFY FOR THE SAME
SUBSIDIES.
THAT THE FAMILIES THAT THEY
SERVE QUALIFY FOR US SO WE PAY
FOR IT LET'S JUST BE VERY CLEAR --
A AND IT'S THROUGH ITS STATE
SUBSIDIES SO I THINK THAT THAT'S
BIGGER -- ISSUE AND I YOU KNOW I
I THINK RESPECTFULLY ANYONEWHO
DOESN'T WANT TO BE PART OF
SOMETHING HAS THE ABILITY TO SAY
NO -- BUT IT'S EIGHT THAT NEVER
GOES AWAY -- INDEPENDENT OF
SOMEONE MAKING SURE THAT THEY
HAVE ACCURATE INFORMATION.
THAT COULD HELP THEM.
JUST A FOLLOW UP REALLY QUICK IS
WHAT IF IT BECOMES A CLOTHES
SHOP THEN THEY DON'T HAVE A SUCH
THAN THEY DON'T HAVE A CHOICE
CORRECT I MEAN IT WHEN YOU CAN
RESPOND TO IT THAT'S FINE BUT I
MEAN.
ULTIMATELY AS YOU GAIN MORE
BARGAINING POWER RIGHT. FOR
EXAMPLESTATE WORKERS RIGHT NOW
YOU DON'T HAVE A CHOICE.
RIGHT -- YOU YOU AND IF YOU GET.
INTO THAT SITUATION RIGHT.
THEN AND ALSO I AGAIN I I I I GO
BACK TO THE ISSUE OF ARE WE
GONNA GET MORE CHILD CARE
WORKERS OUT OF UNIONIZATION.
WE'RE GONNA GET MORE CHILD CARE
WORKERS WHEN WE PAY THEM WELL
WHAT'S YOUR EVIDENCE FOR THAT.
IF THE EVIDENCE WITH ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY WHEN PAY SUPPORTS THE
WORK OF SOMEONE DOING THAT WORK
WE GET BETTER WORKERS WE GET
MORE WORKERS WE HAVE.
CHILD CARE WORKERS.
WHO CANNOT AFFORD TO BE IN THAT
SPACE WHO WILL GO WORK FOR A
FAST FOOD RESTAURANT BECAUSE THE
FAST FOOD RESTAURANT PAYS MORE
THAN WHAT THEY GET PAID?
IT'S DRIVING IT'S SIMPLE IT'S
SIMPLE ECONOMICS IT'S DRIVING
PEOPLE OUT OF AN INDUSTRY
BECAUSE THEY CANNOT AFFORD.
AN UP ALL THE SAID I THINK
THAT'S YOUR PERSPECTIVE I HAVE
HAD HAPPY INVITE ANY EVIDENCE
HAVE RESEARCH YOU TELL ME WHO
YOU LIKE IF I HAVEN'T SEEN ANY
EVIDENCE OF THAT AND I HAVE HAD
MY OWN.
MY OWN SUBJECTIVE EXPERIENCES
WITH CHILD CARE WORKERS HE SAID
THIS IS NOT WHAT THEY WANT YEAH --
AND SO WE IS HIS WE CAN ALL TALK
ABOUT OUR OWN SUBJECTIVE STORIES
BUT YOU KNOW ABSENT SOME REAL
EVIDENCE THAT THAT'S THE CASE
I'M CONCERNED WITH SOMETHING
THAT COULD ACTUALLY.
LEAD TO LESS JOKER WORKERS.
MISTER KALRA THE MS GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
THINK THE AUTHOR I'M A PROUD
PRINCIPLE CO AUTHOR OF THIS BILL
I THINK IS INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT.
AND I THINK THAT IF YOU TALK TO
ANY WORKER.
AND JUST KEEP THE WORD UNION ON
UNIT OUT OF IT JUST LIKE YOU
WOULD YOU LIKE BETTER PAY
BENEFITS AND A VOICE.
I THINK PRETTY MUCH EVERYONE
WOULD SAY YES TO THAT.
AND THE REALITY IS THAT THOSE
ARE WORKING IN CHILD CARE -- OUR
OFTENTIMES WORKING IN ISOLATION
OFTENTIMES THEIR VICTIMS A WAGE
THEFT OFTENTIMES OF VICTIMS OF
HARASSMENT AND THEY CERTAINLY
DON'T HAVE THE BOYS THAT THEY
DESERVE.
CONSIDERING THE IMPORTANT JOB
THAT THEY PROVIDE FOR ALL OF US
AND SIMPLY JUST SAYING WELL.
IF WE CAN IF IF FAMILIES PAVE
THEIR CHILD CARE WORKERS THAT
HAS MORE MONEY IN THEIR POCKET
IS REALLY AB I DISRESPECTED
THOSE THEY'RE DOING THE WORK --
BECAUSE REALLY WHAT WE'RE ASKING
THE THE THOSE THAT.
ARE IN THE THE THE HAD THE LEAST
AMOUNT OF POWER.
UP TO STAND UP TO ASK FOR A
BETTER WAGES AND TREATMENT AND
BENEFITS TO BEAR THE BRUNT OF
THE BURDEN OF HAVING LOWER
CHILDCARE COSTS.
AS AS THE AUTHOR CORRECTLY SAID
THE MONEY COMES FROM SOMEWHERE
IT'S NOT LIKE -- BALLS WITH A
FAMILY GOING TO SAVE A FEW BUCKS
ON CHILD CARE AND THEN THAT THAT
MONEY JUST RECKLESS APPEARS SOME
SOMEWHERE.
NO WE'RE EITHER PAYING IT
BECAUSE ARE SUBSIDIZING OTHER.
BENEFITS THAT THESE WORKERS ARE
NOT.
A DON'T HAVE THAT DON'T HAVE OR
THEY'RE STRUGGLING AND SUFFERING --
IN POVERTY.
AND SO IT'S AN EITHER OR AND I
THINK THAT THEY'RE ALL ALWAYS WE
ALWAYS A BALANCING TEST ON ALL
THESE ISSUES.
BUT I THINK THERE'S AN
OVERRIDING PUBLIC POLICY
INTERESTS FOR US TO ENSURE THAT
NOT JUST THE CURRENT WORK FORCE
WHAT WE KNOW IS GOING TO BE A
GROWING WORK FORCE A CHILD CARE
WORKERS WHO ARE.
IN MOST CASES THE VERY FIRST
EDUCATOR THAT A CHILD HAS -- WE
NEED TO TREAT THEM AS SUCH AND
TREAT THEM WITH RESPECT AND
DIGNITY.
AND I THINK THAT THIS HAS BEEN
THIS INDUSTRY IS -- ONE THAT IS --
WILLIAM BECAUSE SEE PARALLELS TO
MANY OTHER INDUSTRY THERE ARE
DOMINATED BY A WOMAN A FEMALE
WORK FORCE FOR THE MOST PART --
THAT GET PAID LESS THAN HALF
LESS BENEFITS AGAIN BLOOD THAT'S
RESPECT I THINK WE HAVE TO
CHANGE THAT AND THAT'S WHY I
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU -- BUT SOME OF THE
MONTH [inaudible]
GONZALEZ.
I JUST WANT TO CLARIFY -- FOR MY
COLLEAGUE FROM.
HE IS NICHOLAS THANK YOU.
CHICO -- THAT -- THERE IS NO.
SUCH THING AS A CLOSED SHOP AND
PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT -- THAT
ANYBODY WHO DOESN'T WANT TO BE A
MEMBER OF A UNION.
IS NOT FORCED TO BE A MEMBER OF
UNION AND NOW THANKS TO A
SUPREME COURT DECISION THEY
ACTUALLY GET ALL THE BENEFITS OF
THE UNION WITHOUT PAYING A
SINGLE CENT.
SO -- TO SUGGEST THAT BECAUSE
SOMEBODY DOESN'T WANT TO BE PART
OF A UNION -- I'D ASK OUR
CONSTITUENTS IN A ANY
CONSTITUENT -- WOULD YOU LIKE IN
FACT THE BENEFITS OF OF HIGHER
PAY -- WORKFORCE TRAINING
BENEFITS -- AND BY THE WAY NOT
HAVE TO PAY A SINGLE CENT
BECAUSE WE ALLOW FREE RIDERS NOW
AND I I WOULD ASSUME -- THAT THE
ANSWER WOULD BE YES BECAUSE EVEN
THOSE PLAINTIFFS IN THE JANICE
DECISION DID NOT GIVE UP THEIR
RIGHT TO PENSIONS AND HIGHER PAY
THEY SIMPLY -- DID NOT WANT TO
AT SPEND ANY MONEY TO ACHIEVE
ADD THAT THE COLLECTIVE GOALS OF
THE INDUSTRY SO.
I I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE THAT'S
CLEAR AND I'D BE HAPPY TO SIT
DOWN WITH YOU NOT ONLY ON THE
UNIONIZATION QUESTION BUT ALSO
THE DATA THAT -- YOU ARE
ATTRIBUTING TO THE AUTHOR AS AN
OPINION THE PEOPLE ARE LEAVING
THE CHILD CARE -- WILL LEAVE THE
CHILD CARE PROFESSION BECAUSE
THEY WILL HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
HAVE MORE TRAINING AND HIGHER
PAY -- I THINK NOT ONLY IS THAT
NOT COMMONSENSE THERE'S ACTUALLY
THERE'S ACTUALLY STUDIES ABOUT
WHY PEOPLE LEAVE HEALTHCARE SO
IT WOULD IT WOULD BE GREAT TO
HAVE THAT DISCUSSION I WOULD
THINK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THIS FORWARD I THINK WE ARE MADE
A MOTION BUT I'M I'M SAID BEFORE
THERE.
IS NO MORE IMPORTANT BILL I
THINK THIS LEGISLATIVE SESSION
ON THIS -- ONE WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE WORKERS WHO
FOR FAR TOO LONG ARE UNDERPAID --
THAT WE RELY ON TO IT TO DO THE
MOST BASIC -- FUNDAMENTAL.
CARING FOR OUR CHILDREN.
THE THINGS WE ALL AGREE IS VERY
IMPORTANT AND THEY HAVE
UNFORTUNATELY JUST SLIP THE
LOWER THE RATE ARE AND WAY TOO
MANY THINGS THEY ARE WORKERS WHO
CANNOT BE OUTSOURCED THEIR
WORKERS THAT WILL NEVER BE
AUTOMATED AND SO IT IS.
ABOUT TIME THAT WE'RE MOVING
FORWARD ON THIS THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING FOR IT AND I IT WILL
VOTE YES TODAY.
THE U. S. M. THE SOMEBODY WHAT
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD WERE HAVING A PRETTY
PERSPECTIVE CONVERSATION I THINK
ACROSS THE ADMINISTRATION AND
THE LEGISLATURE NOW ABOUT THE
FUTURE THE EDUCATION SYSTEM AN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION IS ONE
OF THOSE CRITICAL COMPONENTS AND
SO FOR CHILD.
CARE WORKERS WHO ARE.
THE FIRST OPPORTUNITY TO START
THAT EDUCATION.
THE STEP WE NEED TO TAKE IS TO
PROFESSIONALISM IS TO BRING THEM
INTO THE WORK FORCE IN AN
APPROPRIATE WAY HAVE THEM PAID
WELL GIVE THEM BENEFITS.
GIVE THEM RESPECT FOR THE THE
POSITION THAT THEY THAT THEY
HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITY AND OUR
SOCIETY AND INTEGRATE THAT INTO
THE EDUCATION SYSTEM THAT'S
ULTIMATELY THE GOAL THAT'S WHY
THIS BILL IS VERY APPROPRIATE.
AND I THANK YOU FOR BRINGING IT
FORWARD THANK YOU.
AND WITH THAT YOU MAY CLOSE
THANK YOU AND I WANT TO ADD THAT
YOU YOU KNOW IN THIS
CONVERSATION.
THAT UNIONIZING AND COLLECTIVE
BARGAINING IS A MEANS TO A
GREATER GOOD WHEN I THINK OF
WHAT IT WOULD MEAN TO HAVE
TRAINING FOR THE INDIVIDUALS
THAT TAKE CARE.
OF THE KIDS -- BELOW FIVE TO BE
ABLE TO DENNIS ACT IN A FIGHT
COGNITIVE CHALLENGES TO BE ABLE
TO IDENTIFY WHAT REALLY IS IN
THEIR BEST INTEREST IN TERMS OF
HEALTH DECISIONS EDUCATION
DECISIONS -- THIS IS BIGGER THIS
IS JUST A MEANS TO CREATE
HEALTHIER.
KIDS OF THAT OUR OUR FUTURE TOO
REALLY PREPARE STUDENTS FOR A K.
THROUGH TWELVE SYSTEM IN THE
BEST WAY POSSIBLE -- ANYTHING
SOMETIMES WE GET LOST THAT THIS
IS ABOUT THE GREATER GOOD OF OUR
FUTURE THIS IS GOING TO BE WHO
LEADS THE STATE -- THIS IS THE
MEANS TO ENSURE THAT THE WORKERS
HAVE ALL THE TOOLS THAT THERE HE
QUIPPED THAT WE PROFESSIONAL
EYES.
THE INDUSTRY IN SUCH A WAY THAT
WE HAVE MORE INDIVIDUALS THAT
WANT TO AND CAN STEP UP TO BE
ABLE TO DO THIS NEEDED WORK.
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION TO
SECOND THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAU CHIU.
AND SALAS.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS.
NORTH AYE REYES.
THE BILL IS ONE MORE OF A SAID
ON CALL THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THIS WORKS THAT TAKES US. TO
ITEM NUMBER FIVE ON OUR LIST AB
[inaudible]
SEVEN TWO FOUR WHERE HI.
MEMBERS I THANK YOU FOR HAVING
ME TODAY -- YOU KNOW I THINK ALL
OF US KNOW THE ISSUES THAT WE'RE
FACING IN TERMS OF HOMELESSNESS
IN OUR COMMUNITIES WHETHER IT'S
WILDFIRES -- THE COST OF LIVING
FINANCIAL SECURITY -- WE HEAR
AND SEE THE STORIES IN THE PRESS
YOU KNOW IN MY DISTRICT ALONG
WE'VE HAD ABOUT A 40% INCREASE
IN HOMELESSNESS IN THE LAST TWO
TO THREE YEARS -- ANYTHING THOSE
TRENDS ARE ARE GROWING AND AND
CONTINUING -- WHAT WE DON'T
ACTUALLY HAVE AS A STATEWIDE
RENTAL REGISTRY DATABASE THAT
WOULD HELP US COLLECT
INFORMATION SO WE CAN UNDERSTAND
TRENDS OF?
EVICTIONS AND RENT INCREASES AND
THINGS OF THIS NATURE -- I'M A
BIG BELIEVER IN EVIDENCE BASED
POLICY MAKING AND HAVING THE
DATA TO CREATE THE POLICIES THAT
WE NEED. TO TO ADDRESS OUR
HOUSING CRISIS YOU KNOW PROTECT
THE TENANTS THAT WE NEED.
TO WE CURRENTLY DON'T HAVE THIS
READ THIS INFORMATION SOME
CITIES HAVE.
RENTAL REGISTRIES A MOST DON'T
I'M SO THIS BILL IS VERY SIMPLE
IT WOULD JUST SEEK TO CREATE A
RENTAL REGISTRY SO WE CAN GATHER
THAT INFORMATION AND FROM THAT
INFORMATION THEN.
FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THE BEST
POLICIES TO HAVE SOLUTIONS TO
THESE PROBLEMS SO.
IT'S A PRETTY SIMPLE BILL IN
TERMS OF ITS CONCEPT -- WE
PASSED OUT OF THE HOUSING
COMMITTEE WE WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE AND WITH ME
IT'S TESTIFIED TODAY'S CATHERINE
BRACE FROM TECH EQUITY AND THERE
ARE SOME AMENDMENTS AS LISTED
THE ANALYSIS YOU'RE TAKING THOSE
IS OFFSHORE -- YES THANK YOU
THANK YOU THANK YOU FIRST
WITNESS HI THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I AM CAPTAIN BRACEY
I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE TECH EQUITY COLLABORATIVE --
WE ARE AN ORGANIZATION BASED IN
THE BAY AREA THAT BELIEVES THAT
OUR STATE'S TECH DRIVEN ECONOMY
CAN AND SHOULD CREATE BROAD
BASED OPPORTUNITY FOR ALL
RESIDENTS.
ARE CORE MEMBERSHIP CONSISTS OF
RANK AND FILE TECH WORKERS WHO
WANT TO USE THEIR UNIQUE POWERS
RESIDENTS OF CALIFORNIA TO PUSH
FOR POLICY CHANGES.
THAT WILL ALLOW THE BENEFITS
CREATED BY OUR BOOMING ECONOMY
TO ACCRUE MORE PEOPLE SOLVING
HOUSING CRISIS IS OBVIOUSLY A
CRITICAL ELEMENT OF THAT
EQUATION.
AS TECH WORKERS WE ARE ACUTELY
AWARE OF THE IMPACT WE ARE
HAVING ON HOUSING COSTS IN
CALIFORNIA WE FEEL THIS CRISIS
TO AS MANY OF US PAY WELL MORE
THAN A THIRD OF OUR INCOMES FOR
HOUSING.
WE KNOW THAT THIS IS
UNSUSTAINABLE PARTICULARLY FOR
NEIGHBORS WHO ARE NURSES
TEACHERS BUS DRIVERS JANITOR.
AND OTHERS TO DO THE CRITICAL
WORK OUR COMMUNITIES NEED TO
THRIVE IN FOR OUR NEIGHBORS HAVE
BEEN MADE HOMELESS ORBIT OR BEEN
DISPLACED BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING.
AS TECH WORKERS WE ALSO
UNDERSTAND THE IMPORTANCE OF
HAVING RELIABLE DATA TO INFORM
DECISION MAKING.
OVER THE PAST FEW YEARS AS WE
HAVE BEGUN TO ENGAGE IN HOUSING
ADVOCACY WORK WE HAVE FOUND THE
POLICY CONVERSATION AROUND TEN A
PROTECTIONS TO BE TAKING PLACE
AND THE ABSENCE OF REAL DATA
ABOUT THE EXTENT OF THE PROBLEM.
NO ONE REALLY KNOWS HOW MUCH
RENTS ARE INCREASING ACROSS THE
STATE.
AT THE DATA THAT DOES EXIST FROM
PLACES LIKE THE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY SURVEY AND PRIVATE
COMPANIES LIKE ZILLOW ARE
INSUFFICIENT IN MANY WAYS THEIR
PROPRIETARY EXPENSIVE -- NOT
COMPREHENSIVE AND THEY TEND TO
REPORT TOP LINE DATA SUCH AS
AVERAGES IN ORDER TO MAKE SMART
HOUSING POLICY WE NEED GRANULAR
TRANSPARENT AND COMPREHENSIVE
DATA ABOUT RENTAL PRICES THAT
CAN ONLY BE GATHERED BY ASKING
THE LANDLORDS TO SUBMIT THEM
DIRECTLY.
WE'RE HAPPY TO STAND WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS ON THIS
BILL AND WE RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE BOATS THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
UPDATE.
HI DAVID ONLY HAVE THE BAY AREA
HOUSING ADVOCACY COALITION IN
SUPPORT.
SUCH A HARD IN ON BEHALF OF THE
WESTERN CENTER ON LAW AND
POVERTY AND THE CALIFORNIA RURAL
LEGAL ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
.
HI THE ONLY BE WITH THE A
CALIFORNIA APARTMENT SOCIAL FROM
HERE IN OPPOSITION -- WE WE
UNDERSTAND THE INTENT OF WHAT
THE A SOMEONE TRYING TO DO --
BUT WE STILL BELIEVE THERE'S NO
RATIONAL REASON FOR MANAGING
THIS EXTENSIVE INFORMATION.
FOR A PUBLIC WEBSITE AND NO
PLAUSIBLE ARGUMENT THAT THIS
INFORMATION WE USE IN A
PRODUCTIVE WAY TO ADDRESS THE
CURRENT HOUSING CRISIS -- INVADE
THE PRIVACY OF OWNERS AND
TENANTS WHO LIVE IN RENTAL UNITS
BY REQUIRING.
DISCLOSURES OF THEIR DRESS
UTILITY COSTS THE NUMBER AND
SIZE OF THEIR BEDROOMS.
AND BATHROOMS AND ALSO MAKE TENS
RIGHT PAYMENT HISTORY OR NON
PAYMENT PUBLIC.
IT ALSO REQUIRES MEMBERS
DISCLOSE INFORMATION ABOUT THE
PENSIONS.
WHEN IT?
WHEN THE INFORMATION BE MASKED?
BY THE COURTS FOR PRIVACY
REASONS -- THE PUBLIC
INFORMATION WILL MAKE IT EASY
FOR TENNIS THE NEIGHBORS. TO
FIND PRIVATE INFORMATION SUCH AS
RENT THAT THE REBBE NEIGHBORS
ARE PAYING.
WHY CERTAIN FAMILY MEMBER MOVED
AWAY OR FAMILY?
HOUSE WOULD MOVE THE WAY OR HOW
SMALL THE APARTMENT IS.
THAT LARGE FAMILIES LIMóN AND
THE BILL WOULD ALSO REQUIRE
POPULOUS PROVIDE EXACT SQUARE
FOOTAGE OTHER UNITS UNDER STATE
LAW NOW.
BILLS ARE NOT ALLOWED TO DEMAND
ENTRY AND INTRIGUE AGAINST A
TENNIS WISHES COLLECT THAT
INFORMATION.
AND THE LAST THING I'LL SAY.
IS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT THAT.
DE ON PAGE SIX THAT THE A
COMPANY A COMPANY TRADE OFFS
IMPROV STILL WORTH THE BENEFIT.
I GUESS WE ASK.
WHAT?
THE BENEFIT IS -- FOR IF IT'S
FOR THE TENANT GROUPS IF YOU
LOOK ON THE SUPPORT LIST THERE'S
NO TENANT RIGHTS ADVOCATES --
LISTED IN SUPPORT AND
ADDITIONALLY.
WE BELIEVE THE INFORMATION CAN
BE GATHERED NOW -- AND NOT NEED
TO CREATE A STATEWIDE DATABASE
COMPANIES LIKE COSTAR --
COLLECTORS TYPE INFORMATION NOW
AND IT IS PRETTY -- IT'S
EXTENSIVE AND DESCRIPTIVE.
CAM THAT COMPANY ALSO HAS A
BELIEVE THREE CONTRACTS WITH THE
STATE -- ONE BEING THE
DEPARTMENT GENERAL SERVICES AND
ADDITIONALLY TWENTY CONTRACTS
ARE TWENTY PLUS CONTRACTS WITH
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS -- DOING THIS
TYPE OF INFORMATION COLLECTED
SOME INFORMATION SO WE BELIEVE
LOOKING AT BAM OR FOLKS LIKE
THEM OUT IN THE UNIVERSE NOW.
IS BETTER THAN QUEEN A BRAND NEW
STATEWIDE DATABASE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS TIM
CAN MEREKA A WITH CALIFORNIA
STRATEGIC ADVISERS ON BEHALF OF
THE AFFORDABLE HOUSING
MANAGEMENT ASSOCIATION OF
PACIFIC SOUTHWEST.
WE CAME IN WITH A LATE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED AND I JUST WANT
TO ACTUALLY THINK THE AUTHOR AND
THEIR STAFF BECAUSE THEY HAVE
BEEN WORKING WITH US.
MEMBERS ARE OUR GROUP
SPECIFICALLY OUR CLIENTS
REPRESENT A 100% DEED RESTRICTED
PROPERTIES THAT ARE ALREADY
COMPREHENSIVELY MONITORED
REPORTED AND TRACKED.
NOT ONLY THROUGH FEDERAL AND
STATE AGREEMENT SPECIFIC PACIFIC
WE THROUGH THE STATE OF
TREASURY'S OFFICE.
THE TREASURY'S OFFICE RIGHT NOW
HAS ALL OF THIS INFORMATION SO
FOR US WEIRD BASICALLY ASKING
THAT YOU KNOW THIS ADDITIONAL
REPORTING REQUIREMENT WHEN IT'S
ALREADY BEING DONE IS
UNNECESSARILY BURDENSOME FOR OUR
MEMBERS.
WE ARE WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR
TO SEE IF THERE MIGHT BE A WAY
IF NOT EXEMPTING OUR MEMBERS
MAYBE POSSIBLY PULLING THAT DATA
FROM THE SECRETARY OF STATE'S
OFFICE.
BECAUSE WE ARE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING GROUP OBVIOUSLY OUR
MEMBERS ARE NONPROFIT AND SO
THEY LIVE WITH MARGINS AND SO WE
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT WE ARE
NOT.
A NECESSARILY BIRD DANCING THEM
WE THINK THAT THE DIRECTION THE
BILL MAKES A LOT OF SENSE LIKE I
SAID WE SUPPORT REPORTING.
IT'S JUST DO IN A WAY THAT
DOESN'T.
DUPLICATE -- BE DUPLICATIVE FOR
AND REDUNDANT FOR OUR MEMBERS
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
GALLAGHER.
SO I'VE BEEN THINKING ABOUT YOUR
BILL AND I MEAN FOR ME OBVIOUSLY.
YOU KNOW.
THEM THE BIGGEST THING IS
HAPPENING MY DISTRICT IS IS A
WILDFIRE AND ESPECIALLY IN THESE.
YOU KNOW CRISIS SITUATIONS
DISASTROUS SITUATIONS.
THE REAL CONCERN IS THAT THERE
IS LIKE RENTS BIKING AND THERE'S
EVICTIONS GOING ON THAT
OTHERWISE WOULDN'T HAPPEN AND
THAT RENTS ARE BEING YOU KNOW --
BASICALLY ARBITRARILY AND
INFLATED -- FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE
WHO ARE.
LOOKING FOR DESPERATELY FOR
HOUSING -- AND SO IN THAT
CONTEXT IN AND I THINK
ULTIMATELY IN THE IN THE HOUSE
FOR IN SOLVING OUR HOUSING
CRISIS ARE OUR ULTIMATE.
SOLUTION IS INCREASING SUPPLY
LIKE WE HAVE TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING -- IN THE FACT THAT WE
HAVEN'T BEEN DOING THAT WHETHER
BECAUSE OF BURDENSOME
REGULATIONS OR BECAUSE THE NAME
BE ISM AND LOCAL [inaudible]
RESTRICTIONS -- FOR WHATEVER
REASON WE HAVEN'T BUILT A LOT OF
HOUSING AND THAT ONLY MAKES THE
PROBLEM WORSE BECAUSE WE HAVE
THIS LIMITED.
NO UNIVERSE OF HOUSING.
THERE'S ONLY STE ONLY SO MUCH IN
IT IN THAT THAT INCREASES I
THINK ULTIMATELY THE COST.
THE OF RENTS OF PURCHASES OF
HOME SO -- BUT I GUESS MY ON THE
OTHER SIDE THAT MY CONCERN WOULD
BE OKAY BILL YOU KNOW HOW IS
THIS.
INFORMATION GOING TO BE UTILIZED
RIGHT BECAUSE I AND I AGREE WITH
YOU WE SHOULD.
I ALSO WANT TO SEE EVIDENCE SO
WANT TO SEE DATA RIGHT -- BUT WE
CAN OFF OFTEN INTERPRET THAT
DATA DIFFERENTLY -- AND I THINK
IN THE IN THE GENERAL'S SCOPE OF
THINGS.
I DON'T WANT TO GET INTO THE
BUSINESS OF TELLING PEOPLE WHAT
THEY SHOULD RENT THEIR HOMES.
FOR THE I DON'T BELIEVE IN RENT
CONTROL -- I DO BELIEVE IN
PROTECTING AGAINST ABUSES LIKE
LIKE THAT WE HAVE SEEN.
YOU KNOW SOMETIMES IN THESE
EMERGENCY SITUATIONS.
SO I DON'T KNOW IF THERE'S A WAY
TO I MEAN IS THAT SOMETHING THAT
YOU THOUGHT ABOUT AND AND AND I
GUESS LAST PROBABLY THE PRIVACY.
ISSUES THAT I I KNOW YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH OPPOSITION ON SO
MAYBE YOU CAN JUST KIND OF
ADDRESS THAT.
THAT WAS A LOT OF TICKET BUT NO
HOUSING IS A BIG ISSUE IN A FEW
A ONE IT BUILD MORE HOMES I GOT
ANOTHER BILL FOR YOU SO.
I GOT.
ONE BUT I AGREE WITH YOU KNOW
THE ISSUES AROUND WILD FIRES IN
THE SPIKES AND RENT YOU KNOW
THIS BILL DOESN'T SEEK -- TO PUT
ANY KIND OF RENTER PROTECTIONS
ON THOSE THERE'S OTHER BILLS I
THINK AIMING TO ADDRESS THAT
ISSUE IN PARTICULAR WHICH I'M
ALSO SUPPORT OF OF AND I DO
BELIEVE WE NEED TO BUILD MORE
HOUSING.
SO I THINK ALL OF THE ABOVE IS
IS CRITICAL AND I THINK WE BOTH
NEED.
TO BOTH PROTECT RENTERS AND
BUILD HOUSING IN DOING BOTH OF
THOSE THINGS OFTEN I THINK IN
THIS DEBATE.
THOSE TWO SIDES GET PITTED
AGAINST EACH OTHER AND I THINK
WE HAVE TO DO BOTH RIGHT -- IN
TERMS OF THE THE PRIVACY
PROTECTIONS -- OUR GOAL HERE IS
NOT TO EXPOSE ANYONE'S IDENTITY
OR YOU KNOW ANYTHING THAT NATURE
WE ARE GOING TO ADOPT AND ARE AT
HAVE ADOPTED.
BOTH STATE AND FEDERAL PRIVACY
LAWS TO ENSURE THAT WE ARE
PROTECTING PRIVACY NAMES OF
TENANTS WILL NOT BE PUBLIC --
NAMES OF LANDLORDS WILL NOT BE
PUBLIC IT'S JUST THE INFORMATION
ON WHAT ARE THESE UNITS BEING
RENTED -- FOR YOU KNOW ARE ARE
THERE -- YOU KNOW EVICTIONS THAT
WE'VE SEEN I'M WHAT IS THE DAD
IT WOULD THAT WE CAN COLLECT SO
THAT YOU KNOW ORGANIZATIONS LIKE
THE TURNER CENTER UC BERKELEY
THE FOCUS ON HOW WE CAN.
TAKE THIS DATA AND UNDERSTAND
AND ANALYZE THAT -- YOU KNOW HOW
THEY CAN -- ACCESS THAT I THINK
IS VERY IMPORTANT RIGHT NOW
THEY'RE JUST ISN'T THAT DAD AT
THE STATEWIDE LEVEL TO DO IT AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO TALK MORE ABOUT
PRIVACY PROTECTIONS AS YOU KNOW
I'M A BIG ADVOCATE ON PRIVACY --
AND AND WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE WE GUARD AGAINST ANY KIND OF
COMPROMISE COMPROMISING
SITUATIONS ON THE PRIVACY ISSUE --
WELL IF I COULD ALSO JUST
ADDRESS SOME OF THE POINTS THAT
WERE RAISED HERE AS WELL -- YOU
KNOW WE DO HAVE TENANTS GROUPS
THAT ARE ADVOCATING FOR THIS --
IN TERMS OF OUR LIST OF
SUPPORTERS HAVING TECH EQUITY IS
ONE IN PARTICULAR THE WESTERN
CENTER YOU KNOW AIDS HEALTHCARE
FOUNDATION ALL OF OUR SPONSORS
AND AND FOLKS ARE ADVOCATING ON
THIS ARE VERY THOUGHTFUL
ADVOCATES IN THE TENETS SPACE SO.
I WOULD JUST YOU KNOW A KINDLY
DISAGREE WITH THAT ASSESSMENT
AND WITH REGARD TO YOUR SHOES
YOU KNOW WE JUST GOT THIS
OPPOSITION LETTER VERY LATE
WE'RE HAPPY TO KEEP TALKING
ABOUT IT.
AND WE WANT TO WORK
COLLABORATIVELY AND WE ALSO YOU
KNOW WE TOOK THE REALTORS
AMENDMENTS THEY RAISE SOME
AMENDMENTS WE TOOK THOSE IN THE
LAST COMMITTEE TO TO MOVE THE
BILL FORWARD SO.
WE WANT TO WORK WITH FOLKS HERE
IN TERMS OF GETTING THIS BILL
THROUGH AND WANT TO BE
THOUGHTFUL IN THE PRIVACY STUFF
AND LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE APARTMENT
ASSOCIATION ON THAT.
AND I DO HEAR YOUR CONCERN ABOUT
THE PRIVACY PIECE SO I'M
COMMITTED TO TWENTY TO SAFEGUARD
AGAINST THAT ISSUE.
I DON'T KNOW IF I ANSWERED ALL
YOUR QUESTIONS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
OKAY.
OTHER QUESTIONS ARE COVERED.
ALL RIGHT SEEING NONE. SIX YOU
MAY CLOSE WELL I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU I'M LOOKING FOR A A
MOTION MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS.
THERE'S A MOTION IS THERE A
SECOND AND THE SECOND THANK YOU --
ROLE PLEASE.
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
CHAO.
GALLAGHER I CHAU CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
BECAUSE I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
COLOR I KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
NEEDS ONE MORE SO PLACE THE BILL
OF THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS RUBIO.
YOU HAVE TO BILLS BEFORE US AB.
TEN SEVENTY THREE AND A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN YOU HAVE A
PREFERENCE.
ALL RIGHT LET'S START WITH AB.
TEN SEVENTY THREE OUR ITEM
NUMBER.
EIGHT I THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS A
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE WHICH AUTHORIZES
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ENTER
INTO AN AGREEMENT WITH
IMMIGRATION AND CUSTOMS
ENFORCEMENT. TO LIMIT
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES AT THE
VICTIM SERVICES LOCATIONS
MENTIONED IN THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL OCTOBER TWENTY EIGHTEEN
MODEL POLICIES ON IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
THANKING THE COMMITTEE AND THEIR
STAFF FOR WORKING THOROUGHLY
WITH OUR OFFICE ON THIS BILL --
EXISTING LAW PROHIBITS A STATE
OR LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENCY
INCLUDING SCHOOL POLICE AND
SECURITY DEPARTMENTS FROM USING
MONEY OR PERSON PERSONNEL TO
INVESTIGATE INTERROGATE DETAIN
DETECT OR ARREST PERSONS. FOR
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT PURPOSES.
SB FIFTY FOUR REQUIRED THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO ESTABLISH
MODEL POLICIES LIMITING
ASSISTANCE WITH IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT TO THE FULLEST
EXTENT POSSIBLE.
WE HAVE HAD ORGANIZATIONS WE
REACH OUT TO US AND INFORM US
THAT THEY HAVE SEEN A DECLINE IN
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS SEEKING
SERVICES FOR DOMESTIC AND SEXUAL
VIOLENCE SINCE.
TWENTY SIXTEEN THIS BILL IS
IMPORTANT TO ME BECAUSE I WAS
UNDOCUMENTED ARE WITHIN
UNDOCUMENTED IMMIGRANTS AND I
HAVE AN IMMEDIATE FAMILY MEMBER
WHO IS A SURVIVOR OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I KNOW FIRST HAND THE FEARS THE
STRESS THE CONFUSION OF TRYING
TO SURVIVE MOMENT BY MOMENT
KNOWING YOU CAN BE TORN FROM
YOUR FAMILY AND DEPORTED AT ANY
TIME.
THIS FEAR IS REAL AND IT'S
SOMETHING I WILL NEVER FORGET.
I KNOW THE PAIN OF MY FATHER
BEING ASKED FOR HIS DOCUMENTS
AND BEING UNABLE TO PROVIDE THEM.
I KNOW THE VISION MY PARENTS HAD
FOR US A VISION THAT IS FOR
FAILED AS BOTH ME AND MY SISTER.
ARE NOW SERVING IN THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
I HAVE SEEN FIRSTHAND THE PAIN
OF MY FAMILY MEMBER -- WHILE SHE
WAS GOING THROUGH -- DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE.
I UNDERSTAND HOW DIFFICULT IT IS
TO ASK FOR HELP WITH PROPER
DOCUMENTATION.
MOST UNDOCUMENTED SURVIVORS ARE
TOO AFRAID TO ASK FOR HELP.
BECAUSE OF THE FEAR OF BEING
RIPPED AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
LET ME BE CLEAR ICE CANNOT BE
PERMANENTLY STOPPED FROM
ENTERING THESE LOCATIONS HOWEVER.
AB TEN SEVENTY THREE WILL HELP
REMEDY THESE FEARS BY WORKING
WITH THE ICE ON HELPING PROTECT
THE SURVIVORS IN THESE LOCATIONS.
THANK YOU AND I DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES I JUST.
WANT TO REALLY APPRECIATE THE
THE COMMITTEE FOR WORKING WITH
US TO WORK THROUGH THESE --
THROUGH THE ISSUES THAT WE HAD --
WITH THIS BILL AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE.
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE LIKE TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT.
THE MORNING ASTRONOMERS TWENTY
SUMMERS AGO.
ALBERTA TO COME OUT OF THE
CALIFORNIA AB CAN ATTORNEYS
ASSOCIATION IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THE MEASURE.
THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSES WHICH IRELAND
STRONG SUPPORT WE JUST FORMER
POSITION LAST WEEK.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
RIGHT THIS RUBIO EVEN
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
THANK YOU WE DO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS KALRA
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE.
PETRIE-NORRIS PETRIE-NORRIS IRIS.
THERE NEEDS TO MORE ABOUT IT IS
THE DOG COLLAR.
THANK YOU.
AND YOU ALSO HAVE ITEM NUMBER
FIFTEEN A. B..
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN AN
ACT RELATING TO THE ADVERTISING
OF AND LICENSE CANNABIS
BUSINESSES.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND YOUR
STAFF FOR HELPING US WITH THAT
AUTHOR PROPOSED AMENDMENTS
DESCRIBED IN THE ANALYSIS AND
HELPING US STRENGTH AND THE BILL.
AS YOU KNOW THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA STARTED ISSUING STATE
LICENSES AT THE BEGINNING OF THE
OF LAST YEAR FOR CANNABIS
BUSINESSES TO OPERATE IN THE
STATE.
DESPITE SOME SUCCESS DURING THE
FIRST YEAR OF LEGAL SALES THE
BLACK MARKET HAS CONTINUED TO
FLOURISH DRIVING DOWN LEGAL
SALES.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT REPORT BY
THE CANNABIS ADVISORY COMMITTEE
LACK OF ENFORCEMENT IS CREATING
A THRIVING ENVIRONMENT FOR THE
UNREGULATED UNDERGROUND MARKET.
IN ADDITION TO DWINDLING TAX
REVENUES THE UNDERGROUND MARKET
PRESENT SERIOUS PUBLIC SAFETY
AND PUBLIC HEALTH THREATS TO OUR
COMMUNITIES.
IN ADDITION THE CANNABIS
PRODUCTS SOLD AT THESE LOCATIONS
DOES NOT MEET ESTABLISHED
QUALITY STANDARDS AND EVADES
STATE TESTING.
COME COMBATING THE UNDERGROUND
MARKET IS A KEY POLICY GOAL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE THIS YEAR.
THIS BILL WOULD TARGET THE BLACK
MARKET BY CRACKING DOWN ON A
SPECIFIC PROBLEM THE ADVERTISING
OF ILLEGAL OPERATIONS FOR PROFIT.
AB FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN WILL
CREATE CIVIL PROBLEM NO
PENALTIES FOR ENTITIES WOULD
DECIDE TO ADVERTISE THE LEGAL
OPERATIONS IN EXCHANGE FOR
PROFIT.
AS THE LEGISLATURE WE CANNOT SAY
THAT WE ARE TAKING THE CANNABIS
BLACK MARKET SERIOUSLY IF WE
ALLOW THE UNREGULATED.
PROMOTION AND ADVERTISEMENT OF
ILLEGAL BUSINESSES TO EXIST
WITHOUT CONSEQUENCE.
WE KNOW THAT THESE
ADVERTISEMENTS DRIVE BUSINESS
TOWARDS ILLEGAL OPERATORS AND
MUST FIND A WAY TO RESTRICT THIS
PRACTICE.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY AND I WILL NOW
TURN THE MIKE OVER TO OUR
SPONSORS AND SUPPORTERS THANK
YOU WE DO HAVE THE MOST IN A
SECOND AND YOU MENTIONED THE
MEMBERS WHO ARE TAKING THOSE IS
OFTEN YES.
JUST TO BE CLEAR THANK YOU MARIN --
CALIFORNIA ADVOCACY ON BEHALF OF
THE THAT KIND OF HIS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION HERE -- WHAT JERRY
KILEY -- THANK YOU VERY TIME AND
CHAIR KYLE ON THE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED CAMAS BUSINESS
ASSOCIATION -- AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN IS NOT A BILL TO
RESTRICT ADVERTISING AND
TECHNOLOGY OF LEGAL BUSINESSES
THIS BILL THAN EFFORT TO HOLD A
SMALL NUMBER OF TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS.
ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR DELIBERATE
IGNORANCE THE CLIENT THEY
FACILITATE PROFIT FACILITATE
FAIL FOR AND PROFITS OFF THOUGH
THE LEGAL FAILED CAMPUS LAWS OR
STATE REGULATED SO ADVERTISING
SHOULD BE AS WELL.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES THERE
ARE OVER TWO THOUSAND ADVERTISED
RETAIL LOCATIONS ON TECHNOLOGY
PLATFORMS A HUNDRED AND EIGHTY
ONE OF THOSE LOCATIONS ARE LEGAL
OVERWHELMINGLY THE CONSUMERS ARE
CONFUSED WITH DECEPTIVE
ADVERTISEMENT THAT ARE DESIGNED
TO STRIP AWAY.
THE MARKERS THAT DIFFERENTIATE A
LEGAL AND ILLEGAL CANNABIS
BUSINESS IT IS TIME FOR THIS
DELIBERATE IGNORANCE OF WHO YOUR
ADVERTISING FOR IS THE REASON
WHY WE ARE HAVING THIS BILL.
THESE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS HAVE
MANY INSTRUCTIONAL VIDEOS
EDUCATING THE CONSUMER ON SO
MANY DIFFERENT ASPECTS OF
CANNABIS FROM BROAD DESCRIPTIONS
OF WHAT CANNABIS IS IN THE
HISTORY.
OF IT AND THE NEW WANTS NATURE
OF CANADA NOISE THEIR
PHYSIOLOGICAL FAX NO WHERE IN
THIS VAST LIBRARY OF EDUCATIONAL
VIDEOS IS ONE ON HOW TO FIND A
LEGAL BUSINESS OR LEGAL
DISPENSARY OR WHAT PUBLIC SAFETY
ISSUES THERE ARE.
IF YOU SHOP IN ANY LEGAL
FACILITY.
THESE CANNABIS CENTRIC PLATFORMS
HAVE DUG DEEP AND PROVIDE
EDUCATION ON EMERGING INDUSTRY
AND LEFT OUT HOW TO SUPPORT ITS
LEGAL GROWTH WE'D MAPS IS THIS
VIOLATOR THAT WOULD RATHER
SUPPORT THE ILLICIT MARKET.
THAN TO PROFIT OFF THE ILLEGAL
SALE OF THAT SUPPORT THE TAX
PAYING ENTITIES TO KEEP THE
GROWTH THIS INDUSTRY SAFE
CONTROLLED AND REGULATED.
THE GOOD PART OF THE STORY IS
THAT THERE ARE GOOD ACTORS THE
CAMPUS ADVERTISING WORLD.
BUT I FOUND THE MORAL COMPASS
AND EVER AND HAVE REMOVED AND
RESTRICTED ADVERTISING. TO JUST
LEGAL CANNABIS BUSINESSES ONLY
LEAVE FULLY THE MOST VISITED
CANNABIS WEBSITE IN THE WORLD --
HAS REMOVED ALL I'M LICENSE CAN
WITH BUSINESSES IN MARCH OF
TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND CONTINUES TO
RESTRICT ANY ADVERTISEMENTS FROM
ILLEGAL BUSINESS AT LEAST FULLY
MADE A CONSCIOUS EFFORT TO
FOLLOW STATE LAW.
IN THAT WE ALLOW PLATFORMS LIKE
WE'D MATH TO CONTINUE TO PROFIT
AND BOLDLY LEGAL OPERATIONS SO
WITH LOOKING.
THE OTHER WAY WHILE ILLEGAL
BUSINESS TO SATURATE THE MARKET
MORE TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS ARE
FOLLOWING THE PROFITABLE
BUSINESS MODEL OF SUPPORTING
ILLEGAL BUSINESSES.
AND THE SLIPPERY SLOPE OF MAKING
ENFORCEMENT AND TAX COLLECTION
NEAR IMPOSSIBLE OR JUST TO
INSPECT IT TO JUST TOO EXPENSIVE
FOR LOCAL MUNICIPALITIES.
THIS BILL OF AN EFFORT TO
DECENTRALIZE THE ENFORCEMENT OF
WHAT IS AN EXPENSIVE AND
DAUNTING TASK FOR LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT TO HOLD ENABLERS OF
THE LEGAL BUSINESSES.
ACCOUNTABLE THEIR BILLBOARDS
MAGAZINES INTERNET ADS FLYERS
MOBILE APPS AND OTHER PLATFORMS
TO MONITOR AND THE MOST
EFFECTIVE AND COST EFFECTIVE WAY
OF DOING THIS IS TO EDUCATE THE
PUBLIC AND INCENTIVIZE THEIR
MONITORING -- FOR INAPPROPRIATE
CONTENT WE'VE RESTRICTED THIS
KIND OF ADVERTISING OF ILLEGAL
ACTIVITY BEFORE AND THE OWNERS A
BACK PAGE DOT COM HAVE SERVE
JAIL TIME FOR THEIR AIDING AND
ABETTING OF ILLEGAL ACTIVITY.
SO THIS IS NOT A PRECEDENT
SETTING BILL.
LAS VEGAS THAT WE'D MAP THE
SYSTEM THE FIFTH AND THE FIFTH
LETTER -- FROM THE TURNING
DEPARTMENT TO WRAP UP PLEASE THE
PROBLEM -- AND THEY'VE BEEN HELD
ACCOUNTABLE MANY OTHER STATES OF
HELD TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS
ACCOUNTABLE AND THEY HAVE ALL
COMPLIED I WOULD LIKE THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THE WHOLE THESE
TECHNOLOGY PLATFORMS ACCOUNTABLE
AND GUIDE THE MARKET. TO A SAFE
AN ACQUITTAL POSITION FOR THE
REST OF THE WORLD TO EMULATE
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU ACCESS PLEASE IT'S
CHAMBER MEMBERS COMMITTEE
ALBERTO TO RECALL ON BEHALF THE
UNITED FOOD AND COMMERCIAL
WORKERS WESTERN STATES COUNSEL.
YOU FEW DOUBLES BEEN INVOLVED
WITH THE WITH THE CANNABIS
INDUSTRY FROM THE OUTSET THE
STATE WIDE INITIATIVES
LEGISLATION.
REGULATIONS.
OUR PRINCIPAL OBJECTIVE IS TO
RAISE THE SENATE LIVING IN THIS
INDUSTRY ONE OF THE FACTORS THAT
IS SEVERELY UNDERCUTTING OUR
EFFORTS.
IS THE ILLICIT MARKET PLACE THIS
BILL CUTS INTO THAT.
THE PUBLIC PARTNERSHIP AND GIVES
ANOTHER TOOL FOR ENFORCEMENT
WHICH IS A VERY LIKE IN THE
STATE LOCAL LEVEL.
RESPECT ASTRONOMICAL THANK YOU
THANK YOU WOULD ANYONE ELSE LIKE
TO SPEAK IN SUPPORT. TO COME
FORWARD GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
JIM CRAIG ON BEHALF OF THE
BUILDINGS IN SUPPORT.
DANIEL SHARP CENTRAL AMERICAN
RESOURCE CENTER OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
JOHN AKITA DIRECTOR OF THE LA
COUNTY DEPARTMENT CONSUMER
BUSINESS AFFAIRS ON BEHALF OF LA
COUNTY.
IN SUPPORT AS OF LAST WEEK.
CHRIS RESPONSIBLE CHIRLA AND
SUPPORT WE JUST FROM THE
POSITION LAST WEEK.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
STRUCTURE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JIM HE WORKED WITH
CALIFORNIA NEWS PUBLISHERS
ASSOCIATION WE WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR AND YOUR STAFF FOR
WORKING WITH US ON THE
AMENDMENTS. TO ADDRESS THE
CONCERNS THAT WE RAISED AND OF
WHAT YOU KNOW THE WERE NEUTRAL
IN THE BILL NOW THANK YOU.
RIGHT THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION NEUTRAL OTHERWISE.
ALRIGHT SING NONE OF BRING IT
BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SIGNUP THIS REVIEW YOU MAY CLOSE
YOU HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU.
CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY MAIENSCHEIN
OBERNOLTE PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THE BILL NEEDS THREE MORE SO
PROTOCOL THANK YOU THANK YOU
[inaudible]
RIGHT.
RIGHT MR COLOR ARE YOU READY
PERCENT.
SO WE'LL START WITH.
AB FOUR OH THREE YOU HAVE TO
BILLS GIVE A PREFERENCE.
RIGHT WILL START WITH A BEFORE --
THREE THEN.
WE DO HAVE A MOTION IS THERE
SECONDS.
AND A SECOND THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMEMBERS
AB FOUR OH THREE INCREASES THE
STATURE LIMITATIONS FOR FILING A
WORKER RETALIATION CLAIM FROM
SIX MONTHS. TO THREE YEARS AND
HAS THE ABILITY TO SEEK
ATTORNEY'S FEES FOR FAILING.
EMPLOYEES WORKPLACE RETALIATION
OCCURS AND EMPLOYERS JUST CHARGE
THREATEN WITH DOES CHARGE DEMOTE
SUSPEND OR SUBJECT EMPLOYEES TO
AN ADVERSE ACTION FOR EXERCISING
THEIR RIGHTS UNDER THE LABOR
CODE.
POINTS RETALIATION CAN RANGE
FROM SUBTLE WORKPLACE
INTIMIDATION TO OUTRIGHT THREATS
SUCH AS THREATENING DEPORTATION.
IT IS TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
RETALIATION COMPLAINT REPORT THE
LABOR COMMISSION REPORT
ACCEPTING OVER TWENTY FIVE
HUNDRED CASES PER INVESTIGATION
RESULTING IN OVER. FIFTY TWO
HUNDRED VIOLATIONS ALLEGED.
ACCEPTED COMPLAINTS MAY ALLEGE
MULTIPLE VIOLATIONS.
ROUGHLY HALF OF THE COMPLAINTS
ALLEGED VIOLATIONS LABOR COULD
LET NO TWO POINT FIVE WHICH
PROTECTS WHISTLE BLOWERS
SPECIFICALLY FROM ITALIAN XIN.
TELL USES ONLY PERVASIVE BUT
ALSO A GROWING PROBLEM TO THE
CURRENT POLITICAL CLIMATE
SURROUNDING IMMIGRATION.
IMMIGRANT WORKERS ARE OFTEN
AFRAID TO COME FORWARD WORKPLACE
RETALIATION CLAIMS FOR A VARIETY
OF REASONS HOWEVER WHEN THEY DO
ESPECIALLY GIVEN.
OR DO OR DO TO LACK OF AWARENESS
THE SHORT STATURE LIMITATIONS
THE CLAIM IS NO LONGER ELIGIBLE
TO BE FILED.
EVEN IF WILL PLAY HAS A STRONG
CLAIM OFTENTIMES THE BURDEN OF
PAYING ATTORNEYS FEES CAN BE A
DETERRENT.
A DETERRENT FOR TO GRIEVE WORKER
ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH LOW WAGE.
TWO YEARS AGO LEGISLATORS AND
LEGISLATURE ADOPTED THE GOVERNOR
SIGNED SB NINETY SIX INTO LAW
WHICH PROVIDED THE DEPARTMENT OF
LABOR STANDARDS.
ENFORCEMENT THE RIGHT TO RESUME
ATTORNEY'S FEES FROM THE
EMPLOYER IF THE LABOR COMMISSION
PREVAILS.
THIS BILL SIMPLY BUILDS UPON SB
NINETY SIX PROVIDING THAT SAME
RIGHT TO PRIVATE CHARITIES.
TAKE THESE RETALIATION CASES
OFTEN ON PRO BONO STATUS ON
BEHALF OF WORKERS.
AND IT ONLY ENTITLES THE FEES IF
THE WORK PREVAILS IS REALLY A
KEY COMPONENT.
THIS IS NOT A BILL THAT IS
INTENDED TO INCREASE FRIVOLOUS
LITIGATION AS THE OPPOSITION
ARGUES RATHER PROVIDES
ADDITIONAL SENSIBLE AND REGIONAL
WASTE WORKERS PURSUE RECOURSE
WHEN THEY HAVE BEEN UNFAIRLY
RETALIATE AGAINST FOR INVOKING
THEIR LEGAL RIGHTS UNDER STATE
LAW. EIGHTY FOUR OH THREE
STRENGTHENS LEGAL RIGHTS WHISTLE
BLOWERS FACE TIE ASIAN AND
ESPECIALLY HELPS LOWER WAGE
WORKERS ATTAIN LEGAL
REPRESENTATION.
WITH ME TO PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS WITH SOBRE TOLD
FROM SANTA CLARA COUNTY WAKES UP
COALITION AND CAITLIN VEGAS THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH THIS PLEASE.
MY NAME IS RUTH SILVER TELL BY
SUPERVISE THE WORKERS RIGHTS
CLINIC AT ALEXANDER COMMUNITY
LAW CENTER AT SANTA CLARA
UNIVERSITY SCHOOL OF LAW.
AND COORDINATE THE WAIT STAFF
COALITION.
OF SORRY OR BRING BACK BUT TO
YOU.
THANK GOOD MORNING -- THE
EXISTING LAW PROVIDES WORKERS
WITH ONLY SIX MONTHS TO FILE A
CLAIM AT THE LABOR COMMISSION
FOR WORKERS WHO ARE RETALIATED
AGAINST BECAUSE THEY COMPLAIN
ABOUT A VIOLATION OF THE LABOR
CODE OR FOR WHISTLE BLOWERS.
I HAVE SUPERVISED THE CLINIC FOR
FIFTEEN YEARS AND HAVE SEEN THE
FULL RANGE OF RETALIATION AND
WHICH WAS A BLOWER CASES FROM
TERMINATION TO ACTUAL THREATS TO
KILL. TO WORKER WHO WAS BEATEN
UP WHEN HE ASKED FOR HIS WAGES
SINCE THIS SINCE THE ELECTION OF
DONALD TRUMP THERE HAS BEEN AN
UP TICK AND THREATS OF
RETALIATION.
FROM SEVEN IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN NINETY FIVE IN TWO
THOUSAND AND SEVENTEEN AND I
RECENTLY TALKED TO A DEPUTY
LABOR COMMISSIONER IN THE
RETALIATION UNIT UNIT.
WHO TOLD ME IT IS EVEN HIGHER
NOW I HAD SEVERAL CASES WHERE
THE EMPLOYER LEFT MESSAGES ON
VOICE MAIL WITH THREATS OF
DEPORTATION WHERE THE EMPLOYER
THREATEN THE WORKER OVER THE
PHONE?
AND SHE WAS ABLE TO LEGALLY
RECORDED BECAUSE HER BOYFRIEND
WAS ALSO ON THE PHONE AND SPOKE
WHERE THE EMPLOYER IS GOING TO
THE WORKPLACE OF THE WORKER AND
HER COUSIN AND THREATEN THEM NOT
ONLY WITH DEPORTATION.
BUT ALSO WITH THE VIXEN FROM
THEIR APARTMENT AND A RECENT
CASE WHERE THE EMPLOYER WAS THE
ONLY ONE WHO KNEW WHERE THE
WORKER LIVED REPORTED HIM TOP
ICE.
AFTER REFILED THE WAGE CLAIM AND
ICE PICKED HIM UP AND HE'S NOW
IN MEXICO A SIX MONTH STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS IS TOO SHORT TO IN
ONE CASE WE HAD.
A SECURITY GUARD MADE A HEALTH
AND SAFETY COMPLAINTS AND WAS
FIRED SHE CAME TO OUR CLINIC
AFTER SEVEN MONTHS BECAUSE SHE
THOUGHT THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS WAS THREE YEARS AS
IT IS IN WAGE CLAIMS.
OTHER WORKERS WHO COMPLAINED
ABOUT UNPAID WAGES AND WERE
FIRED CAME TO OUR CLINIC TOO
LATE IN MANY CASES A WORK -- IS
THREATENED WITH DEPORTATION BUT
NOT FIRED AND IS AFRAID TO FILE
WATCH YOUR SHE IS STILL WORKING
FOR THE EMPLOYER HOWEVER ONCE
HERE SHE LEAVES THE WORKPLACE
AND GETS ANOTHER JOB.
THEY ARE WILLING TO FILE THE
RETALIATION CLAIM IF THEY FILE
THE WAGE CLAIM THEY WOULD HAVE
THREE YEARS HOWEVER.
IF SIX MONTHS OF A LAPSE SINCE
THE THREAT THEY CANNOT FILE LOW
WAGE WORKERS ALSO LACK ACCESS TO
ATTORNEYS FEES AND RESOURCES
THEY NEED TIME TO FIND AND
GATHER EVIDENCE AND GATHER IT.
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS FOR
RETALIATION AT ABOUT AT OTHER
AGENCIES AS LONGER AT THAT LSAT
THAT'S THE THE LAW THAT SAID
FORCE BY THE DEPARTMENT OF LABOR
IS TWO YEARS THREE YEARS OF ITS
WELL. FOR ONE YEAR AT THE DFG H.
I HAD WORKED AT THE EEOC AND
IT'S THREE HUNDRED DAYS IF YOU
BRING THIS ELEVEN OH TWO POINT
FIVE IN COURT YOU HAVE TWO YEARS.
BUT IF YOU BRING IT AT THE LABOR
COMMISSION YOU ONLY HAVE SIX
MONTHS AND IF THE WAGE LOSS IS
LOW THERE'S NO WAY THAT THIS
WILL BE BROUGHT IN COURT THERE'S
ALSO WHEN ATTORNEYS THE
PROVISION.
AND THERE'S MANY PROVISIONS FOR
ATTORNEYS FEES AND OTHER
STATUTES FLSA WHISTLEBLOWER ACT
AND ALSO FOR AT THE EEOC AND THE
HOW THE FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND
HOUSING.
ARE I MEAN THE DEPARTMENT OF
FAIR EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING THAT
ENFORCES FIAT THE OPPOSITION IS
CLAIMING THAT IT WILL ENCOURAGE
FRAIL FRIVOLOUS LITIGATION BUT
ATTORNEYS LOSE EVERYTHING IF
THEY BRING A FRIVOLOUSLAWSUIT.
IN FACT THE BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
VALID CASES NOW ATTORNEYS WON'T
TAKE CASES BECAUSE THERE'S NO
FEES ATTORNEYS A BRING CLAIMS
FOR DISCRIMINATION HARASSMENT OR
WAGE THEFT ARE ABLE TO RECOVER
ATTORNEY'S FEES. ELEVEN OH TWO
POINT FIVE IS AT ODDS WITH THOSE.
THERE'S A STRONG PUBLIC POLICY
TO PROTECT WORKERS AT RISK FOR
THEIR JOB OR FOR OPPOSING ABUSES.
THE BILL IS IMPORTANT TO LOW
WAGE PREDOMINANTLY IMMIGRANT
WORKERS THAT I REPRESENT AND I
URGE YOU TO VOTE YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S WITH US.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS CAITLIN VEGA
FOR THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION ALSO KAREN STRONG
SUPPORT.
I WOULD JUST ADD THAT -- FOR
EMPLOYERS RETALIATION AS A
WEAPON USED TO SILENCE WORKERS
IT'S IT'S AT A PUNISHMENT
BECAUSE WORKERS SPOKE OUT AND
REPORTED ISSUES LIKE WAGE THAT
LIKE UNSAFE WORKING CONDITIONS.
SO THE WORKER HAS ALREADY HAD
THEIR RIGHTS VIOLATED SPOKEN OUT
ABOUT IT AM BEEN PUNISHED OF
COURSE THEY'RE RELUCTANT TO THEN
COME FORWARD TO COMPLAIN ABOUT
RETALIATION BECAUSE THEY'VE
ALREADY SEEN WHAT WILL HAPPEN
WHEN THEY SPEAK OUT ABOUT
WORKPLACE CONDITIONS.
THAT MAKES IT EVEN MORE
IMPORTANT AND THAT THE
RETALIATION STATUTE BE
LENGTHENED INSTEAD IT'S MUCH
SHORTER THAN THE UNDERLYING
VIOLATIONS SO IT IT IT I THINK
IS THE REVERSE OF WHAT.
AND NEEDS TO BE THE CASE.
I WOULD OUT ALSO IN TERMS OF THE
PUBLIC POLICY THERE BEEN A LOT
OF REPORTS RECENTLY AROUND --
THE BOEING WORK FORCE WHEN THEY
WENT NON UNION AND AND THERE
WERE ALL THESE SAFETY VIOLATIONS
THAT WORKERS WANTED TO REPORT
THEY TOO WERE PUNISHED FOR
SPEAKING OUT.
ABOUT THE SAFETY VIOLATIONS SO
IT'S NOT ONLY ABOUT THE
INDIVIDUAL WORKER IT'S ABOUT THE
WORKPLACE CULTURE AND THE
CULTURE OF FEAR THAT GETS
CREATED WHEN RETALIATION IS NOT
TAKEN SERIOUSLY.
IT'S ALSO ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
AND WORKERS BEING ABLE TO REPORT --
VIOLATIONS OF THEIR OWN RIGHTS
AND ALSO ISSUES THAT ARE THREAT
TO PUBLIC SAFETY AND FOR THEM TO
BE PROTECTED SO WE'RE HEARD
STRUCK SUPPORT THIS BILL
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THAT'S WHAT THIS THAT ANYONE
ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SHE HARD ON BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA PLUMMET LAWYERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
JESSICA CENTER ON BEHALF OF
EQUAL RIGHTS ADVOCATES IN
SUPPORT.
THE LARA STRAND FLORES ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
RENEE BORRADOR IS HERE YOU
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
CORAL HENDON I STRONGLY SUPPORT
THIS BILL BECAUSE WORKERS LIKE
ME SHOULD HAVE MORE TIME TO FILE
THE RETALIATION EARLY NINETY
WILL TAKE MORE TESTIMONY WHICH
IS TAKING NAME AND AFFILIATION.
I SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
CHRIS RESPONSE WHICH ALLOWED
STRONG SUPPORT WE JUST TOOK
POSITION LAST WEEK.
NO I BOTTOM A WITH CALIFORNIA
RURAL LEGAL ASSISTANCE
FOUNDATION IN SUPPORT.
LEYVA RESERVE YOU WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PROGRAM POLICY CENTER
ALSO STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU
ANYONE ELSE AND SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
THIS DISCOUNT IS.
TO GOOD MORNING THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
TESTIFY TODAY MY NAME'S LAURA
CURTIS AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE -- WE ARE NOT IN
OPPOSITION TO THE EXTENSION OF
THE STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS AND
WITH REGARD TO THE LABOR
COMMISSIONER DEPARTMENT.
WE ARE ONLY IN OPPOSITION TO THE
ONE SIDED ATTORNEY'S FEE
PROVISION THE REASONS BEING THAT
WE FEEL THAT THE UNDERMINE CITY
LOC PROCESS IN TWO WAYS FIRST IT
UNDERMINES THE PROCESS OF THE
DEAL AS HE BECAUSE MORE
INDIVIDUALS.
IF THEY'RE ALLOWED ONE SIDED
ATTORNEY'S FEE RECOVERY WILL
FILE THE CLAIMS IN CIVIL COURT
DIRECTLY BECAUSE MOST OF THESE
CLAIMS ARE BROUGHT ON A
CONTINGENCY FEE BASIS OF THE
EMPLOYEE ACTUALLY HAS NOTHING TO
LOSE WHAT THE ATTORNEY MIGHT.
THE EMPLOYEE HAS NOTHING TO LOSE
WITH FILING A CLAIM IN CIVIL
COURT BECAUSE THEY HAVE NO UP
FRONT COST.
THAT'S OUR FIRST CONCERN WITH
THE DEAL AS HE PROCESS THE
SECOND IS THERE IS SOME
POTENTIAL AMBIGUITY WITH THE ONE
SIDED ATTORNEY'S FEES WERE THAT
COULD BE RECOVERED THROUGH THE
DEAL AS THE PROCESS ITSELF.
RIGHT NOW THE DEAL AS THE
PROCESS HOLDS THE EMPLOYEES HAND
THEY WALK THEM THROUGH THE
PROCESS.
THEIR INVESTIGATOR ACTUALLY
INVESTIGATE THE CLAIMS THE
EMPLOYER IS NOT ACTUALLY --
OFTENTIMES NOT PROVIDE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT EVIDENCE
OTHER OFTENTIMES NOT A PROVIDE
AN OPPORTUNITY.
TO REMEDIATE THERE AT POTENTIAL
FEES THAT MIGHT AT THE AT THE
AMOUNT OF THE ATTORNEYS FEES AT
THE PLAINTIFF'S ATTORNEY MIGHT
BE BRINGING WITH THIS.
CLAIM IF IT'S FILED WITH THE
DALLAS EAT AND SO OUR CONCERN IS
IS THAT IF MORE OF THESE CLAIMS
ARE FILED BECAUSE OF THE
ATTORNEYS FEES PROVISION THAN IT
WOULD BE ALLOW FOR A MORE
CONTENTIOUS DELISTED PROCESS.
IF THAT'S NOT THE CASE AND IT'S
ONLY ATTORNEYS FEES WITHIN THE
CIVIL COURT THEN WE SEE MORE
THESE CLAIMS BEING FILED
DIRECTLY IN CIVIL COURT AND NOT
UTILIZING THE DEAL AS THE
PROCESS AND SO THESE POTENTIAL
CLAIMS WOULD CLOG UP THERE --
CIVIL COURT AND SO THOSE ARE
CONCERNS OVER ALL -- BUT WE ALSO
AGREED -- FEEL THAT IF THERE ARE
GOING TO BE ATTORNEYS FEES
PROVISION ADDED IT SHOULD NOT BE
ONE SIDED BOTH PARTIES SHOULD
HAVE STUCK THE SAME STAKE IN THE
CLAIM.
THAT WILL DRIVE DOWN FOR FELIZ
LITIGATION AND THAT'S OUR
OVERALL CONCERN AND FOR THOSE
REASONS WE ARE POST THANK YOU
FOR YOUR TIME.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
SINGER BRING BACK TO COMMITTEE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE WE MISTER KALRA.
YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISTER CHAIR -- AND I APPRECIATE --
THE THE CHAIR SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL COMMITTEE SUPPORT FOR THE
BILL -- AND JUST JUST A COMMENT
ON ON WHAT THE REALITY IS AND
THE REALITY IS THAT -- BUT GIVEN
THE FACT.
THAT ATTORNEYS MAY LOSE THAT
WE'RE NOT GONNA REALLY HAVE --
AN ONSLAUGHT OF ATTORNEYS
LOOKING FOR LOW WAGE WORKERS
THAT IN GENERAL HAVE VERY --
ALTHOUGH POTENTIAL SETTLEMENT
CLAIMS -- YOU HAVE BEEN TO GO
AFTER IT AS CLIENTELE TO TAKE TO
THE COURTS RIGHT NOW ON PLEASE
REALLY I KNOW GENUINE ABILITY TO
SEEK JUSTICE IN OUR COURT SYSTEM
ONE OF THE FEW OUT TO USE THE
HOT THEY HAVE.
IS AN EGG IS OF WHAT.
SILVERTONE DOES IN TERMS OF THE
LAW CLINIC.
AND GETTING SOME ATTORNEYS FEES
ALLOWS A LAW CLINIC TO ACTUALLY
REPRESENT MORE PEOPLE.
AND AND ALLOWS THEM TO BE ABLE
TO OFFER JUSTICE. TO WORKERS AND
SO THAT'S WHY THE ATTORNEY FEES
A PORTION IS SO IMPORTANT EIGHT
IT WON'T.
I HAD TO GREATER LITIGATION
AGAIN BECAUSE ONLY THE
PREVAILING SIDE WILL WIN AND
THIS IS NOT LIKE OTHER TYPES OF
CIVIL ACTIONS WERE THE POTENTIAL
PAY OUT IS GOING TO BE ENORMOUS --
YOU KNOW I ATTORNEYS ARE VERY
CAUTIOUS WHEN IT COMES TO USING
THEIR TIME ESPECIALLY IF THEIR
GOAL IS TO MAKE MONEY -- THIS IS
NOT THE ROUTE TO GO -- BUT
YOU'RE TRYING TO BUY LOW WAGE
WORKERS BEING TAKEN ADVANTAGE UP
WHAT IT WILL ALLOW FOR IS THOSE
LAWYERS THAT ARE.
ATTEMPTING TO HELP WORKERS SEEK
JUSTICE TO BE ABLE LEASE GET
SOME COMPENSATION TO ALLOW THEM
TO REPRESENT MORE WORKERS AND
MORE SPECIFICALLY ALLOW OF NON
PROFITS CLINICS.
SUCH AS THE ONE THAT MISSED OVER
TOLD -- BUT RUNS AB TO BE ABLE
TO REPRESENT -- TO BE ABLE TO
REPRESENT -- MORE WORKERS AND
GIVE THEM A VOICE AND IT WON'T
STOP THE WORKERS FROM GOING
BEFORE THE LABOR COMMISSION.
AS WELL AND SO -- IN ANY CASE I
I STRONGLY.
ASKED THAT -- WITH THE COMMITTEE
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND AND OTHERS
LIKE IT THAT I HAD MORE
OPPORTUNITY FOR WORKERS TO SEEK
JUSTICE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND THAT MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS KALRA PLEASE
STONE BY STONE AYE GALLAGHER
CHAU.
CHIU GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN OBERNOLTE
PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
WITH THE BILL LAW CALL IT NEEDS
THREE MORE VOTES.
SO THAT TAKES US TO ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB [inaudible]
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO YEAH
[inaudible]
POSSIBLE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS ASSEMBLY BILL THAT IN
SIXTY TWO WILL TAKE MEANINGFUL
ACTION TO CURB AVOIDABLE PLASTIC
USE A TINY BOTTLE BATH
TOILETRIES IN THE LODGING
INDUSTRY.
THE PROLIFERATION LIBERATION OF
PLASTIC WAYS HAVING A
DEVASTATING IMPACT ON OUR
ENVIRONMENT AND IS PLEASING OUR
OCEANS.
STILL USE PLASTIC IS ALSO ADDING
TO OUR LANDFILLS THOSE TINY
PLASTIC SHAMPOO BOTTLES AND
OTHER PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS
REPRESENT A SIZEABLE AMOUNT OF
WASTE.
THAT CAN EASILY BE ELIMINATED
THROUGH MORE COST EFFECTIVE AND
ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY
ALTERNATIVES.
SB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO PROHIBITS A
LODGING ESTABLISHED FROM
PROVIDING SMALL PLASTIC BOTTLES
CONTAINING CHRIS AND PERSONAL
CARE PRODUCTS. TO A GAS ANY
SLEEPING ACCOMMODATION.
CURRENTLY -- THE BILL PROVIDES A
THREE YEAR OF IMPLEMENTATION
DELAY TO GET BUSINESSES TIME TO
DEPLETE THE CURRENT STOCK.
INSTALL DISPENSERS ENSURE THAT
DISTRIBUTION OF SUPPLY AND OF X.
I HAVE EXPRESSED TO THE
CALIFORNIA HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION WILLINGNESS TO
PROVIDE SMALLER ESTABLISHMENTS
AN EXTRA YEAR TO COMPLY.
GENTLY MANY BUSINESSES AND
BRANDS THE HOTEL INDUSTRY --
ALREADY PHASING OUT THE SMALL
PLASTIC BOTTLES IN FAVOR OF FOR
IN FAVOR OF A FILLABLE
DISPENSERS.
BY NOT OFFERING SMALL PLASTIC
BOTTLES OF PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS HOTELS MOTELS AND OTHER
LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS WE CAN
REDUCE SINGLE USE PLASTIC
CONSUMPTION AND INCREASE
CONSUMER AWARENESS.
ABOUT USE OF PLASTIC -- IN IN
FACT THE REASON WHY WE SEE THE
INDUSTRY MOVING IN THIS
DIRECTION IS IN MUCH PART DUE TO
CONSUMER PREFERENCE.
I'VE BEEN A PRODUCTIVE
CONVERSATION THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION.
AND REALLY WANT TO THANK THEM --
FOR PRACTICALLY WORKING WITH US
TO TRY TO RESOLVE AS MANY
IMPENDING ISSUES WE MAY HAVE --
IT IS MY HOPE TO KEEP WORKING
WITH INDUSTRY INCOME TO THE
GOVERNMENT ARE MAKING IT CLEAR
BUT PRODUCTS ARE SUBJECT TO THE
BILL.
AND ENFORCEMENT END -- BUT IT'S
IT'S ALSO.
GOOD TO KNOW THAT THE INDUSTRY --
IS SUPPORTIVE OF WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO BECAUSE THAT'S THE
DIRECTION ARE GOING AND I THINK
IT'S AN INDUSTRY THAT HAS BEEN
AGGRESSIVE ON ISSUES OF THE
ENVIRONMENT.
AND THIS IS ONE MORE EXAMPLE
BECAUSE WE SEE THE INDUSTRY
MOVING IN THIS DIRECTION ALREADY.
THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS RECOGNIZE
THE CHALLENGES OF APPLYING A
SAFE HARBOR USED FOR HUMAN
TRAFFICKING POSTING TO THIS BILL --
AND HOPEFULLY THERE'S PROGRESS
TO CLARIFY WHICH PRODUCTS ARE
COVERED THAT PROVISION WILL NOT
BE NECESSARY.
ALSO NOTHING IN THE BILL WOULD
PROHIBIT HOTEL GUESTS AND BRING
IN THEIR OWN SMALL BOTTLE
TOILETRIES PATEL FROM OFFERING
CONVENIENCE ITEMS OUTSIDE THE
ACCOMMODATION ROOM.
WITH SO MANY VIABLE ALTERNATIVES
PROVIDING SMALL PLASTIC BOTTLES
OF PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS LIKE
SHAMPOO THE LODGING INDUSTRIES
IN A PRIME POSITION TO PHASE OUT
THE PRACTICE.
AND CONTINUE THEIR COMMITMENT TO
ABOUT OF WHAT ABOUT AMOUNTS TO A
SHIP A PRODUCING PLASTIC WASTE.
AND BY SOME ESTIMATES THERE ARE
AS MANY AS HALF A BILLION OF
THESE LITTLE BOTTLES.
THAT ARE PUT IN THE ROOMS IN
CALIFORNIA IN JUST A SINGLE YEAR
SO WE'RE NOT TALKING ABOUT A
SMALL ISSUE ARE SMALL PROBLEM
EVEN THOUGH THE BOTTLES MAYBES.
I WOULD BE PROVIDE SUPPORTING
TESTIMONY IS CAN HEY WHAT
PRESIDENT OUR COMMUNITIES AND
GENEVIEVE AVEDON REPRESENT THE
CLEANS HIS LOBBYING COALITION.
THANK YOU FIRST WITH US PLEASE.
HELLO THANK YOU GUYS -- FOR HAVE
ME SPEAK HERE TODAY MY NAME'S
KEN HAYWORTH AND FOUNDER
INVENTOR AND PRESIDENT OF OUR
COMMUNITIES WE ARE AN AMENITY
FIXTURE MANUFACTURER BASED HERE
IN CALIFORNIA BUT DOING BUSINESS
ALL OVER THE WORLD.
I'M IN SUPPORT OF ASSEMBLY BILL
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO I BELIEVE THAT
FROM MY EXPERIENCE IN OVER NINE
YEARS IN THE INDUSTRY THAT IT
SHOULD BE EASY YES DECISION FOR
ALL OF YOU.
ENVIRONMENTALLY FOR THE PLANT
WE'VE ALL SEEN THE PLASTICS ARE
DOING TO OUR WORLD THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL WILL
SAVE UP TO A THOUSAND SMALL
BOTTLES.
IN OVER FIVE GALLONS A PARTIALLY
USE PRODUCT BECAUSE WE ONLY USE
25% ON AVERAGE.
OF THOSE LITTLE BOTTLES AND ALL
OF YOU HAVE BEEN IN HOTELS --
FROM LANDFILLS PER ROOM PER YEAR
ADDITIONALLY WILL CREATE
ANCILLARY SAVINGS AND FREIGHT
PACKAGING.
WASTE REMOVAL AND RECYCLING
FINANCIALLY FOR THE HOTELS IT'LL
SAVE HER HOTELS BETWEEN THIRTY
AND 45% FROM THEIR CURRENT
AMENITY BUDGETS LIMITING THEIR
FRIGHTENED PACKAGING LOWER IN
THEIR WASTE AND RECYCLING BILLS.
FURTHER IT LIMITS OPERATIONAL
TIMELINES AS TO PLACING PIC
REDELIVERY AND CLEAN UP OF THE
SMALL BOTTLED.
BOTTLES IN THE ROOMS.
WE COME TO SEE OVER THE LAST FEW
YEARS A GREAT MOVEMENT ACROSS
OUR COUNTRY WITH COMPANIES LIKE
I. H. G. INTER CONTINENTAL HOTEL
GROUP DISNEY MARRIOTT HYATT AND
OTHERS PHASING OUT THE USE A
SMALL BOTTLES WITH FOCUS ON THE
ENVIRONMENT.
THIS YEAR ALONE I. H. G. CREATED
A BRAND STANDARD FOR CANDLE
WOULD STAY BRIDGE SUITES HOLIDAY
INN EXPRESS AND EVEN HOTELS WILL
SAVE.
OVER A HUNDRED AND THIRTY
MILLION PLASTIC BOTTLES AND OVER
FIVE HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND
GALLONS A PARTIALLY USE PRODUCT
FROM OUR LANDFILLS.
IMAGINE A GALLON OF MILK FIVE
HUNDRED AND TEN THOUSAND OTHERS.
WITH FINANCIAL SAVINGS TO THOSE
HOTELS OF OVER TWENTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
ALSO WE SEEM TO BEEN CONTACTED
BY MORE MORE FLAGS TO THE DESIRE
TO MOVE TOWARDS A MORE
SUSTAINABLE SOLUTION FOR THEIR
MANY PROGRAMS.
WE DON'T SEE THIS IS MERELY AN
ECONOMICAL DECISION.
WHICH IT CERTAINLY IS BUT MORE A
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL.
ONE FROM A GUEST PERSPECTIVE DUE
TO THE SAVINGS HOTELS ARE ABLE
TO PROVIDE A BETTER QUALITY
PRODUCT FOR THE GUESTS AND
FURTHER THAT FURTHER ENHANCES
THE GUEST EXPERIENCE.
AND WORKS IN TANDEM WITH THE
ZERO A SOLUTION THAT THE GUESTS
ARE EXPECTING -- THIS INCREASE
IN DEMAND IS FORCED AMENITY
DISPENSER COMPANIES LIKE MYSELF
TO CREATE A BETTER GREATER
DIVERSITY IN THE PRODUCT
OFFERING IT'S NO LONGER IS THAT
THE BOX OF GOO THAT YOU MAY
REMEMBER.
THERE'S A A MUCH BETTER PRODUCT
OUT ON THE MARKET -- AND FINALLY
EVERY DAY WE HEAR ABOUT A
PLASTIC IS INVADING OUR PLANET
NOW THERE'S FIVE FLOATING
ISLANDS.
THE SIZE OF TEXAS ON OUR OCEANS
AND WHAT THE COST WOULD BE.
TO JUST CLEAN UP THE SURFACE OF
OUR OCEANS SAY NOTHING ABOUT
WHAT LIES BENEATH.
YOU ALL HAVE A CHANCE TO MAKE A
CHANGE TO NOT ONLY LIMITS THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR PLASTICS TO
REACH OUR OCEANS BUT ALSO SAVES
MONEY FOR THE PROPERTIES
INCORPORATING IT.
THERE ARE FEW THINGS THAT YOU
CAN DO.
TODAY THAT WILL INCREASE THE
SIZE OF YOUR CONSTITUENTS
POCKETS.
AND HELP TO MAKE THE WORLD A
BETTER PLACE I HOPE THAT YOU
MAKE A DECISION IT MEANS
SOMETHING. TO THIS AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS AND SAY YES TO A. B.
ELEVEN SIXTY TWO AND INSPIRE A
POSITIVE CHANGE.
THANK YOU TODAY FOR YOUR TIME
AND HOPE YOU'LL JOIN ME IN A
SPORT FOR ASSEMBLY BILL ELEVEN
SIXTY TWO THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT
THIS PLACE.
GOOD MORNING CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS GENEVIEVE AVEDON AND
I REPRESENT THE CLEAN SEIZE
LOBBYING COALITION THAT CONSISTS
OF ELEVEN NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
THROUGH CALIFORNIA.
INCLUDING HEAL THE BAY SURFRIDER
FOUNDATION SAVE OUR SHORES AND
MANY OTHERS -- AS YOU KNOW
PLASTIC POLLUTION AFFECTS EVERY
STREAM RIVER PARK AND STREET IN
CALIFORNIA IT STARTS WITH FOSSIL
FUEL EXTRACTION AND CONTINUES
THROUGH MANUFACTURING
TRANSPORTATION USAGE AND
DISPOSAL.
PLASTICS HAVE RECENTLY BEEN
FOUND TO EMIT POTENT GREENHOUSE
GASES THAT THE AS THEY BREAK
DOWN.
AND WITH THE PLAN 40% INCREASE
IN PLASTIC PRODUCTION OVER THE
NEXT DECADE UNLESS WE MAKE MAJOR
POLICY CHANGES TO COUNTER THIS.
PLASTIC PRODUCTION WILL ACCOUNT
420% OF GLOBAL FOSSIL FUEL
CONSUMPTION.
ADDITIONALLY MICRO PASTA HAVE
BEEN FOUND IN TAP WATER BOTTLED
WATER TABLE SALT FISH SELF
SHELLFISH AGRICULTURAL SOILS AT
CETERA.
ALL OF WHICH POSE A POTENTIAL
THREAT TO HUMAN AND ANIMAL
HEALTH.
ALL OF THIS COMES WITH THE
TREMENDOUS COST TO INDIVIDUALS
AND COMMUNITIES ECOSYSTEMS AND
WILDLIFE ALL ALONG THE SUPPLY
CHAIN.
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SPEND OVER FOUR
HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILLION
DOLLARS ANNUALLY AND ONGOING
EFFORTS TO CLEAN UP AND PREVENT
LITTER.
IN STREET STORM DRAINS PARKS AND
WATER RATES.
NOT ONLY IS THIS EXPENSIVE BUT
IT CANNOT KEEP PACE WITH THE
PRODUCTION OF SINGLE USE
DISPOSABLE ITEMS WHICH CONTINUES
TO GROW EXPONENTIALLY.
NEITHER CAN EXISTING RECYCLING
INFRASTRUCTURE WITH LESS THAN 9%
OF PLASTIC HAVING BEEN RECYCLED
AND THAT PERCENTAGE DROPPING
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
POLICIES AND CHINA AND OTHER
COUNTRIES.
WHICH IS SEVERELY RESTRICTED THE
AMOUNT OF FOREIGN WASTE THEY
ACCEPT.
COUNTLESS TINY BOTTLES OF
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER LOTION AND
OTHER PRODUCTS ARE THROWN AWAY
EVERY DAY BY THE HOSPITALITY
INDUSTRY.
BECAUSE OF THE SIZE OF THESE
BOTTLES THE CRASH OF A RECYCLING
MARKET AND THE FACT THAT MOST
ARE DISCARDED WITH SOME AMOUNT
OF PRODUCT STILL IN THEM.
THEY ARE NOT RECYCLABLE IN MOST
COMMUNITIES MORE SUSTAINABLE
METHODS LIKE WALL MOUNTED
DISPENSERS TO PROVIDE GUESTS
WITH THESE PERSONAL CARE
PRODUCTS EXIST AND ARE BEING
USED AS I'M SURE YOU'VE SEEN AS
CAN HAS REFERRED.
TO ALL COMMUNITIES SUCH AS SANTA
CRUZ A MODERATE AREAS ARE
ACTIVELY WORKING TO REMEDY THIS
ISSUE ESTATE MIGHT MEASURE WILL
ELIMINATE THE NEED FOR COMMUNITY
BY COMMUNITY APPROACH.
THUS WE EAT RESPECTFULLY URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE ON THIS IMPORTANT
MEASURE THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLACE.
FLOOR COMMON BEHALF OF SIERRA
CLUB CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT AND
I'VE ALSO BEEN ASKED TO REGISTER
SUPPORT FOR CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS THANK YOU.
KILLER ROBINSON ON BEHALF OF
RETHINK WASTE IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE AND
SUPPORTS.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION
[inaudible]
YEAH.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR JOHN
CALLED ONE HALF THE CALIFORNIA
HOTEL LODGING ASSOCIATION WE'RE
WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO WHAT THE
WE'VE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH THE
AUTO WE'RE NOT OPPOSED TO WHAT
THE AUTHOR IS TRYING TO DO --
WAIT WE THINK WE HAVE SOME VERY
REASONABLE AMENDMENTS THAT WE'VE
TALKED HIM ABOUT FIRST -- OUR
INDUSTRIES A LEADER IN
SUSTAINABILITY IN HAS
DEMONSTRATED A HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT TANGIBLE COMMITMENT TO
ENVIRONMENTAL STEWARDSHIP THE
INTERNATIONAL.
THE I. H. G. INTERNATIONAL
CONTINENTAL HOTELS GROUP HAS
RECEIVED THE HIGHEST SCORE FOR
THE INDUSTRY.
ON THE CORPORATE SUSTAINABILITY
ASSESSMENT HILTON HAS REDUCE
LANDFILL WASTE BY 41% ACROSS
MANAGED HOTEL SINCE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT HI IT HAS COMMITTED TO
DIVERTING 40% OF ITS WASTE.
FROM LANDFILLS MARRIOTT
INTERNATIONAL HAS SET A GOAL TO
REDUCE ITS WAYS IT SOUNDS TO THE
LANDFILLS BY. 45% BY.
TWENTY TWENTY FIVE SO WE TAKEN
RECOGNIZED IN INNOVATIVE STEPS
TO CREATE A MORE SUSTAINABLE
FUTURE WHICH IS WHY WE ASK.
FOR THIS COMMITTEE THIS AUTHORED
IS TO CONSIDER SOME AMENDMENTS
TO HELP.
AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO MEN MELD
WITH THESE EXISTING
ENVIRONMENTAL INITIATIVES.
WE RESPECTFULLY ASK THE SCOPE OF
THE BILL BE LIMITED TO SHOWER OR
BATH ACCESSORIES WHICH THE
INDUSTRY HAS ALREADY BEGUN IN
EARNEST OVER THE PAST DECADE.
WITH SEVERAL HOTEL BRANDS
ALREADY MOVING AWAY AS IT HAS
BEEN DISCUSS FROM THE SINGLE YOU
SHAMPOO CONDITIONER AND LIQUID
SOAP.
WE THINK -- THE DEFINITIONS AND
MAKE MADE EXPAND MAY GO UP
BEYOND THAT GROUP IN NATURAL
RESOURCES COMMITTEE FOR EXAMPLE --
THE CHAIR LAURA FRIEDMAN ASKED
WHETHER MOUTHWASH WOULD BE
COVERED TO FACE WILL BE COVERED
YEAH AND THE WAY THE BILL'S
WRITTEN TODAY PROBABLY YES.
SO WE WOULD WE WOULD LIKE TO
KNOW THAT -- SECONDLY THE BILL
HAS TWO SECTIONS OF FOR
ENFORCEMENT ONE SECTION WOULD
HAVE THIS LAW ENFORCED BY CITY
ATTORNEY COUNTY COUNCIL OR
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
WE'RE OKAY WITH THAT -- BUT THE
BILL ALSO GIVES ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITY TO QUOTE A STATE OR
LOCAL AGENCY WITH AUTHORITY TO
INSPECT SLEEPING ACCOMMODATIONS.
WE HAVE NO IDEA WHO THAT IS ON
THE STATE LEVEL -- AND WITH FIVE
HUNDRED CITIES IN FOR FIFTY
EIGHT COUNTIES NOT CLEAR THAT'S
GOING TO BE ON A LOCAL LEVEL WE
THINK IT'S SEXUAL ONLY CAUSE
CONFUSION WE SUGGEST A SECTION
BE ELIMINATED IN THE ENFORCEMENT.
IN THE BILL FOR THE CITY
ATTORNEY THE COUNTY COUNCIL AND
THE AGE YOU WERE REMAIN.
WE HAVE ALSO ASKED FOR
PREEMPTION OF LOW OF LOCAL
ORDINANCES ENACTED AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF THE BILL.
NOT NOT SO WHAT WOULD NOT
PREEMPT YEARS THAT THE SANTA
CRUZ -- THE SANTA CRUZ ORDINANCE
BUT WE DON'T WANT TO HAVE TO
DEAL WITH THE NEW REQUIREMENTS
ON A CITY CITY BY CITY BASIS
AFTER THE INDUSTRY.
HAS.
COME UP WITH A DEAL HERE AND
WE'VE PAID MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
TO TO COMPLY WITH THE LAW -- AS
A AS TALK ABOUT WE'VE REQUESTED
A RIGHT TO CURE PROVISIONS
SIMILAR TO WHAT'S REQUIRED IN
THE HUMAN TRAFFICKING SIGNAGE
LAW -- LASTLY WE REQUEST AN
IMPLEMENTATION DATE OF JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY FIVE FOR ALL
OF LODGING ESTABLISHMENTS WITH
FIFTY ROOMS ARE MORE AND TWENTY
TWENTY SIX FOR THE SMALLER
ESTABLISHMENTS.
THIS IS A LONGER THAN WHAT'S IN
THE PRESS PRESENT BILL BUT OUR
OUR OUR MEMBERS BELIEVE THAT
IT'S GOING TO TAKE SOME TIME NOT
ONLY.
THE CONTRACTS THEYHAVE EXIST
BUT MAKING THE TRANSITION BUT
ALSO TRYING TO FIND OUT WHAT THE
CONSUMER WANTS WHAT THE WHAT THE
CONSUMER WANTS -- AGAIN WE'RE
NOT TRYING TO YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
TRYING TO GET A WOOD GOT THIS
BILL GOT THIS LAW WHAT WE'RE
TRYING TO DO IS WORK WITH WORK
WITH THE AUTHOR WAS SO WE CAN
PHASES WE CAN PHASE THIS BILL IN
IN A MANNER THAT WORKS WITH THE
PUBLIC.
AND WORKS WITH THE THE INDUSTRY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
EXCEPT FOR THIS.
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MANUALLY ON BEHALF OF THE
PERSONAL CARE PRODUCTS COUNCIL A
TRADE ASSOCIATION REPRESENTING
ABOUT SIX HUNDRED SMALL MEDIUM
LARGE COSMETIC AND PERSONAL CARE
COMPANIES.
MANY OF THEM LOCATED HERE IN
CALIFORNIA WE ALSO HAVE TO
REGISTER RESPECTFULLY ARE OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION ON THIS
BILL -- WE WOULD ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH A SOME OF THE CONCERNS OF
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY AS STATED --
BEFORE I GO INTO THAT I ALSO
THINK I SHOULD NOTE THAT OUR
INDUSTRY TO IS TAKING THE ISSUE
OF SUSTAINABILITY VERY SERIOUSLY.
WE HAVE FORMED A THIRD PARTY
COALITION GROUP -- CALLED THE
SUSTAINABILITY -- IN PACKAGING
IN BECAUSE MEDICS SPICE FOR
SHORT.
AND WE'RE LOOKING AT ISSUES
AROUND RECYCLABILITY COMPOSED
ABILITY AND EVEN -- BIODEGRADE
ABILITY OF THE THE BOTTLES THAT
WE ARE USING SO WE'RE TAKING
THIS ISSUE VERY SERIOUSLY.
THERE ARE ALSO TWO PENDING BILLS
IN THE LEGISLATURE THAT LOOK AT
THIS ISSUE MORE BROADLY --
AROUND PACKAGING AND AND PRODUCT
PACKAGING IN PARTICULAR -- IN
THE CITY'S SUSTAINABILITY THERE
OF AND WE ARE ACTIVELY AND
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE BILL
SPONSORS -- ON THOSE TWO
MEASURES -- WHERE WE ALIGN WITH
THE HOTEL INDUSTRY AND THEIR
CONCERNS IS NUMBER ONE WE'D LIKE?
TO INCREASE OR PUSHED OUT
IMPLEMENTATION DATE AS WELL NOT
ONLY WELL THAT AID SOME OF THE
SMALLER HOTEL CHAINS BUT IT WILL
ALSO HELP SOME OF THE SMALLER
AND MEDIUM SIZED.
COSMETIC COMPANIES -- THAT
AREN'T AS NIMBLE OR DON'T HAVE
AS MUCH RESOURCES AS SOME OF THE
LRGER MULTINATIONAL
CONGLOMERATES THAT HAVE SET VERY
AGGRESSIVE DATES FOR RELATIVE TO
SUSTAINABILITY -- WE LIKE TO
GIVE THE SMALLER MEDIUM SIZE
COMPANIES MORE TIME -- THE
SECOND ISSUE IS WE ALSO ALIGNED
WITH THE HOTEL INDUSTRY'S
CONCERNS AROUND THE LIMITING THE
SCOPE OF THE PRODUCTS WE WOULD
LIKE TO SEE AND UNDERSTAND --
WHAT THE THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
IS BECAUSE RIGHT NOW IT'S -- SO
CONDITIONER AT SHAMPOO LOTION
BUT NOT LIMITED TO THOSE
PRODUCTS WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSTAND.
THE SCOPE AND THEN LASTLY --
PERMISSION TO USE PROPS.
YES -- THE THE BILL DEFINES THEY
SMALL -- FOR PURPOSES OF BILL
WHAT WHAT THE BILL WOULD BAN IS
ANYTHING TWELVE OUNCES OR BELOW.
AND WHEN WE LOOKED AT THE BILL
WE ARE.
NOT REALLY FAMILIAR WITH WHAT
TWELVE OUNCES REALLY LOOKS LIKE
HERE'S WHAT YOU'LL FIND IN MOST
HOTELS WHICH IS ONE POINT TWO
NOW ONE POINT TWO OUNCES.
OR THERE ABOUTS AND THE BILL
WOULD BAN -- PRODUCTS ANYTHING
LESS THAN TWELVE LIEU ANSWERS OR
BELOW.
NOT MANY HOTELS ARE GIVING
PATRONS THE SIZE OF A BOTTLE --
WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE BILL
MORE CLOSELY ALIGNED WITH THE
PRODUCTS THAT ARE PROVIDED TO
THE PATRONS WHICH IS AROUND ONE
POINT TWO OUNCS -- WE FEEL MUCH
MORE COMFORTABLE WITH THAT
APPROACH -- WERE ALSO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE BILLS -- POTENTIAL TO
BAND THE HOTEL LOBBIES OR THAT
THE GIFT SHOPS FROM SELLING
PRODUCTS WHICH THEY OFTEN DO SO
WITH THOSE A CLOSE MY COMMENTS.
THANK YOU.
ANYONE ELSE IN OPPOSITION
BECAUSE YOUR NAME AND YOUR
AFFILIATION THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN FIRST ON CAP KHIMIK YOU
KEPT CAN ASSOCIATES ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION WE
APOLOGIZE FOR THE LATE NOTICE --
BUT WE ALIGN OUR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSED UNLESS AMENDED POSITION
OUT WITH THE PERSON THANK YOU.
WHEN CHAIR AT A REGULAR ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE WE ALSO ALIGN OUR
COMMENTS WE HAVE AN OPPOSE
UNLESS AMENDED POSITION THANKS?
HELLO AFFECT WORKERS FOR THE
SEMINAL BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
THE TRIBE HAS -- TO OFF SITE --
OFF RESERVATION HOTELS WOULD BE
AFFECTED AND WORKING WITH THE
HOW THE AUTHOR HAS STAFF NOW
WHEN WE HONOR OUR QUESTION
AMENDMENTS OF THOSE OF THE
INDUSTRY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT SEE NONE THE BRING IT
BACK QUESTIONS COMMENTS WAS
YOUNGER.
YEAH SO I GUESS WHAT I'M
THINKING ABOUT HERE'S LIKE WHY
DO WE NEED A BAND EXACTLY RIGHT
I MEAN. ONE I'M JUST NOT A BIG
FAN OF OF BANDS -- AND YEAH I
LIKE THESE THINGS MAN I I
COLLECT THESE STUFF IN THE HOTEL
ROOM TO BRING THEM HOME.
AND IT SEEMS TO ME AND THIS IS
JUST MY SUBJECTIVE OBVIOUS THI
IS LIKE AN EASIER THING TO
RECYCLE RIGHT LIKE.
IS THIS YOU KNOW TO ME IT'S LIKE
THAT'S THE THAT'S ONE OF THE
FIRST THINGS I WOULD TO ALONG
WITH MY MILK JUGS INTO THE BLUE
RECYCLE BIN YOU KNOW -- BUT
THAT'S JUST ME RIGHT I MEAN SO
IS THERE SOME DATA OUT THERE AND
MAYBE YOU ALREADY TALKED ABOUT
THIS IT SHOWS THAT.
THESE ARE JUST NOT RECYCLED AT
ALL THAT I MEAN WHAT WHAT IS
THAT DATE AND MAYBE YOU CAN JUST.
LAY THAT OUT FOR THE AND FEEL
FREE TO FOLLOW UP.
MY EXPERT TESTIMONY BUT A ONE OF
THE ISSUES IS THE CONTAMINATION --
ISSUE -- THE INFO.
MY UNDERSTANDING OF ACTUALLY
FROM MY CITY COUNCIL DAYS THAT
THERE'S A LOT ISSUE A
CONTAMINATION RECYCLES CYCLES
THAT FEDERAL BEING RECYCLABLE --
AND ALSO SIZE THE THE SMALLER
THE ITEMS LESS LIKELY THEY ARE
TO BE -- ARE TO BE RECYCLED I
DON'T KNOW IF WE HAVE EXACTED ON
BOTTLES ITSELF HOWEVER I WILL
SAY.
THAT THE OWNERS THIS BILL CAME
FROM -- INFORMATION HEARING THAT
MR SHARE A HELD IN SANTA CRUZ
AND THERE WAS A PRESENTATION
THAT DID -- AND I'D BE HAPPY.
TO FOLLOW UP AND AND GET SOME OF
THE REPORTS THAT -- MIGHT LEAD
TO THIS BEING ONE OF THE
SUGGESTIONS TO REDUCE PLASTIC
WASTE THAT MAY HAVE MORE DATA OR
MORE POTENTIAL INFORMATION AS TO
THE SCOPE OF THE ISSUE.
BY NO CONTAMINATION IS A BIG
PART OF IT AS WELL AS THE SIZE
THAT LEADS TO A LOWER LIKELIHOOD
OF IT BEING RECYCLED.
I'LL JUST ADD THAT ARE RECYCLING
MARKET IS IS CRASHING I MEAN
WE'RE IN A CRISIS ONLY NUMBER
ONE TO NUMBER TWOS OR IF THERE'S
A MARKET -- FOR AND SO BECAUSE
OF THAT WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
CHINA RIGHT NOW YEAH YEAH.
SO A LOT OF A LOT OF THESE ITEMS --
ESPECIALLY THE ONE OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT WAS SHOWN EIGHT
DON'T BELIEVE IS A ONE OR TWO SO
IF YOU BUT THEN YOU RECYCLE BIN.
IT'S JUST GOING TO CONTAMINATE
RECYCLING IN EITHER GO TO
LANDFILL -- BUILD UP IN IN THE
RECYCLING CENTERS I ALSO HAVE
THE TWINS YOU KNOW SO I I USE A
LOT OF WIPES AND SO YOU KNOW WE
HAD THAT PREVIOUS BILL.
ANYWAY.
IT WAS -- SO AND THEN IT SOUNDS
LIKE THE INDUSTRY'S MOVING AWAY
FROM THIS RIGHT LIKE IT SOUNDS
LIKE A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
ACTUALLY MOVING AWAY ALREADY.
SO IF THEY'RE ALREADY KIND OF
MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
YEAH I MEAN DO WE AGAIN WE NEED.
AN ALL OUT BAN WELL I THINK THAT
THAT YOU KNOW THE ARGUMENT
BEFORE BY THE WAY IF THE IF
INDUSTRY WASN'T AND WE ARE
PUTTING THIS IN PLACE THE
ARGUMENT WOULD BE WHILE YOU'RE
ENFORCING SOMETHING THAT.
WE DON'T WANT TO DO I THINK THAT
IT'S A IT SHOULD BE.
GOT MORE GREATLY APPRECIATED
THAT A BILL COMES FOR THAT'S
ACTUALLY ENCOURAGING THE CONTACT
THAT'S ALREADY OCCURRING IN THE
TRENDS THAT ARE OCCURRING.
BY MAKING IT A STATEWIDE POLICY
RATHER THAN HAVING JURISDICTIONS
DO IT ONE BY ONE WHICH WHICH IS
ONE OF THE ISSUES THAT WE
DISCUSSED THEY DISCUSSED MISSED
CALL OTHER DAY.
YESTERDAY -- OR RATHER THAN --
OF HAVING A DIFFERENT SET OF
PROTOCOLS WHAT YOU DO IS YOU
SIMPLY IS OKAY YOU'RE MOVING
INSTRUCTION ANYWAY.
LET'S MOVE FORWARD IT ALLOWS
INDUSTRY -- ORGANIZATIONS TO
HELP FACILITATE THE TRANSITION --
ESPECIALLY FOR SMALLER HOTELS I
HAD ALLOWS LARGER SHOULD HOTELS
TO SET AN EXPECTATION AS TO HOW
THEY'RE GONNA HAVE THEIR SUPPLY
CHAIN SET UP -- BUT THE BOTTOM
LINE IS THAT WE HAVE TO DO MORE.
TO A LIMITED AMOUNT OF CLASSES
COMING IN OF PEOPLE BEING
PRODUCED AN ENTRY ALWAYS STREAM
AND THIS IS JUST ONE OF MANY
THINGS WE NEED TO DO -- IT'S
ALIGNED WITH OTHER EFFORTS TO A
TO MOVE AWAY FROM SEEN THESE
PLASTIC IN OUR STATE THAT I KNOW
THAT WHEN BURKE MANY MEMBERS
BECAUSE ALSO OTHERS.
ARE WORKING ON AND BUT YOU CAN
HAVE THAT GOAL BUT YOU HAVE TO
HAVE ACTUALLY MORE SPECIFIC
INITIATIVES TO ACTUALLY MOVE
TOWARDS THAT GOAL.
AND SO THIS IS AGAIN IT'S A
PUBLIC POLICY.
DEBATE AS TO WHETHER IT'S
VALUABLE FOR US TO GET RID OF
THESE SINGLE USE PLASTIC BOTTLES.
TOILETRIES AND I JUST THINK THE
FACT INDUSTRIES ALREADY MOVING
THAT DIRECTION HOST OF ASSAULTED
AND MAKES IT MORE VIBRANT WHY WE
SHOULD DO IT.
WITHOUT -- I WENT THANK YOU FOR
THE BELL A AT THERE'S THE
PERSONAL SIDE OF ME DOESN'T WANT
HI LITTLE.
BOTTLES TAKEN BECAUSE I REALLY
LIKE TO TAKE THEM HOME --
CULTURAL.
WE DON'T WASTE -- BUT BILLIONS
OF WASTE IN THE SEVEN I'M
TALKING ABOUT AT SO BUT I AM BUT
I UNDERSTAND I MEAN THAT'S
PERSON I KNOW 91% OF PLASTICS
THAT WE PRODUCE DON'T GET
RECYCLED AND SO WE WOULD THAT WE
HAVE KIND OF A AT I NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
I DO HAVE A QUESTION ABOUT LIKE --
THE REQUEST LIKE AT THE FRONT
DESK IF YOU FORGET TO PASTE MORE
THAT WILL BE AVAILABLE AND ABLE
TO BE GIVEN TO YOU IN A SMALL
SIZE SO THAT WILL STILL BE
AVAILABLE AS WELL AS THE THE HAS
SHOPS THERE IN THE LOBBIES.
THAT SELL SMALL SIZE PRODUCTS
WILL ALSO STILL BE A BE
AVAILABLE THIS IS JUST IN THE IN
COMBINATION WITH ITSELF.
OKAY -- IN THIS IS JUST HOTELS
NOT SPAS.
THIS IS A OF A LODGING YES
THAT'S CORRECT Là LODGING
ESTABLISHMENTS PLEDGE MISTER
THAT'S CORRECT THANK YOU I I'M
OF THE BILL IF IT HAS BEEN MOVED
IT HAS NOT BEEN MOVE THAT IS A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION
AND A SECOND.
RIGHT OTHER QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SEEING NONE MISTER CARR YOU MAY
CLOSE THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
JUST RESPOND -- AND I I DO WANT
TO THANK OPPOSITION I THINK THAT
THE AGAIN BOTH WITH OVER THERE
IS THE PERSONAL CARE INDUSTRY OR
THE LODGING INDUSTRY.
OTHER BOTH MOVING IN THAT
DIRECTION AND IN THE IN THE
RIGHT DIRECTION AS FAR AS WERE
CONCERNED -- SPECIFICALLY -- IN
TERMS OF CLARA FIND DEFINITIONS
AND I HAD A REALLY GOOD
CONVERSATION YESTERDAY THIS CALL
WELL ABOUT IT WE'RE GOING TO
CONTINUE TO HAVE CONVERSATIONS
BUT I DO AGREE I THINK WE NEED
TO HAVE GREATER CLARIFICATION.
AS TO BOTH OF THE WITNESSES ARE
CONCERNS AND WE WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THAT TO HAVE A MORE
CLARITY IN TERMS DEFINITIONS --
WE ADDED SOME ADDITIONAL
LANGUAGE I THINK THE ADDED SOME
CLARITY IN ONE REGARD BUT
CRITICS ON CONFUSION OTHER SUB
GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK ON
THAT.
AND IN TERMS OF THE THE ISSUE OF
LOCAL VERSES OTHER ENFORCEMENT
THE REASON WHY WE HAVE THE LOCAL --
WHETHER IT'S COUNTY PUBLIC CALL
FOR OF LOCAL CULTURES IS -- THE
REALITY IS PRAGMATICALLY THEY'RE
THE ONES ARE MORE LIKELY THEY'RE
GOING TO BE ABLE.
TO SEE AND IDENTIFY THE FACT
THAT A HOTEL -- MAY NOT BE
COMPLYING AND LET'S KEEP IN MIND
THAT IN THAT CASE THE FIRST
VIOLATIONS A WARNING LETTER SO
IT WE'RE NOT INTENDED TO BE
PUNITIVE.
IT IN THAT REGARD WE JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT ONCE THE AND
THE ISSUES IDENTIFIED THAT IT
COULD BE RECTIFIED IN A WAY THAT.
THAT'S AS EFFICIENT AS POSSIBLE
AND AGAIN THE AMENDMENTS THAT
WE'VE ADDED AND WILL CONTINUE TO
ADD -- EXTEND THE TIMELINE TO
THREE YEARS AND WORK WE'VE UP IN --
ON THE RECORD HERE ARE IN
AGREEMENT THAT WILL EXTEND INTO
FOUR YEARS FOR SMALLER
ESTABLISHMENTS AND WE THINK
THAT'LL BE SOMETHING THAT I WILL
GET PLENTY OF TIME FOR THAT
ADJUSTMENT.
AND IN TERMS OF PREEMPTION THIS
IS AN ISSUE THAT WAS FIRST AT
LEAST IN DIALOGUE BROUGHT UP
YESTERDAY BUT WE HAD A VERY GOOD
CONVERSATION ON THAT I THINK
COULD BE SOMETHING THAT -- WE
COULD WORK ON IN TERMS TO MAKE
IT EASIER FOR LOCAL
JURISDICTIONS NOT HAVE TO GO
THROUGH THE PROCESS OF NOT
HAVING LOCAL ORDINANCES IF WE
COME TO AN AGREEMENT THAT WE
BELIEVE MAKE SENSE.
THAT -- THERE COULD BE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO CONTINUE TO TALK
ABOUT LOCAL PREEMPTION BUT AGAIN
I REALLY WANT TO THANK THE
OPPOSITION THAT WE GOT A LOT OF
DIALOGUE.
THE ENTIRE PROCESS AND I WANT TO
REMIND FOLKS THAT EVEN IN BEFORE
THIS BILL IS EITHER INTRODUCED I
SAT WITH THE HOTEL LODGING
ASSOCIATION TO DISCUSS IT
BECAUSE I UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
NEEDS TO BE A COLLABORATIVE
EFFORT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE AND
SO.
I DO APPRECIATE OPPOSITION WITH
THAT ASK FOR AND I'M UP AND WHEN
I BUILT THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A
MOTION A SECOND THE MOTION IS TO
PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE
ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO CHAO CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA AYE KALRA AYE
KILEY MAIENSCHEIN.
MAINTAIN AYE OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE
NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
REYES I THE BILL IS OUT THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHTS -- THIS TAKES US TO
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO MISTER BONTA.
GOOD MORNING MORNING THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES AND STAFF THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT A. B..
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO WHICH IS A
POLICY THAT STANDS UP FOR AND
DEFENDS AND PROTECTS OUR
IMMIGRANTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA
CONSISTENT WITH SB FIFTY FOUR
ARE SANCTUARY STATE ACT.
FROM A COUPLE YEARS AGO WHEN IT
BASICALLY SAYS THAT.
NO CITY OR COUNTY OR STATE
JURISDICTION SHALL DO.
SO HAVE A CONTRACT TO DO
BUSINESS WITH A A COMPANY.
THAT.
ENGAGES IN DATA BROKE GREEN OR
EXTREME VETTING OR TO DENT
DETENTION FACILITY SUPPORT THAT
LEADS TO THE DEPORTATION.
OR DETENTION OF OUR FELLOW
CALIFORNIANS AND THE COMPANIES.
CAN MAKE A DECISION AND AND NOT
SHARE DATA.
IN ASSIST ARM ICE OR THE
CALIFORNIA BORDER PATROL IN
WHICH CASE THEY ARE ELIGIBLE TO
HAVE A CONTRACT WITH US BUT IF
THEY DO THEN THAT UNDERMINES IT
IS AN AND RUN IN A LOOP HOLE
AROUND A SANCTUARY STATE
PROVISIONS.
I WE YES IT WE ARE SEXUALLY
USING A STATE TAX DOLLARS.
TO DEPORT DETAIN.
IMMIGRANTS HERE IN CALIFORNIA --
WE TOOK SOME A NUMBER OF
AMENDMENTS TO HELP.
MAKE THE PROCESS LESS BURDENSOME
ON LOCALS THAT WERE I AM.
EXPRESSING SOME CONCERNS ABOUT
THAT NOW THE DOJ WOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING AND
PUBLISHING A LIST OF COMPANIES.
THAT PROVIDE PROHIBITS SERVICES
TO FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AGENCIES
WE ALSO HAVE A COMPONENT OF THE
BILL THAT.
ALLOWS -- OUR PUBLIC AGENCIES TO
DO BUSINESS WITH COMPANIES WHEN
THERE IS NO REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVE.
I THINK THESE ARE ALL
APPROPRIATE STEPS TO MAKE THE
BILL I'M MORE AND IMPLEMENTABLE
AND MORE PRACTICAL.
I APPRECIATE YOUR WORK MISTER
CHAIR -- AND YOUR STAFF WORK I
WITH MY TEAM A TO HELP GET THE
BILL TAB WHERE IT IS WITH THE
WITH THE AMENDMENTS THAT IT HAS --
AND TO I THANK YOU FOR YOUR
CONSIDERATION TODAY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK THE AYE VOTE.
I HAVE WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT BRIAN HOPE.
FOR SECURE JUSTICE LES LOVERS
ABI CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND MAHMOUD TO REACT
COUNCIL OF ON ON AMERICAN
ISLAMIC RELATIONS.
THANK YOU SO JUST TO BE CLEAR
THE MEMBERS ARE LISTED IN THE
ANALYSIS YOU'RE TAKING AS
AUTHORS AND TAKEN.
THANK YOU PERFECT RIGHT FIRST
WITNESS PLEASE.
HONORABLE ASSEMBLY MEMBERS MY
NAME IS BRIAN HOPE FOR AN
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF SECURE
JUSTICE ALPHA CHAIR OAKLAND
PRIVACY COMMISSION.
I WANT TO THANK MEMBER BONTA AND
IS LEGISLATIVE AIDE GRAHAM DRAKE
FOR WORKING WITH OUR COALITION.
AND YOUR WONDERFUL CONSULTANT
JUST MAKING A CENT THANK YOU FOR
LETTING ME INVADE YOUR WEEKEND --
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU THE
INSPIRATION FOR THIS BILL WHICH
CAME FROM TWO OF MY CHILDHOOD
FRIENDS AT WORK IN SEPARATE
FINANCIAL AID OFFICES.
THERE IS SHARING WITH ME THE
pAND GPS PROTECTED STUDENTS FROM
APPLYING FOR FINANCIAL AID.
BECAUSE THEIR PARENTS WERE
SCARED TO PROVIDE DATA TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
AROUND THE SAME TIME IN ALAMEDA
COUNTY SUPERVISOR SHARED WITH ME
THE RESULTS OF THE LOCAL HEALTH
CARE ENROLLMENTS.
AS A COUNTIES LARGE IMMIGRATION
POPULATION CHOSE TO FOREGO
HEALTH CARE THAT THEY'RE
ENTITLED TO BY OPERATION OF LAW.
RATHER THAN PROVIDE DATA TO THE
FEDS.
IMAGINE BEING THOSE PARENTS
CHOOSING TO REJECT HEALTH CARE
AND FINANCIAL AID FOR YOUR KIDS
BECAUSE YOU'RE TERRIFIED THAT
THEY ARE YOU WILL BE DEPORTED.
I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU A QUOTE
FROM A RECENT LEGISLATIVE EFFORT
I WORKED ON WAS -- BART.
PART WAS FOUNDED SHARE DATA WITH
ICE THERE CENTURY TRANSIT
DISTRICT.
PUT IT IN A MERCURY NEWS
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT IS JUSTICE
ALLIANCE THE WORD SANCTUARY HAS
LOST A LOT OF ITS STRENGTH.
TRUST IN ANY STATE AGENCY TO
FULLY SUPPORT THE UNDOCUMENTED
COMMUNITY THROUGH CENTURY FARCES
IT'S SOMETHING WE ARE NO LONGER
GAMBLING WITH.
THIS IS OUR CONCERN THIS BILL IS
STRAIGHT FORWARD IF YOU PROVIDE
SPECIFIC SERVICES TO FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AGENCIES YOUR
INELIGIBLE TO RECEIVE ARE SCARCE
TAXPAYER DOLLARS.
THIS WOULD BETTER ALIGN OUR
BUDGET WITH OUR VALUES.
THIS IS NOT A NEW CONCEPT
PURSUANT TO A BE EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THE STATE ALREADY USES ITS
ECONOMIC POWER IN SUPPORT LGBT
Q. FOLKS.
PROHIBITING STATE FUNDED OR
STATE SPONSORED TRAVEL TO
CERTAIN STATES WITH
DISCRIMINATORY LAWS AND WE'RE
ASKING YOU TO CONTINUE TO BE
SUPPORTIVE OF OUR CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS BEING DISCRIMINATED
AGAINST.
THE DOJ IS NOW RESPONSIBLE FOR
IT -- UNDER EIGHTEEN EIGHTY
SEVEN THE DOJ IS ALSO
RESPONSIBLE FOR IDENTIFYING THE
LIST OF OFFENDING STATES.
MANY LOCALITIES HAVE ADOPTED
ANTI NUCLEAR WEAPONS ORDINANCES
BORDER WALL CONTRACTOR
PROHIBITIONS AND SIMILAR TRAVEL
BANS -- THOSE LOCALITIES HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO COMPLY AND REVIEW
CONTRACTS WITHOUT HURTING THEIR
BUDGETS -- RICHMOND ENACTED A
SOMEWHERE Là LAST JUNE BERKELEY
IS EXPECTED TO DO SO TONIGHT
WE'RE ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
OAKLAND WILL BE VOTING ON MAY
FOURTEENTH.
MY PUBLIC RECORD REQUEST SHOW
THAT TWO TO THREE CONTRACTS AT
ISSUE -- PER CITY IS THE AVERAGE
COUNTIES WITH JAILS WOULD HAVE
FIVE TO SIX CONTRACTS THERE ARE
BECAUSE THE ANALYSIS SHOWS THERE
IS A MULTITUDE OF VENDORS IN
EACH OF THESE CATEGORIES.
WE BELIEVE THERE ARE REASONABLE
ALTERNATIVES.
BY HAVING TO DO J. IDENTIFY THAT
LAST LOCAL ENTITIES ARE RELIEVED
OF THE BURDEN.
BY THE DOJ FIRST NOTIFYING THOSE
COMPANIES IT SHIFTS THE BURDEN
TO THEM TO PROVE THEY DO NOT
PROVIDE SUCH SERVICES.
BY HAVING THIS PROHIBITION AND
LOCAL CONTRACTING SOLICITATIONS
NOTICES LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WILL
BE ASSURE THAT RESPONSE OF
BIDDERS ARE QUALIFIED AND NOT
PROVIDING SUCH SERVICES.
WE ALL KNOW OUR WORLD WAR TWO
HISTORY.
THAT SEEMINGLY BENIGN DATA
COLLECTED BY CENSUS BUREAU'S WAS
USED BY BOTH AMERICAN AND
EUROPEAN GOVERNMENTS TO TARGET
CERTAIN POPULATIONS.
WE HAVE THESE LOOPHOLES ARE GAPS
IN OUR EXISTING CENTURY STATUTES
AND WE'RE ASKING YOU TO HELP
FILL THEM.
WE ASK YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU THAT'S WHAT THIS PLACE
GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS THAT LAY LOWER IS THAT
THE WITH THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER.
I AM PROUD TO BE HERE IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL TODAY OUR
ORGANIZATION IN TWO THOUSAND
SEVENTEEN SUPPORTED PROUDLY SB
FIFTY FOR THE CALIFORNIA VALUES
ACT WHICH WAS PASSED INTO LAW
AND HAS BEEN.
DUBBED BY THE MEDIA FOR BETTER
OR WORSE AS BEST STATE SANCTUARY
LAW -- THE SIMILARLY A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD MAKE
IMPORTANT STEPS IN EXTENDING THE
PROTECTIONS IN SB FIFTY FOUR TO
MAKE SURE THAT THEY'RE TRULY
REALITY FOR ALL OF OUR STATES
RESIDENTS.
WERE BECOMING INCREASINGLY
CONCERNED ABOUT THE USE OF
PRIVATE CORPORATE DATABASES AND
THE WAYS THOSE HAVE THE
POTENTIAL TO COMPROMISE THE
PRIVACYINTERESTS OF OUR STATES
IMMIGRANTS.
IN PARTICULAR UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS -- AS WELL AS FOLKS
WHO'VE BEEN GRANTED A TEMPORARY
LAWFUL PRESENCE BY THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT THIS WOULD INCLUDE
POPULATIONS SUCH AS STOCK --
THAT ARE PARTICULARLY VULNERABLE
IN THESE TIMES -- CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND SECURITY
HASAN OPERATING BUDGET OF FORTY
FOUR BILLION DOLLARS AND IT IS
EVER GROWING. 10% OF THAT MONEY
GOES DIRECTLY TOWARDS DATA
MANAGEMENT SO THAT'S TO SAY 10%
OF THAT MONEY.
GOES TOWARDS PURCHASING THE
PRIVATE INFORMATION OF RESIDENCE --
IN OUR STATE AND ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST IMMIGRANT POPULATION IN
THE ENTIRE COUNTRY WERE ALSO
HOME TO SILICON VALLEY -- AMAZON
HAS BEEN ONE OF THE MOST NOTED
AND REPORTED UPON OFFENDERS IN
TERMS OF SELLING AND
PARTICIPATING -- IN THIS
DETENTION AND DEPORTATION SCHEMA
AND SO WE THINK THAT THERE IS A
UNIQUE OPPORTUNITY AND
RESPONSIBILITY HERE IN
CALIFORNIA. TO DEMONSTRATE
LEADERSHIP BY EXTENDING THE
PROTECTIONS THAT WE HAVE
AFFORDED TO OUR STATE IT
CITIZENS AT TO OUR RESIDENTS
WITH RESPECT.
TO PROTECTING THEIR PHYSICAL
INTERACTIONS -- WITH FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION AUTHORITIES AND
EXTENDING THAT TO THE VIRTUAL
ROUND BY PROTECTING THEIR
PRIVATE DATA AS WELL AND WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THAT'S THAT IS PLEASE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WITH THE AREA FROM THE COUNCIL
ON AMERICAN ISLAMIC RELATIONS.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AS
THE SANCTUARY STATE WE CURRENTLY
LIMIT LOCAL AND STATE AGENCIES
AND THEIR INTERACTIONS WITH
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION AGENCIES.
YEAH OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS
CONTINUE TO BE USED TO SUPPLY
TECHNOLOGY AND DATA THAT ARE
THEN USED ON ONE OF OUR
POPULATIONS.
BY THOSE VERY SAME AGENCIES.
NOW THERE'S NO SURPRISE THAT
THERE'S A LACK OF TRUST FROM
AMERICAN AND COMMUNITY WITH THE
INFLUX OF SURVEILLANCE.
EXTREME VETTING AND THE RISE OF
HATE CRIMES THAT ARE FAR GREATER
TODAY THAN THEY WERE AFTER.
NINE ELEVEN CURRENTLY OUR
COMMUNITY IS RIDDLED WITH FBI
AND ICE INFORMANTS.
AND THE DEPARTMENT OF HOMELAND
SECURITY'S COUNTERING VIOLENT
EXTREMISM PROGRAM -- STATEWIDE
KNOWN AS PREVENTING VIOLENT EX
WAS A PROGRAM.
FUNDS NONPROFITS TO THE VEIL
MUSLIMS AND REFUGEES.
AND COOPERATE WITH DHS.
COMPANIES SHOULD NOT BE IN THE
BUSINESS OF ENHANCING AND
PROVIDING SUPPORT. FOR ISIS
DIRTY WORK.
COMPANY PROVIDING DATA BROKER
EXTREME VETTING AND DETENTION
FACILITY SUPPORT SERVICES ARE IN
CLEAR CONFLICT WITH THE
CALIFORNIA VALLEY'S ACT.
THIS IS WHY CARE IS IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB THIRTEEN THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME AND
YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE.
REBEKAH GONZALEZ NATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL WORKERS
CALIFORNIA CHAPTER.
EMILY GOLDMAN EDUCATORS FOR MIKE
AND JUSTICE IN THE S. G.
TRANSPARENCY INITIATIVE AND VERY
MUCH SUPPORT.
JULIE CHAPMAN OF INDIVISIBLE
SACRAMENTO AND CALIFORNIA
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG AND
WERE IN FULL SUPPORT.
DOUG TROUBLE.
INDIVISIBLE SACRAMENTO IN
INDIVISIBLE STATE STRONG IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
GOOD MORNING I THINK IT'S STILL
MORNING.
A ROB WHICH SHE FOR THE CUSTOMER
OF COMMERCE -- AND WE ARE
STRONGLY OPPOSED TO THIS BILL AS
A JOB KILLER -- BECAUSE IT WOULD
FORCE.
RESPECTED INDUSTRY STANDARD
BUSINESSES OUT OF CALIFORNIA
BASED ON WHAT.
WE'VE DISAPPEAR OF VAGUE --
BLACKLIST -- WOULD LIKE TO THANK
STAFF FOR SPEAKING TO US WE HAVE
BEEN IN TOUCH WITH THE OFFICE
OFFICE AND WE APPRECIATE THAT
TME HOWEVER OUR PRIMARY CONCERN
STILL HAVE NOT BEEN ADDRESSED.
ON TO CLARIFY SOME WHAT WHAT WE
DO IS MISINFORMATION ABOUT THIS.
WE APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
HEARTFELT AND AND EVERYONE HEARS
A HEARTFELT CONCERN ABOUT THE
FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY.
ON HOWEVER AND AND WE DO NOT
OPPOSE THIS SET OF ANY SUPPORT
FOR THAT POLICY THIS BILL IS
MUCH BROADER THAN THAT POLICY IS
MUCH MORE TROUBLING IMPLICATIONS
FOR THE BUSINESS COMMUNITY -- SO --
FIRST THAT'S DEAL WITH THIS
BEING A A PRECISE OR OR DETAILED
BLACKLIST THAT IS NOT THE CASE
OF THE BLACKLIST IS TO FIND TWO
WAYS.
BY WHETHER OR NOT A FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT AGENCY THAT YOU WOULD
CONTRACT WITH PROVIDES
IMMIGRATION RELATED SERVICES --
THAT TERM IS NOT CLEARLY DEFINED
AND AS A COMMON SENSE WOULD SAKE
SURE IT INCLUDES ICE OR SEE KEEP
A CUSTOMS AND BORDER PATROL.
BUT DEPARTMENT STATE ISSUES
IMMIGRATION DOCUMENTS TO PART OF
EDUCATION TEACHES CLASSES --
DEPART OF JUSTICE HILLS
IMMIGRATION COURTS SO WE'RE NOT
TALKING ABOUT A SMALL DEFINED
LIST OF JUST ICE CAN'T WORK
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT ANYONE A
CONTRACT WITH HUGE SUAS THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
NOW HAVING -- THE CONCERNS UP BY
THAT THEY CAN DO BUSINESS IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND WITH RESPECT
TO THE MOMENT KICKING THAT TO
DOJ -- COULD NOT TO THE JUST NOT
ADDRESS OUR CONCERN BECAUSE THE
DOJ WILL CONFRONT THE EXACT SAME
VAGUE LANGUAGE WHICH IS IN FRONT
OF US TODAY.
AND THEY WILL BE ASK WHAT IS
IMMIGRATION RELATED AND THEY
WILL BE UNABLE TO AVOID THE FACT
THAT OUR STATE AND MANY OTHERS
ARE INVOLVED IN -- AS TO THE
SCALE OF THE COMPANY'S COVERED --
BECAUSE THE BLACKLIST WOULD BE
CITIES SO BAG IT'S HARD FOR US
TO EVEN AS A BUSINESS COMMUNITY.
ASSESS HOW MANY BUSINESSES WOULD
BE COVERED BY THIS AND EVEN WHAT
SECTORS -- THE WHAT WE DO KNOW
IS PRESUMABLY MANY MANY TECH
COMPANIES TO BE COVERED BECAUSE
THE BILL TARGETS.
COMPANIES THAT GATHER DATA OR
ANALYZE DATA -- BUT SOME OF THE
EXAMPLES THAT WERE INCLUDED IN
THE AUTHORS -- INITIAL DRAFT
RECITALS DID YOU EXAMPLES OF
REALLY HOW CATACLYSMIC THE
IMPLICATIONS OF OF THIS BILL
WOULD BE TO ANYONE OPERATING ON
PUBLIC AND IN CALIFORNIA.
BY FORBIDDING BASIC NECESSARY
INDUSTRY WIDE STANDARDSERVICES.
MICROSOFT.
I'M I'M SURE EVERYONE IN THIS
ROOM AND I I CAN'T SEVERAL BY
SOON WE ALL USE -- MICROSOFT
WORD MICROSOFT OUTLOOK.
MICROSOFT TO BE OFF LIMITS UNDER
THIS BILL BECAUSE MICROSOFT HAS
AN A. I. THAT ANALYZES DATA FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
SO EVERY PUBLIC AND IN
CALIFORNIA WOULD NEED TO FIND A
NEW EMAIL SERVER -- AND I'LL
DEAL WITH THE REASON ALTERNATIVE
LANGUAGE LATER BUT THAT DOES NOT
ADDRESS THAT -- THOMSON REUTERS
LEXIS NEXIS AT THREE OTHER
ATTORNEYS IN THIS ROOM WE ALL
KNOW THAT A LEXIS NEXIS
WESTLOWER FUNDAMENTAL
FUNDAMENTAL PROJECTS.
THEY ALSO BE OFF LIMITS INTO
THIS BILL BECAUSE THOSE
COMPANIES ACCUMULATE THAT.
IBM JUST AS MENTIONED AMAZON I
DON'T KNOW -- YEAH I CAN'T
PROJECT FOR YOU THE VOTE THE
BREATH HERE BECAUSE THE VEGAS
THE TERMS BUT WE'RE TALKING UP
FOR BIDDING BASIC INDUSTRY WIDE
SERVICES.
IN CALIFORNIA -- LET'S SEE --
NEXT APPOINTMENT TOUCH ON IS
THAT THE THIS IS IN MANY WAYS
OVER KILL THE MAY HAVE NO POINT --
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TARGETING A
FEDERAL POLICY WHICH WAS PUT IN
FOR THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH AND
COULD BE CHANGED TOMORROW IF
TRUMP WANTED TO OR CHANGED AT
THE NEXT ELECTION TWENTY TWENTY
AND PUTTING A CALIFORNIA LAW
PROHIBITION.
BASED ON THAT SO LET'S JUST SAY
TRUMP WAS THE ELECTION TWENTY
TWENTY THIS BILL GOES INTO
EFFECT IN THE LAW ON THE BOOKS
MAKING CONTRACTING CALIFORNIA
THAT MUCH MORE DIFFICULT.
WHEN THE POLICY IS GONNA?
SO IT IS ALSO JUST THAT IN THAT
WAY THE WRONG RESPONSE.
AB I THINK IT WAS TEN SEVENTY
NINE THAT JUST CAME UP THAT
DEALS WITH ICE IMPLICATIONS WE
YOU KNOW UNDERSTAND THAT AND
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT OPPOSED.
TO FOR YOU KNOW DEALING WITH
FEDERAL POLICY THE CHAIR DID NOT
WEIGH IN BUT THIS IS WELL BEYOND.
THAT AREA OF CONCERN IT'S JUST
THE WRONG RESPONSE -- AND WE'RE
GLAD TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS I
THINK THERE'S A LOT OF
MISINFORMATION GOING AROUND
ABOUT THIS BILL BUT FOR INTEREST
OF TIME AND WE'VE BEEN HERE A
LONG TIME -- I WILL STOP THERE
AND PASSES OVER -- TO TO DANGER
WITH THE PUBLIC PERSPECTIVE.
THANK YOU THANK GOODNESS PLEASE
GOOD AFTERNOON HAD CHAIR MEMBERS
OF NOT QUITE YET DâN HUTCHINGS
DELETED CALIFORNIA CITIES -- WE
DO APPRECIATE THAT THE THE
ATTEMPTS MADE BY THE AUTHOR AND
SPONSORS TO ADDRESSING CONCERNS.
THE MEASURE AS WAS STATED CRACK
CREATES A A BLACK LIST OF%
COMPANIES THAT IS ALL TO FIND AN
OVERLY BROAD I WOULD DIRECT YOUR
ATTENTION.
TO SECTION SEVENTY TWO EIGHT
THREE POINT FIVE ONE WHICH
PROVIDES REALLY AN ALL
ENCOMPASSING CABBIE OUGHT -- FOR
IMMIGRATION RELATED SERVICES
WHICH REALLY YOU KNOW IT SAYS
THAT YEAH DO YOU KNOW MAY
INCLUDE BUT IS NOT LIMITED -- TO
IT IN OUR ASSESSMENT IT COULD
ACTUALLY SPEND ALL FOREIGN FORTY
FIVE AGENCIES OF THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT -- CERTAINLY
SOMETHING WE DON'T WANT TO DO
AND SO BY BY DOING BY BEING SO
BROAD -- IT IMPEDES LOCAL
AGENCIES ABILITY TO DO LEGAL
RESEARCH -- DEFEND THEMSELVES
FROM LAWSUITS WOULD HINDER LAW
ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY TO ENTER
EVEN POLICE REPORTS INTEGRATING
THAT WITH OUR NAME A ONE
DISPATCH SYSTEMS -- THERE IS A A
POTENTIAL LOSS OF OF GRANT
FUNDING OR COMPLETING NEW
APPLICATIONS DO A LACK OF ACCESS
TO RESEARCH TOOLS BANNED BY THE
BILL -- UP FOR IT ALSO FORCES
EACH AGENCY TO REVIEW EVERY
CONTRACT PURCHASE ORDER YOU KNOW
EVEN SMALL CITIES AFFECT
THOUSANDS AND THOUSANDS OF BY
PURCHASE ORDERS AND AND AND IN
IN CONTRACTS THEY MAY ISSUE.
IT'S GONNA HAVE TO HAVE US GO
OUT THERE AND REVIEW AND ENSURE
THAT WERE NOT ON YOU KNOW THAT
WE ARE WE ARE IN COMPLIANCE WITH.
THE LISTING TERM BY THE DOJ --
ADDITIONALLY ALTHOUGH IT YOU
THAT THE BURDEN HAS BEEN PLACED
ON DOJ TO ESTABLISH THIS LESSON
DOES NOT PROVIDE ANY PROTECTION
OR DIDN'T VACATION FOR CITIES
WHO ARE STILL VERY VERY MUCH --
LIABLE I SHOULD THEY SHOULD THEY
YOU KNOW NOT K<c.cyan> CONFORM WITH</c>
THE EVER CHANGING SORT OF BLACK
LET'S THAT IS BEING CREATED BY
DOJ -- YOU KNOW IT ALSO YOU KNOW
ONE OF THE THINGS WE FIND YOU
KNOW THIS MUCH IS THE THE
SPONSORS.
IS VERY NARROWLY SCOPED IF YOU
LOOK AT SEVEN TWO EIGHT THREE
POINT FIVE SIX THE BILL IT
CLEARLY SAYS THAT ALL-- STATURE
TO BE INTERPRETED BROADLY TO
EFFECTUATE THE THE TIP TO
EFFECTUATE THE CHAPTER THAT
SCARES US.
BECAUSE NOW YOU'RE LOOKING AT
THIS FROM THE MOST BROADEST POP
POSSIBLE TERMS HOW CAN THIS BE
IMPACTED THIS IS NOT NEARLY IN
SCOUT -- SO ALL TOLD A. B.
THIRTEEN THIRTY TWO BUT STILL
EMPTY THE GOVERNMENT'S ABILITY
TO LEGAL RESEARCH IT WOULD
IMPEDE LAW ENFORCEMENT'S ABILITY
TO UTILIZE A BEST AVAILABLE
TOOLS TO KEEP THE PUBLIC SAFE --
IT WOULD HARM AGENCIES ABILITIES
TO FINANCIAL AND REGULATORY
OBLIGATIONS I WILL INCREASE THE
WORKLOAD -- AND DRIVE A COST
INCREASE DECISIONAL -- AVENUES
FOR THE EDUCATION. FOR OUR
CITIES COUNTY SPECIAL DISTRICTS --
AND AND AGAIN ALL OPPOSED BY
SAYING WE ARE WE ARE IN A VERY
PRECARIOUS MOMENT IN TIME YEAH
I'M AYE AND ON TOP OF ALL MY
OTHER DUTIES ON THE FEDERAL
POLICY THE IS ON FOR THE LEAGUE
OF CITIES AND SO I DEAL WITH ARE.
SOME OF THAT THE ISSUES WE HAVE
FEDERALLY EVERYONE FED IN IN DC
JUST. EIGHTY TALKING ABOUT THAT
THEY KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON IN
THIS IS THIS IS A VERY TEMPORARY
MOMENT IN TIME AND WE'RE PLACING
LIFELONG.
YOU KNOW IT BE YOU KNOW A
RESTRICTIONS ON ON ON ON
CONTRACTS IS VERY VERY GOOD
COMPANIES THAT ACTUALLY SERVE
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND SERVE THE
PEOPLE THAT WE REPRESENT SO WITH
THAT WE MUST.
CONTINUE TO OPPOSE.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION YOU GIVE US YOUR NAME
AND YOUR AFFILIATION PLEASE GOOD
MORNING MR TURN MEMBERS
COURCELLES ALONE BEHALF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE SHERIFFS
ASSOCIATION IN OPPOSITION.
BELIEVE A POINT IS HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE ASSOCIATED GENERAL
CONTRACTORS A CALIFORNIA IN
OPPOSITION.
MAX PER THE CALIFORNIA POLICE
CHIEFS ASSOCIATION AND THE CITY
OF RIVERSIDE ALSO IN OPPOSITION
THANK YOU.
CORNING GENTLE TECHNION
OPPOSITION.
THOROUGHBRED ON BEHALF OF THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
HEALTHCARE DISTRICTS OPPOSITION.
MISTER CHAIR CRISPY KAYLEE ON
BEHALF OF THE COMPUTING
TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
IN OPPOSITION.
JEFF NEAL WITH THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
ALSO POST.
JEAN HEARST HERE TODAY ON BEHALF
OF THE URBAN COUNTIES OF
CALIFORNIA ALSO IN OPPOSITION.
DON'T GIVE US FOR THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION.
CLEAR SHOT HIM WITH THE
INFORMATION TECHNOLOGY INDUSTRY
COUNCIL IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
OPPOSITION.
I'D SAY NONE OF BRING IT BACK TO
THE COMMITTEE QUESTIONS COMMENTS.
SALAS I'M GONNA GO FOR THIS
OBVIOUSLY I'M OF THE BILL.
IT HAS BEEN MOVED YET BUT I'M I
AM CONCERNED.
I'M GONNA PRESENT A BILL TODAY
IN THE MORE WE LEARN.
THE MORE WE REALIZE -- THERE ARE
NO ASSURANCES WE CAN MAKE TO OUR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THEIR DATA --
IT DOESN'T MATTER WHO WE
CONTRACT WITH OUR OWN. EIGHT
GOVERNMENT HAS.
ALLOWED OUR DATA TO BE SHARED
WITH THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT --
UNDER A VARIETY OF OF THE
PROVISIONS IN OUR LAW WE WE HAD
A MEETING YESTERDAY WITH THE DOJ
M. AND THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND
I THINK I I'M.
A LITTLE TAKEN ABACK SO.
NOTHING THAT WE SHOULDN'T DO
ANYTHING -- BUT I I'M GOING MORE
MORE CONCERNED THAT WE'RE GIVING
FALSE.
PROMISES TO OUR COMMUNITIES
ABOUT THEIR DATA AND ARE IN
ABOUT OUR ABILITY TO STOP --
DERANGED PRESIDENT PROBLEM FROM
UTILIZING NOT -- TO TERRORIZE
OUR COMMUNITY SOUTH I'M GONNA
SUPPORT THIS TODAY I WANT TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH -- THAT
THE AUTHOR ON THIS BECAUSE I
THINK THAT THAT IS AN IMPORTANT
FEATURE -- YOU KNOW I'VE BEEN
ASKED ABOUT THIS BILL LOT IN AND
HOW IMPORTANT THIS IS AND I'M
STARTING TO BELIEVE THAT.
NOTHING WE CAN DO IS REALLY
GONNA KEEP THE DATA OF OUR
COMMUNITIES OUT OF THE HANDS.
OF THIS ADMINISTRATION SO JUST
THAT'S KIND OF A I DON'T THINK
SHE WHERE ANYTHING.
I THINK IT WOULD GIVE A MOST AND
IS THERE A SECOND.
THANK YOU AND A SECOND.
SERVICE BONTA AYE THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD.
I DO SORT OF SHUDDER WHEN WE
TALK ABOUT THIS NOTION OF
SANCTUARY STATE BECAUSE SB FIFTY
FOUR DID NOT IN FACT CREATE A
SANCTUARY STATE IT'S THAT'S
THAT'S JUST POLITICAL RHETORIC.
I WISH WE COULD I WISH THERE WAS
MORE THAT THAT WE COULD DO TO
PROTECT OUR CITIZENS.
ACTUALLY IN IN.
THIS NEAR TIME FRAME WHEN WE'RE
STRUGGLING WITH VERY AGGRESSIVE
IN ABUSIVE FEDERAL POLICY.
THE THE ONE POINT THAT THE
OPPOSITION BRINGS THAT I THINK
WE NEED TO BE COGNIZANT OF AND
I'M SUPPORTING THIS BILL AS IT
AS IT MOVES FORWARD.
BUT WE'RE PUTTING IN PLACE
STRUCTURES AND LAWS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT ONCE WE GET A
MORE RATIONAL FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
WE'RE GONNA PUT PROBABLY HAVE TO
GO BACK AND FIGURE OUT.
HOW TO ADDRESS THOSE AND I THINK
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT WE NEED TO
BE VERY COGNIZANT UP AS AS WE
MOVE FORWARD SO WE CAN BE
PROTECTIVE BUT UNWINDING THINGS
THAT ARE NO LONGER NECESSARY?
PERHAPS OVERLY RESTRICTIVE SEEMS
SOMETHING THAT THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO TAKE VERY VERY SERIOUSLY.
ALL RIGHT -- THIS VOTE TO MAKE
CLOTHES.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY I APPRECIATE THE
CONCERNS RAISED BY THE CHAIR AND
BY THE PROVISIONS CHAIR -- I
THINK IT IS IMPORTANT WE DON'T
OVER PROMISE OUR OUR COMMUNITIES
WHAT WE MAY NOT BE ABLE TO
DELIVER.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THIS BILL
MAKES IMPORTANT PROGRESS ANIMALS
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION IT'S
HELPFUL.
IT IT CAN CHANGE LIVES IT CAN
PROTECT -- CALIFORNIANS IT MIGHT
NOT BE THE POLICY OR THE CURE
ALL -- BUT IT IT MAKES PROGRESS
AND IT IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
RESPONSE.
TO AT THE MOMENT AT AND I
UNDERSTAND THAT MUCH OF WHAT
WE'RE DOING TERMS FOR A POLICIES
MAKING SURE WE WE STAFF FOR
VALUES TO PROTECT.
ARM ARE PEOPLE BASED ON THIS
MOMENT AND IF THE MOMENT CHANGES
AND I HOPE IT DOES.
I BELIEVE IT WILL -- WE CAN
REACT ACCORDINGLY THEN THAT'S
THE BEAUTY OF HAVING LEGISLATION
THAT WE INTRODUCED EVERY YEAR --
NO ONE SAYS THIS IS BEING
WRITTEN IN STONE BUT THIS IS
NEEDED NOW.
AND THIS WILL HELP PEOPLE TODAY.
AND SO I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO PRESENT TODAY AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK DR -- THANK YOU
WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BY STONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
CHAU.
CHAU AYE CHU.
CHU AYE GONZALEZ.
AND SALAS AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
REYES.
THE BILL IS OUT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF THANK
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN MISTER
HOLD
[inaudible]
THIS OLD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR OUT ITS
BY.
PLEASURE TO PRESENT A BE
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN TO YOU
TODAY I WANT TO THANK THE STAFF
FOR WORKING WITH US AND ALWAYS
BEING CONSTRUCTED AND AND GUIDES
US ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK OUR
STAKEHOLDERS WHO HAVE WORKED ARE
CLOSELY WITH US ON THIS ISSUE AS
WELL -- A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY
SEVEN SUBJECTS PROPERTY.
ON A HOSTED PLATFORM TO ANTI
DISCRIMINATION LAWS.
THE CREATION.
OF OF THE CREATION OF A NEW OF
NEW MARKETS FACILITATED BY THE
INTERNET OR A LEGAL GRAY AREA.
AND EVER CHANGING WORLD IT IS
NECESSARY OUR LAWS NECESSARY FOR
LAWS TO REFLECT THE
TECHNOLOGICAL ADVANCEMENTS THAT
ARE BEING MADE.
CURRENTLY THE DEPARTMENT OF FAIR
EMPLOYMENT AND HOUSING HANDLES
DISCRIMINATION COMPLAINTS ON
HOSTING PLATFORMS. FOURTEEN
NINETY SEVEN WILL CODIFY THE
CURRENT PRACTICE AND EMPOWER THE
DEPARTMENT TO CONTINUE
INVESTIGATING.
AND HANDLING THESE COMPLAINTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
BUT THANK YOU.
SO ANYONE WHO'D LIKE TO BEGIN
SUPPORT.
SEEING NONE IS THERE ANY
OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU THERE IS A
MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND AND A
SECOND.
ANY COMMENTS FROM COMMITTEE.
SING THEN MISS ALL THE MAKE
CLOTHES I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
ABOUT THANK YOU.
THE MOST IT IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS CALL THE ROLL
PLEASE STONE BY STONE AYE
GALLAGHER CHAU.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ.
GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN.
MENTION I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I PETRIE-NORRIS REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT THANK YOU AND
OUR FINAL ITEM IS ITEM TWENTY
ONE A. B. SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN
MS GONZALEZ.
MORNING AT EIGHT AFTERNOON
MISTER CHAIR IT'S STILL MORNING
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
FAIRLY -- SIX YEARS AGO
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANTS GAIN THE
RIGHT TO DRIVER'S LICENSE SO
THEY COULD BE LAW ABIDING
DRIVERS AN EFFORT AIMED AT
PROVIDING US ALL PEACE OF MIND
ON THE ROAD.
NOW FEAR IS UNDERMINING THE AB
SIXTY LICENSE PROGRAM AND IT
SHOULD.
RECENT REPORTS HAVE UNCOVERED
THAT ICE HAS BEEN ACCESSING
STATE RUN DATABASES CONTAINING
INFORMATION ABOUT INDIVIDUALS
WITH LICENSES THAT WERE MADE
AVAILABLE UNDER AB.
SIXTY THIS BILL PROHIBITS
CALIFORNIA LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES FROM MAKING THEIR
DATABASES INCLUDING.
THOSE MAINTAINED BY PRIVATE
VENDORS A BELT AVAILABLE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF IMMIGRATION
ENFORCEMENT.
THIS WOULD NOT APPLIED
INFORMATION WITHIN THOSE
DATABASES ON INDIVIDUALS WITH AN
ACTIVE ARREST WARRANT ONE
FORSMAN AGENCIES WITH ACCESS TO
CLASS ARE.
ALLOWED TO ACCESS CERTAIN
INFORMATION FROM A DRIVER'S
LICENSE OR IDENTIFICATION CARD
RECORDS INCLUDING NAME DATE OF
BIRTH RESIDENTS AND OR MAILING
ADDRESS AND PHOTOS AS WELL.
AS ANY PREVIOUS ARREST
INFORMATION ACCIDENTS IN ANY
LICENSING ACTIONS TAKEN BY THE
DMV THE DMB ASSERTS THAT DOES
NOT RELEASE ANY APPLICANT
DOCUMENTS EXCEPT IN RESPONSE TO
A CRIMINAL SUBPOENA.
A COURT ORDER OR CERTIFICATION
FROM LAW ENFORCEMENT ATTEMPTING
TO AN URGENT HEALTH OR SAFETY
NEED FOR THE RELEASE OF THESE
DOCUMENTS.
THESE FEDERAL IMMIGRATION POLICY
TACTICS ARE CONCERNING.
AB SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN LIMITS
INVOLVEMENT STATE LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES IN FEDERAL
IMMIGRATION ENFORCEMENT IT IS
IMPERATIVE THAT WE PROTECT THE
PRIVACY OF CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS
I UNDERSTAND.
THAT CURRENTLY THE BILL WILL
ONLY PARTIALLY ACHIEVE THE GOAL
TO LIMIT ACCESS TO STATE
DATABASES FOR IMMIGRATION
PURPOSES.
I'M COMMITTED TO WORKING TO
CLOSE LOOPHOLES ALTHOUGH I'M
BECOMING LESS.
ENSURE THAT WE WILL BE ABLE --
TO BUT FOR TODAY TO MOVE THE
SPORT I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU AND THERE ARE
AMENDMENTS IN THE ANALYSIS
YOU'RE TAKING THOSE YES I AM
TAKING THE AMENDMENTS THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
HI -- GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JOSEPH THE GEL OF DIRECTOR
POLICY ADVOCATES WHO WOULD
CHIRLA THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS I'M HERE STRONG
SUPPORTER OF AB. SEVENTEEN FORTY
SEVEN HE IMMIGRATION OF FOR
ENFORCEMENT POSSIBLE FROM HUMAN
ENFORCEMENT TO AUTOMATED
ENFORCEMENT WE SOLD A PEAK WIND
SECURE COMMITTEES -- WAS CREATED
UNDER THE BUSH ADMINISTRATION
DID MORE INTO THE PRIORITY
ENFORCEMENT PROGRAM KNOWN AS BAD --
THESE AUTOMATED SYSTEMS ARE
RESULTING IN THE RUSSIAN BETWEEN --
IMMIGRANT COMMUNITIES AND LAW
ENFORCEMENT AS WELL AS OTHER
STATE AGENCIES -- SINCE THE
ELIMINATION OF AB SIXTY S.
ONLINE IT CHIRLA HAS HER OF
CASES BROUGHT TO OUR ATTENTION
THAT DIEM BE ITS STAFF.
THE DMB IS THAT I'M SORRY OF
INDIVIDUALS WHO HAD NO CRIMINAL
OFFENSE AB JUST IMMIGRATION --
THE PETITION ORDER ON THE RECORD.
ONCE THEY GOT A DRIVER LICENSE --
WE SAW ALL THE EXPERIENCE I WAS
GOING TO THEIR HOUSE THIS IS
EXAMPLE OF OF GABRIELLE WHO WAS
THE REMOVAL PROCEEDINGS A FORMER
RESIDENT OF WEST COVINA WHO
APPLY FOR AB SIXTY DRIVER.
AT USING HIS REAL NAME HE ONLY
HAD A AT THE PETITION ORDER
UNDER HIS RECORD WEEKS LATER
HOMELESS SECURITY INVESTIGATION
UNIT ICE JUST OF HIS HOUSE AND
PICKED HIM UP AND DEPORT HIM --
THIS BILL BILLS ON THE
PROTECTIONS OF AB SIXTY WITHOUT
INTERFERING WITH FEDERAL -- LOSS
AT BUT ALSO MAKE SURE IS THAT
IMMIGRANTS ARE ARE ENSURE TO
APPLY FOR A DRIVER'S LICENSING
INTERACTED AT THE CLOSE A
LOOPHOLE AND FOR ALL THOSE
REASONS WE WILL REQUEST AN APPLE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE
IN SUPPORT.
LEYVA RESERVE YOU AT THE
CALIFORNIA IMMIGRANT POLICY
CENTER AND STRONG SUPPORT.
MY ANGER MAYES FAILURE OF
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
DANIEL SHARP WITH CUT AS IN THE
CENTRAL AMERICAN RESOURCE CENTER
OF CALIFORNIA IN STRONG SUPPORT.
NO I BOTTOM ALL REPRESENTING
CALIFORNIA RURAL LEGAL
ASSISTANCE FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT.
BRIAN -- FOR SECURE JUST AS
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU.
AND WHAT ELSE IN SUPPORT SEEING
NONE IS THERE OPPOSITION.
SEE NONE OF BRING BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
QUESTIONS COMMENTS [inaudible]
MOTION.
SO WE DO HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
WAS WITH ALL TO MAKE CLOTHES.
THANK YOU YOU KNOW WE PASSED A.
B. SIXTY IN ORDER TO MAKE OUR
STREETS SAFER IN -- MANY OF US
WENT OUT INTO OUR COMMUNITIES
AND ENCOURAGE FOLKS TO APPLY FOR
A DRIVER'S LICENSE AND INSURANCE
AS ENSURE THAT WE HAD.
FEWER UNLICENSED DRIVERS
UNINSURED DRIVER CENTER STREET
WE GAVE THEM ASSURANCES THAT THE
DMV OF COURSE WOULD NOT SHARE
THEIR INFORMATION -- EXCEPT THAT
REQUIRED BY LAW IN LITTLE DID WE
KNOW THAT REQUIRED A LOT
INCLUDES CLASS.
LITTLE DID WE KNOW THAT THAT
WOULD BE USED -- BY ICE FOR
DEPORTATION ORDERS -- OR REST TO
LOOK FOLKS UP AND GET THEIR
CURRENT ADDRESS AND PHOTO.
SO NOW WE ARE IN A POSITION TO
TO A ONE BE HONEST WITH THEIR
COMMUNITIES ABOUT THE THE
MISTAKEN ASSURANCES WE GAVE THEM.
BUT TO TO TRY TO STOP THIS
PRACTICE FROM HAPPENING NAY --
RESPECT LAST NIGHT ABOUT.
THANK YOU WE DO HAVE A MOTION A
SECOND MOTIONS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS CALL
THE ROLL PLEASE STONE BYSTONE
AYE GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
GONZALEZ GONZALEZ I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
IN CHINA HI OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
RIGHT WE HAVE QUITE A BIT OF
CATCH UP WORK TO DO SO WE'RE
GONNA ROLL THROUGH THE AGENDA.
STARTING WITH CONSENT CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
SO -- ITEM NUMBER TWO AB TWO
FORTY TWO CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GALLAGHER.
CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER THREE IS ON CALL AB
THREE SEVENTY EIGHT I'M GONNA
LIFT THE CALL [inaudible]
CHAU.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS.
THE BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER FOUR
IS AB FOUR OH THREE IS ON CALL
I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER CHOW CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
I OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
FIVE AB SEVEN TWENTY FOUR IS ON
CALL I'M GONNA LIFT THE CALL
[inaudible]
CHAO [inaudible]
CHIU. TWO I KILEY.
MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN I
OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
SIX CALL THE UP THE MEMBERS
PLEASE AB SEVEN FIFTY EIGHT
CARILLO CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER SEVEN ALREADY PASSED
THAT IS AB EIGHT THIRTEEN
FRAZIER CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
CHIU.
CHIU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE RUBIO IS ON CALL MIDDLE IF
THE CALL.
GALLAGHER.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU.
CHIU I KILEY NUMBER.
MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE
[inaudible]
REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER
NINE AB ELEVEN SIXTY TWO KALRA
HAS ALREADY PASSED CALL THE UP
TO MEMBERS CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY DOWN.
ITEM NUMBER TEN ELEVEN EIGHTY AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR GLORIA HAS
ALREADY PASSED CALL THE OF THE
MEMBERS GALLAGHER.
CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY AYE.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR LEVINE HAS ALREADY
PASSED CALL THE OF THE MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER TWELVE AB THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO BONTA CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GALLAGHER [inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
I REMEMBER THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
FORTY TWO LOCAL THE UPS A MEMBER
GALLAGHER CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY IS ON A CALL OF A
LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN MAIENSCHEIN
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
I REMEMBER FIFTEEN AB FOURTEEN
SEVENTEEN RUBIO IS ON CALL IN A
LIFT THE CALL.
GALLAGHER CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO PETRIE-NORRIS.
PETRIE-NORRIS I REYES.
THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN HOLDEN
CALL THE OF SOME MEMBERS
GALLAGHER.
CHIU. TWO I PETRIE-NORRIS
[inaudible]
PETRIE-NORRIS IRIS.
ITEM NUMBER SEVENTEEN AB SIX
ZERO SEVEN BURNER HORVATH IS ON
CALL IN A LIFT THE CALL CHOW.
CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
KILEY AYE MAIENSCHEIN
MAIENSCHEIN AYE OBERNOLTE
OBERNOLTE AYE RADIUS.
THAT BILL IS OUT ITEM NUMBER.
EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN TWENTY EIGHT
REVERSE ROBERT RIVAS IS ON CALL
AND LIFT THE CALL.
CHOW CHOW I CHU.
CHU AYE KALRA.
KALRA AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE NO
RAMOS.
AND GALLAGHER NO.
THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER NINETEEN A. B.
SIXTEEN SIXTY SEVEN SANTIAGO
CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE KILEY [inaudible]
KILEY AYE.
I REMEMBER TWENTY AB SIXTEEN
SEVENTY TWO BLOOM CALL THE UP TO
MEMBERS.
CHAO.
CHAO AYE CHU.
CHU AYE KILEY.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY ONE AB
SEVENTEEN FORTY SEVEN GONZALEZ
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER.
CHIU.
CHIU I REYES [inaudible]
REYES AYE [inaudible]
GALLAGHER NO.
ITEM NUMBER TWENTY TWO AB
SEVENTEEN FIFTY THREE CARILLO
SOKOLOVA LIFT THE CALL.
CHOW.
CHOW I CHIU. TO AYE KILEY.
KILEY NO MAIENSCHEIN.
MAIENSCHEIN I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
THAT BILL IS OUT RIGHT WILL GO
BACK TO THE LIST ONE MORE TIME.
EVERY BILL HAS PASSED THIS
COMMITTEE SO WE'RE JUST AT
ALLOWING ADD ONS TO THE
DIFFERENT BILLS.
THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR PLEASE GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER I I REMEMBER TO AB
[inaudible]
TWO FORTY TWO GALLAGHER.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB THREE
SEVENTY EIGHT Là M<c.cyan></c>
[inaudible]
REYES [inaudible]
REYES I ITEM NUMBER FOR A BEFORE
THREE KALRA.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE A. B. SEVEN
TWENTY FOUR WEEKS.
REYES [inaudible]
HI.
BUT A NUMBER SIX AB SEVEN FIFTY
EIGHT CARILLO.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER SEVEN AB EIGHT
THIRTEEN FRAZIER GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE.
ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB TEN SEVENTY
THREE RUBIO GALLAGHER.
RAMOS I REYES AYE.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB ELEVEN SIXTY
TWO KALRA.
GOT EVERYBODY ITEM NUMBER TEN A.
B. ELEVEN EIGHTY FOUR GLORIA.
GALLAGHER.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB THIRTEEN
TWENTY FOUR LEVINE GALLAGHER
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER DON'T.
I REMEMBER TWELVE A. B. THIRTEEN
THIRTY TWO BONTA GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO RADIUS [inaudible]
I I'VE NEVER THIRTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN FORTY TWO LOW.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO.
ITEM NUMBER FOURTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN SIXTY TING.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER NO RADIUS.
REYES HI.
I DO NUMBER FIFTEEN A. B.
FOURTEEN SEVENTEEN RUBIO
[inaudible]
GALLAGHER [inaudible]
RAMOS.
REYES SIDE I HAVE OVER SIXTEEN
A. B. FOURTEEN NINETY SEVEN
HOLDEN.
GALLAGHER.
GALLAGHER AYE RADIUS.
REYES AYE BOTTOM NUMBER
SEVENTEEN BURNER HERVE.
RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
I'VE NEVER EIGHTEEN AB SIXTEEN
TWENTY EIGHT REVERSE ROBERT
RIVAS RADIUS.
REYES AYE.
I REMEMBER NINETEEN AB SIXTEEN
SIXTEEN SEVEN SANTIAGO WE HAVE
EVERYBODY ITEM NUMBER TWENTY AB
SIXTEEN SEVENTY TWO BLOOM.
THAT EVERYBODY I REMEMBER TWENTY
ONE WE HAVE EVERYONE ITEM.TWENTY TWO ALL RIGHT WE HAVE
EVERYONE THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE WE ARE ADJOURNED